SOFTWARE. YEAH TEST TEST TEST.
IS THAT RIGHT. FULL SO. SINCE
OUR. I WANNA DO IS AN APPROACH
ON THE GROUND BUT I HAVE. OKAY
DOING NUMBERS AGAIN. MONDAY I
KNOW OPEN OF. YEAH. WORLD HERE.
YEAH YEAH. YEAH VERY GOOD OKAY
THAT. YEAH AND. HEY. AT HOME.
YEAH THERE IS A KIND OF THE. IN
ORDER TO YEAH. NOT ONLY FOR OUR-
MEMBERS AND- AS A MEDICAL.
RAPPING ON. THIS OR. YEAH YEAH-
YEAH BREAK OUT THE GAME SALES
ORGANIZATION OR. OKAY. YEAH WE
CAN'T YEAH. ALL. THAT. YEAH.
YEAH YEAH. RIGHT NOW. YEAH.
YEAH THANKS FOR. STARZ AND- ONE
OF THESE DAYS. MORE. AB.
SO.
THIS IS THE SAME. THE.
THIS.
AND.
PERIOD.
HE. THERE HAS.
OKAY. ALL OF.
TO GEN. THIS BILL.
THE.
SIX ONE. YEAH. FOR SOME.
AFTER. HEY GOOD THANKS FOR
BEING HERE WHEN. IF FEEL LIKE
MAKING SOME COMMENTS. PLAYER UP
I THINK THIS IS A RESTORATION
STRIKE SPENDING. A SURPRISE FOR
REMARKS. THAT'S WHY ALL OF THIS
STARTED IN. AND. IT'S FINE I
MEAN. YOU WANT TO OUTSIDE-
THIRTY TOLD IT YOU'RE GOOD FOR
YOUR DON'T HANG OUT HERE SENATE
YOU WANT TO BE CAPTURED BY THE-
THAT'S WHY OUR NECK AND- JUST A
SOCIALIST IF YOU WANT TO YOU
WANT TO SWAP SEATS WITHOUT GUY
I MEAN EVERYONE. I THINK FOR A-
FOR THE FANATICS. HIRING NOT
PLAY THIS THING. I LIKE TO CALL
THIS A HEARING TO ORDER- GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME'S ED
SHALL ON THE- CHAIR OF THE
PRIVACY CAN MEET IN THE
ASSEMBLY I WANT TO WELCOME ALL
OF YOU TO OUR JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON SHOAL
RECOGNITION BY G. OR F. R. T. I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR.
BEING HERE BEING AT THE-
SPECIAL THANKS TO ALL OUR
PANELISTS- BEING HERE
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
DEVELOPING STORIES SURROUNDING
THE CORONA VIRUS AND I AM TRULY
GRATEFUL. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO- WHO
WILL BE JOINING US ALSO PETER-
THANK OFF. OF THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE WATCHING- BE A LIVE STREAM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTRIBUTION.
AS WE KNOW CALIFORNIA IS TRULY
A FRIEND OF BOTH INNOVATION AND
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES. WHAT WE
DO HERE HAS A PROFOUND EFFECT
ON HOW THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
AND IN THE WORLD ADDRESS
TECHNOLOGY POLICY ISSUES. WE
ARE HERE TO LEARN HOW FOR T.
WORKS HOW COMMERCIAL AND
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES ARE YOU
DOING IT TODAY. THE CHALLENGES
THAT COME WITH THE USE OF OUR
TEA AND THE POTENTIAL ROLE OF
THE STATE GOVERNMENT IN
REGULATING THIS RAPIDLY
EXPANDING FORM OF TECHNOLOGY.
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
USES BIOMETRICS TO MAP FACIAL
FEATURES FROM FOR A- VIDEOS AND
COME EARNERS THE INTO. WITH A
DATABASE OF KNOWN FACES TO HELP
IDENTIFY OR VERIFY THE IDENTITY
OF INDIVIDUALS IN IMAGES. WELL
THIS TECHNOLOGY HAS EXISTED FOR
DECADES ONLY RECENTLY HAS BEGUN
TO PERVADE OUR EVERYDAY LIVES
AT AN EXPONENTIAL RATE. FROM
ASSISTING SMARTPHONE USERS IN
UNLOCKING OF THEIR PHONES TO
ITS USE IN RETAIL STORE THIS
CASINO MOST CONCERTS IN
AIRPORTS FRT SERVES THE PURPOSE
OF IDENTITY THANK PEOPLE FOR A
VARIETY OF. REASONS FOR EXAMPLE
IT CAN ASSIST IN PREVENTING
RETAIL CRIME FIVE MISSING
CHILDREN AND VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. NO SEEN THESE IT
IS THAT CAUSE DETECTABLE
CHANGES IN APPEARANCE
FACILITATING SECURE TRANSACTION
MAKING TRAVEL WILL CONVENE IN
AN ASSISTING LAUNCH. WITH SAFE.
THE LATTER WAS RECENTLY ON LATE
SO EVIDENCE BY THE RECENT USE
OF F. R. T. TO IDENTIFY. THE
SUSPECTED KILLER IN MARYLAND'S
CAPITAL DOES THAT THE MASS
SHOOTING WERE FIVE PEOPLE DIED.
NEVERTHELESS EVEN WITH ALL OF
THE BENEFITS OF F. R. T. CAN
OFF PURSES EIGHTY. COMES WITH
CHALLENGES THAT MERIT OUR
SCRUTINY I FORTIES CAPABILITIES
CREATE THE POSSIBILITY TO
SURVEIL EVERY INDIVIDUAL WHO
ENTERS THE PUBLIC IN AN
ORWELLIAN MATTER. ONE OF THEM
STEP PROMINENT COUPLE TO EIGHT
INVOLVES VIEW A I A COMPANY
RECENTLY PROFILE IN OUR BY THE
WAY BY THE NEW TIME. IN JANUARY
OF TWO TWENTY WHICH HOUSES
TUMBLE DATA MORE THAN THREE AND
FACES COLLECT. FROM THE IN THAT
IN OUR IT WOULD AVAIL TO LOW
VOICE. AROUND HONOR. THE SERVER
AND PRIVACY ABUSES PRESENTED
THIS TO. ARE IN FACT A VERY
ALONG. AND EXCESS THE IF. MAY
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE IT DID NOT
TAKE LONG FOR THAT TO HAPPEN IN
CLEAR OF USE CASE. AND MOST
RECENTLY WE LEARNED THAT BEFORE
IT BECAME A LAW ENFORCEMENT
TOOL OF CLEAR OF USED INVESTORS
CLIENTS AND FRIENDS ALL HAD
ACCESS TO THE LOCATION. OF THE
USED IT TOUGH GILLY AT CLUBS
COOLEY UP BY THE NEW YORK
TIMES. THEY'RE ALSO CREDIBLE
CONCERNS ON THE ACT T. OF F.
PARTIES TUNES AND SOME RACIAL
AND ETHNIC GROUPS. THESE PLEASE
ON. A BY A IN FACE RECOGNITION
ARGERICH BECAUSE OF THESE
CONCERNS THE LEGISLATURE MAY
NEED TO STEP IN AND REGULATE
THE USE OF OUR TV TO MINIMIZE
AND ELIMINATE ANY PRIVACY
CONCERNS BY IS CONCERNED
ANOTHER WELL DOCUMENTED ISSUES.
AS WE STUDY THIS ISSUE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER TO
REMEMBER THAT SIMILAR CONCERNS
HAVE RESULTED IN LOCALITIES
BANNING THE USE OF F. R. T.
MOST NOTABLY THE CITIES OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND ALSO OAKLAND. AND
TO A PULP THE PUBLIC HOWEVER
ATTITUDES REGARDING THE
APPLICATION OF F. R. T. DIFFER
DEPENDING ON THE CONTEXT. A
SURVEY RELEASED BY THE PEW
RESEARCH CENTER IN TWENTY
NINETEEN REVEALED THAT 56% OF
AMERICANS TRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO USE THESE
TECHNOLOGIES RESPONSIBILITY. AS
A TOOL TO ACCESS SECURITY
THREATS IN PUBLIC SPACES WHILE
A SMALL SHARE OF THE PUBLIC
TRUST TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES. 36%
OR ADVERTISERS 18% TO USE
FACIAL RECOGNITION RESPONSIBLY.
NOW THAT ARE FAR TIAS HERE AND
MORE PREVALENT THAN EVER THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND
FULLY WORD STANDS WITHIN THE
CURRENT LAW AFTER ALL EVEN
THOUGH THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT PROTECTION FOR ALL
OF PERSONAL INFORMATION
INCLUDES BIOMETRIC. INFORMATION
TO CCPA DOES NOT SUFFICIENTLY
REGULATE F. R. T. WITH TEN
OTHER STATES INTRODUCING A
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR TO EITHER
REGULATE BAN OR STUDIED FACIAL
RECOGNITION SYSTEMS THE TIME
HAS COME FOR US TO SHAPE THE
FUTURE. OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY IN CALIFORNIA BY
IDENTIFYING ITS PROMISES AND
CHALLENGES AND TO THAT END E.
S. LEGISLATORS MUST ENGAGE WITH
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND A
BALANCE. BETWEEN CONSERVE
SECTION AND BUSINESS INNOVATION
WITH THIS EMERGING TECHNOLOGY.
I'M CONFIDENT THAT OUR ANALYSTS
WILL HELP PROVIDE. ALL OF THIS
THE INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
UNDERSTAND THE TECHNOLOGY AND
WITH THAT INFORMATION WILL TO A
DEVELOPING SUS LUCIEN'S FOR ANY
OF OUR TEA IS TO SWITCH. TO
ADDRESS. I THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
BEING TODAY I AND I LOOK FOR TO
A VERY ROBUST AND INFORMATIVE
OUR DISCUSSION. AND AT THIS
TIME I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
JOINED US TO GIVE OPENING
REMARKS OF DIGITAL DESIRES
STARTING WITH THE- BY STATE-
VICE CHAIR KILEY. WHICH LIKE TO
SAY A FEW WORDS MISS KILEY. I
KNOW BUT I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
A VERY INFORMATIVE HEARING. MR
OBERNOLTE WOULD YOU LIKE TO FAR
I'M VERY GLAD THAT WE'RE HAVING
THIS HEARING TODAY THIS IS A
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
YOU KNOW THESE TECHNOLOGIES
HAVE A TRANSFORMATIVE POWER TO
MAKE SOCIETY BETTER BUT THEY
ALSO HAVE THE POWER TO BE USED
FOR PURPOSES THE DON'T IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE
REPRESENT SO. I THINK IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE THAT WE'RE HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION I THINK THAT WE
ALL COME IN HERE WITH AN OPEN
MIND- INTO- TRYING TO. ACHIEVE
THAT PERFECT BALANCE OF-
ENABLING TOOLS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OTHER AGENCIES ON
THE ONE HAND BUT PROTECTING THE
PRIACY RIGHTS OF THE CITIZENS
WE REPRESENT ON THE OTHER AND
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING
PART OF THE DISCUSSION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AT THIS TIME I
LIKE TO WALK WELCOME OUR FIRST
PANELIST SO MATTHEW TURK
PRESIDENT OF TOYOTA'S
TECHNOLOGICAL INSTITUTE AT
CHICAGO AND ALSO A PROFESSOR
EMERITUS. AT T. S. IS
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER KANNST
COMPUTER SCIENCE WHO WILL SPEAK
TO THE TOPIC HOW FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY WORKS
AND ITS RECENT. ADVANCES
WELCOME. AND PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME FOR THE RECORD- BEFORE YOU
START YES PROPOSAL TURK WELCOME
WELCOME. SO YES I MATTHEW TURK
AND I'M GLAD TO BE HERE THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME APPRECIATE
IT I'VE WORKED IN A FACE
RECOGNITION FOR MANY YEARS
BEGINNING IN THE LATE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES- AND ON AND OFF SINCE
THEN- IN OF ACTUALLY DONE SOME-
LEGISLATIVE CONSULTING ABOUT IT
AS WELL- SO HAVE SOME DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES ON IT. SO I JUST
WANTED TO TALK TO YOU A BIT
ABOUT HOW IT WORKS AND
BASICALLY WHAT IT IS- AND JUST
GIVE SOME GENERAL- BACKGROUND
ABOUT FACE RECOGNITION TO GO
FORWARD WITH SO WHAT IS IT.
BRIEF HISTORY. OF A LITTLE BIT
A THE STATE OF THE ART IN.
RECENT ADVANCES IN CHALLENGES
IN MOVING FORWARD WITH FACE
RECOGNITION. SO I SHOW YOU A
PICTURE ON ON A SCREEN OR
FISCAL PICTURE WHATEVER- YOU
CAN VERY QUICKLY TELL ME. THERE
ARE TWO FACES IN THEIR OR THEIR
NO FACES AND THEIR OR THAT'S MY
BROTHER BILL OR WHATEVER. NO
EFFORT ON YOUR PART TO DECIDE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT YOU TELL ME
WHERE THE FACES HOW LARGE THEY
ARE YOU CAN MAYBE SAY. WHAT THE
SEX OF THE PEOPLE ARE
APPROXIMATE AGES ALL KINDS OF
THINGS ABOUT THIS PEOPLE IN AN
IMAGE- YOU'VE SEEN. THOSE
PEOPLE BEFORE YOU PROBABLY GIVE
THE IDENTITY OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE IMAGE. YOU WOULD HAVE A
LITTLE MORE PROBLEM THOUGH IF
THE PICTURE WAS VERY DARK WERE
FOR FACE WORK. WERE FIFTY IS
WERE UP SO DOWN. STREAM CAN
CURATE. UP PLACES WE SOME IN
THE IN YOUR WAS VERY LOW RESIN
OR PAUL. MAJOR TOM THING THE
PERSON WEARING ON. THIS IS
SCOTT EYES THEIR LOT OF
CHALLENGE TO FACE RECOGNITION
IS SOMETHING THAT WE AS HUMANS
DO VERY EASILY AND QUICKLY YOU
DON'T HAVE TO THINK ABOUT. BUT
IT'S A QUITE A CHALLENGE TO GET
IN THE IN TO DO IT. SO THE GOAL
OF ALL. FACE CAN IS TO. IS OF
THE- MACHINE. GIVE THE CHOICE
THE IDEA. OF THAT. LOS THIS IN
MAY TO DO FOR THOSE OF THINGS
TO ME. SURE TO EXPRESS. IN THIS.
THINGS YOU ABLE TO. WIN FROM.
RECOGNITIONS IT IS IDENTITY WHO
IS THAT PERSON CAN WE TELL WHO
THAT PERSON IS. AND THAT SYSTEM
CAN BE FULLY AUTONOMOUS THEY
CAN MAKE THAT DECISION ITSELF
AND MAYBE DO SOMETHING BASED ON
THAT DECISION- AWARD COULD
ACTUALLY PROVIDE INFORMATION TO
GIVE TO A PERSON. LIKE I HAVE
75% CERTAINTY THAT THISIS
PERCENT. OR IT'S ONE OF THESE
FIVE PEOPLE MOST LIKELY OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND THEN
PEOPLE CAN THEN MAKE DECISIONS-
BASED ON THAT. SO FACE
RECOGNITION IS A PART OF THE
FIELD THAT'S CALLED COMPUTER
VISION SO MAKING COMPUTERS HE-
OR IN SOME CASES AB BETTER THAN
PEOPLE SEE. COMPUTER VISION HAS
A FIFTY SIX YEAR OLD HISTORY.
IT'S USED CURRENTLY IN THINGS
LIKE DRIVER ASSISTANCE
AUTONOMOUS DRIVING PLANETARY
ROVERS INTERPRETING MEDICAL
IMAGERY CLASSIFYING AERIAL
IMAGERY FACTORY FLOOR WELDING
INSPECTION OPTICAL CHARACTER
RECOGNITION ALL KINDS OF
THINGS- AND THIS IS GENERALLY
INTELLIGENCE SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT FACE RECOGNITION SORT OF
A SUB SUB AREA OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. IT'S ALSO
RELATED- AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER TO THIS AREA CALLED
BIOMETRICS. BY METRIX'S
IDENTIFYING PEOPLE STILL ON
THIS TO. OR MORE. OF
PHYSIOLOGICAL AND OR BEHAVIORAL
CHARACTERISTICS SO FINGERPRINTS
I REQUEST RETIN A HAND YOU
MAJORITY VOID. GATE THE WAY YOU
WALK. GEN AS AS A GENERAL
DISCIPLINE HAS A LOT IN COMMON
WITH BIOMETRICS OVERLAPS WITH
BIOMETRIC SPEND BUT CAN BE
QUITE DIFFERENT TIMES TO. SO
HERE'S A SLIDE TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF. OF SOME OF THE MAIN
THINGS IN THE FAMILY OF FACE
PROCESSING TECHNOLOGIES SO ON
THE LEFT COLUMN YOU HAVE A FEW
IMAGES ASSOCIATED WITH FACE
DETECTION THAT IS. OUR THEIR
FACES IN THOSE IMAGES CAN WE
FIND THEM AND IDENTIFY WHERE
THEY ARE IN THE APPROXIMATE
SIZE OF THE FACE AND ALL THAT
AND AS YOU CAN SEE. THAT CAN BE
DONE POTENTIALLY IN A VIDEO
WITH A SINGLE PERSON WITH A FEW
PEOPLE STANDING BROWN OR WITH
MANY DOZENS PEOPLE FAIRLY ACT.
THESE DAYS. THERE'S A OF FACE
MODEL SECOND CALL ON THAT SAYS
GIVEN A FACE. CAN WE BUILD SOME
KIND OF MODEL OF THAT FACE
MAYBE IT'S A TWO DIMENSIONAL OR
THREE DIMENSIONAL MODEL MAY BE
UNDERSTANDS WHERE THE EYES ARE
WHERE THE NOSE IS WHERE THE
MOUTH IS. A CERTAIN PARAMETERS
OF THE FACE IN THE FACIAL
FEATURES SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
BOTTOM VIDEO CLIP YOU CAN SEE A
SNAPSHOT KIND OF FILTER- ON
EACH OF THOSE THREE PEOPLE
THAT'S THAT'S- BEING PUT ON
THEM. CLIP BECAUSE IT'S
MODELING FACE KNOWING WHERE TO
PUT THAT KIND OF THING. THE
THIRD COLUMN IS FACIAL
EXPRESSION ANALYSIS SO- PEOPLE
WORK ON UNDERSTANDING THE FACE
AND MOTIONS OF THE FACE. TO GET
A SENSE OF HOW IS THE FACE
CONFIGURED AT DIFFERENT TIMES
BASED ON DIFFERENT EXPRESSIONS
YOU MIGHT MAKE- HER LEFT
EYEBROW MIGHT BE RAISED.
PERCENT BE SMILING FOR IN EVER.
AND ON THE RIGHTS IS WHAT WE'RE
PRIMARILY HERE TO TALK ABOUT
FACE RECOGNITION AND THE
RELATED SUBSET OF THAT CALL
FACE VERIFICATION. IN THE TOP
RIGHT SOMEONE IS BASICALLY
LOOKING AT THE PHONE TRYING TO
LOG IN AND THE PHONE IS TRYING
TO DETERMINE IS THIS MERRY OR
NOT THAT'S A QUESTION OF
VERIFICATION YES OR NO. ON THE
BOTTOM RIGHT THERE'S AN IMAGE
AND THAT PERSON. WHO'S RED
BOXES AROUND HER FACE SHE COULD
BE ONE OF HUNDREDS DOZENS
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE SO THAT'S
FACE RECOGNITION TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHO OF MANY POSSIBLE
PEOPLE IS THIS PERSON. SO ALL
OF THESE ARE ARE INVOLVED IN
THE FAMILY FACE PROCESSING
ANALOGIES BUT IT'S THE FAR
RIGHT THAT WERE PRIMARILY
CONCERNED WITH BUT MAY USE
ASPECT THE- ALMOST AS WELL. SO
HOW FACE SYSTEMS ACOMPLISH.
AND THAT'S A OF ABLACK AND
WHITE OR COLOR IMAGE- OR MAYBE
A VIDEO WHICH IS JUST A BUNCH
OF IMAGES- MAYBE THIRTY SIXTY
HUNDRED PER SECOND IT COULD BE
MULTI VIEW IMAGERY LIKE TWO OR
MORE CAMERAS MAKING IT SO FACE.
BE A RED IMAGE LOW IN FOR YOUR
NEAR INFRARED IT COULD BE A
DEATH IMAGE FROM VARIOUS
TECHNOLOGIES OF IN DEPTH
INSTEAD OF INTENSITIES AND
OTHERS OR SO COULD BE A
COMBINATION OF THINGS. SO IN
EMERGES IF WE SEE THE TOP LEFT
SO THERE'S A IMAGE OF PEOPLE
HAVE COFFEE. AND THE YELLOW BOX
THERE IS THEN SHOWN TO THE
RIGHT AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THE COMPUTER SEASON THAT YELLOW
BOX THE COMPUTER HAS A BUNCH OF
NUMBERS. NUMBER A REPRESENTING
INTENSITIES AND COLORS IN THAT
PARTICULAR BOX IN THE LARGER
IMAGE. SO THERE THERE'S BASE
RATE FIRST THERE'S THREE
NUMBERS THERE'S- NUMBERS THE
COPPER RGB. THAT LITTLE SEARCH
NUMBER. SHOWING THE VALUE
BEHIND IT OR GREEN AND BLUE THE
AS WELL. SO THOSE THOSE LARGE
LARGE MATRICES OF NUMBERS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS PERHAPS
SEVERAL MILLION NUMBERS ARE
BEING FED INTO A COMPUTER TO
REPRESENT THAT SINGLE IMAGE SO
THE COMPUTERS JOB IS TO TAKE
THAT LARGE ARRAY OF NUMBERS.
AND FIGURE OUT POTENTIALLY IS
THERE A FACE THERE WHO IS THAT
PERSON SO IT IT'S A COMPLICATED
PROBLEM. AND SEE A PERSON'S
FACE AN ARRAY OF NUMBERS AND
PROBABLY YOU CAN EITHER BUT THE
TASK IS TO MAKE A COMPUTER DO
THAT. SO THERE ARE LOTS%
CHALLENGES IN DOING THAT WE
CAN'T JUST TAKE THOSE NUBERS
AND COMPARE TO ANOTHER SET OF
NUMBERS AND SEE IS THAT. OR NOT
THAT JUST DOES NOT WORK IN THE
REASON IS THOSE NUMBERS ARE SO
DEPENDENT ON MANY DIFFERENT
FACTORS ON THE EXPRESSION THE
FACIAL EXPRESSION OF THE
PEOPLE. ON THE WAITING OF THE
ENVIRONMENT ON THEIR HEAD
ORIENTATIONS WHERE THEY'RE
LOOKING. ON ON THEIR AGE ON ON
A CLINICIANS MAYBE SOMEBODY'S
WEARING SUNGLASSES A BASEBALL
CAP- ON THE QUALITY OF THE
IMAGE ON THEIR THEIR HAIR STYLE
THEIR FACIAL. ALL KINDS OF.
GOOD DETERMINING THOSE LARGER.
NUMBERS AND IT'S AWESOME TO
JUST TO MATCH THE NUMBER. SOME
SENSE. SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES- IN TERMS OF
CHANGING EXPRESSION CHANGING
LIGHTING. CHANGING HEAD
ORIENTATION WHERE SOMEONE'S
LOOKING FOR THE RESPECT TO A
CAMERA CHANGING AGE ON ON THE
TOP RIGHT THERE ARE SEVERAL
IMAGES OF THE SAME PERSON OVER
DECADES OF HER LIFE- IN IN
VARIOUS WAYS OF INCLUDING FACES
THESE ALL POSE VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS TO FACE
RECOGNITION AND TO ANY THOUGHT
OF TAKING THAT LARGE LARGE
ARRAY OF NUMBERS. IN MAKING
SOME SENSE OUT OF IT SO THAT'S
KIND OF THE PROBLEM IN A REALLY
REALLY HIGH LEVEL SO INSTEAD OF
TAKING THE IMAGE OF ONE OF
THOSE AND JUST. BRING IT TO HIM
OF ME. PEOPLE KEEP FACE RECKON
SYSTEM THE WHAT'S IMPORTANT IN
EACH OF THOSE IMAGES WHAT'S
REALLY FUNDAMENTALLY PART OF
THAT PERSON'S IDENTITY THAT CAN
BE SHARED WITH OTHER IMAGES OF
THAT PERSON SO HAPPEN WE
REPRESENT THAT PERSON'S FACE
FROM THE DATA. INPUT TO THE
COMPUTER IN THE IMAGE SO WE
WANT TO IGNORE THE CONFOUNDING
FACTORS THE FACIAL EXPRESSIONS
THE LIGHTING THE ORIENTATIONS
ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AND
FOCUS ON THE THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE CORPS
REPRESENTATION THEY'RE GONNA
REPRESENT THE ESSENCE OF
PERSON. ON AND SO IF WE COULD
DO THAT PERFECTLY THEN EVERY
SINGLE PERSON'S FACE- THE EVERY
FACE OF A SINGLE PERSON WOULD
MAP TO A PARTICULAR NUMBER OR
SET OF NUMBERS OR SOME KIND OF
REPRESENTATION. THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN IT'S TOO DIFFICULT WHAT
WE REALLY END UP BEING IS FORM
SOME REPRESENTATION OF ANY OF
THOSE FACES THE MUCH. VERSION
IN ALL MILLION FIRST IT'S A
DOZEN OF ARE FOR HUNDRED OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT THAT
THE IDEAS THAT REPRESENTATION
IS THE ESSENCE OF A PERSON-
TRIES TO BE THE ESSENCE OF THAT
PERSON AND THEN COMPARE THOSE
REPRESENTATIONS. AND SO THAT IS
CLASS FLYING BASES BY COMPARING
REP IS FINE FINDING
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN A
REPRESENTATION YOU JUST
COMPUTED FROM IN IN. AN URGENT
SINCE YOU HAVE STORED OF
VARIOUS THAT YOU COMPUTED
BEFORE. ANYTHING RECALL VERY
SMACK SOME APPLICATIONS OF A
VERY HIGH. APPLICATION ARE
IMPORTANT TO GET RIGHT THEN YOU
WANT A VERY HIGH BAR FOR THAT
SIMILARITY MATCH IF IT'S
SOMETHING NOT SO IMPORTANT
LIKE. RISING THE PHOTOS ON YOUR
PHONE FOR EXAMPLE THEN YOU
MIGHT HAVE A MUCH LOWER BAR OF
WHAT IT TAKES TO BE COUNTED AS
A MATCH. SO THE FIRST ONE OF
AUTOMATIC FACE RECOGNITION
SYSTEMS TO DO THIS KIND OF
THING WAS IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES SO LONG TIME AGO. OF
THE FIRST SYSTEM THAT RELEASE
FROM START TO FINISH WAS A
FULLY AUTOMATED SYSTEM TO DO
FACE RECOGNITION WAS A PHD
THESIS IN JAPAN IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE SO ALSO A LONG
TIME AGO. THAT'S SYSTEM
REQUIRED A FRONTAL VIEW OF A
FACE THAT WOULDN'T WORK ON ANY
OTHER KIND OF USE- IT FOUND
ABOUT TWENTY DIFFERENT FEATURES
ON THE FACE IMAGE WHERE THE
EYES ARE THE WITH OF THE EYES.
THE WITH OF THE LIPS THE WITH
OF THE OF THE MOUTH- NOSTRILS A
BUNCH OF POINTS ON THE FACE.
AND THEN IT TOOK SEVERAL
COMBINATIONS OF THOSE POINTS
DISTANCES RATIOS ANKLES THINGS
LIKE THAT AND CAME UP WITH
SIXTEEN MEASURES SIXTEEN
NUMBERS. THAT WHAT THE
REPRESENTATION OF FACE THE
GOING FROM. SHOULD TO SICK. FOR
A LOT OF DIFFERENT APPROACHES
TO TRY TO DO THIS- AND THE
COMMON THEME WAS LET'S THINK
ABOUT WHAT A FACES AND THINK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN MAKE A
REPRESENTATION THAT WOULD DO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO HERE. NOT A
LOT OF SUCCESS IN IN A REAL
WORLD. AND ACTUALLY SOME PRETTY
WELL KNOWN FAILURES DURING THAT
TIME. AROUND NINETEEN NINETY
THERE ARE SOME APPROACHES THAT-
STARTED TO EXPLORE A FOCUS ON
LEARNING FROM THE DATA INSTEAD
OF. THE HUMAN PROGRAMMERS AND
RESEARCHERS SAYING LET'S TRY TO
THINK HOW TO DO THIS. THE THIS
NEW IDEA WAS LET'S AND DATE A
BUNCH OF FACE IMAGES AND
LABELED FACE IMAGES OF WHO
THESE PEOPLE ARE. BRING THEM TO
IT MACHINE A LET THE COMPUTER
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S IMPORTANT
INSTEAD OF THE P. IN A PROJECT.
TO IMPORTANT. SO THIS IS WHAT'S
THE MACHINE LEARNING APPROACH
TO FACE RECOGNITION TRAINING
SYSTEM. WITH LOTS AND LOTS OF
DATA LABELED FACE IMAGES
TRANTOR REPRESENT THOSE FACE
IMAGES EFFICIENTLY AND WELL.
THE TRAINING CAN TAKE A VERY
LONG TIME WITHIN A TRAINS A
SYSTEM THAT CAN BE RUN VERY
VERY QUICKLY. OKAY SO ABOUT FOR
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS THAT WAS-
WORKED ON MORE AND MORE AND
THEN IN RECENT YEARS THE LAST.
TEN FIFTEEN OR SO YEARS THERE'S
BEEN A REVOLUTION IN THIS AREA
KNOWN AS DEEP LEARNING WHICH IS
PART OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. WHERE MORE DATA
BECAME AVAILABLE MUCH FASTER
MACHINES AVAILABLE AND BETTER.
IS TO CHECK IN THE SYSTEM. SO
BAY. WHAT IS THE THIS WAY OF
LEARNING FROM DATA. OF
INSTRUCTING THE TEAM PEOPLE HAS
VERY. SOON PASSED YEARS AND BY
THE WAY A LOT THAT'S TAKEN
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA IT
UNIVERSITIES ANDBENEATH. SO
THIS IS A SAMPLE. OF AND
VERSION OF. DEEP NEURAL NETWORK
TO DO FACE IN THEIR- SOCIAL
NETWORK- FRIEND TAGGING YOUR
FACE TAGGING AND BASICALLY IT'S
JUST A REPRESENTATION OF WERE
TOO MUCH ABOUT THE DETAILS WEAR
A FACE ON THE LEFT INPUT TO THE
SYSTEM- EITHER ON THE TOP
WRITER TOP BOTTOM THERE JUST TO
FOR TWO DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF
SHOWING THE SAME THING AND IT
GETS SORT OF RUN THROUGH THAT
DEEP NEURAL NETWORK IN AT THE
FAR RIGHT. IS A- SMALL AREA
REPRESENT. ACTION THE HE IS THE
A RELATIVE SMALL OF NO SO THIS
DEEP NETWORK TAKES A LONG TIME
TO TRAIN IT CAN TAKE DAYS TO
TRAIN EVEN A WEEK SOMETIME TO
TRAIN BUT THEN IT CAN BE RUN
ONCE IT'S TRAIN VERY VERY
QUICKLY AND IT TURNS AT THE- I.
DEEP NETWORKS UP. FRONT
PROGRESS GOING FROM THE SIXTEEN
PARAMETERS FROM DECADES AGO TO
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
PARAMETERS THAT ARE LEARNED IN
THIS TRAINING PROCESS THE
CONVENTICLES RECOGNITION VERY
VERY QUICKLY. SO MODERN FACE
RECOGNITION SYSTEMS ARE SOME
VERSION OF THIS KIND OF SYSTEM-
DEEP NEURAL NETWORKS THE
DETECTIVE FACE THE A LINE PROP
AND RE SIZE OF FACE THE
REPRESENTED AT THE END OF THAT
NEURAL NETWORK AND THEY DO SOME
KIND OF CLASSIFICATION. THEY
MAKE ERRORS THEIR ERRORS IN
EACH OF THOSE STEPS- AND
THERE'S ERRORS IN THE TRAINING
BUT THEIR PERFORMANCE HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLE COMPARED TO THE PAST
AND HAS IN SOME CASES SURPASSED
HUMANS AND HUMANS ABILITIES. SO
CURRENT RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT IN FACE RECOGNITION
CONTINUES TO WORK ON DOING THIS
BUT IN. UNSTRUCTURED
ENVIRONMENT SO TO WORK ANYWHERE
IN ANY KIND OF FACE IMAGERY- TO
WORK OVER AS SOMEBODY AGES- TO-
IT DO IT WITH VERY LITTLE
TRAINING DATA. TO DO IT IN A
WAY THAT'S REVOKE HERBAL SO IN
CASE YOUR INFORMATION GETS LOST
OR STOLEN OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT IT WON'T TO BE
NECESSARILY- A TERRIBLE THING.
AND SO THE GRAND CHALLENGE A
FACE RECOGNITION IS TO BUILD
FIX RECOGNITION FICK FACE
RECOGNITION SYSTEMS THAT ARE
ACCURATE ROBUST EASY TO USE
EXTENSIBLE WORKS WELL FOR
EVERYBODY. AND USABLE ONLY IN
WAYS THAT ARE SAFE RESPONSIBLE
ACCESSIBLE AN ETHICAL AND
THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON TODAY. SO
WE'RE VERY QUICK VERSION OF HOW
I SEE FACE RECOGNITION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- FOR THAT
PRESENTATION- BEFORE WE OPEN IT
UP FOR QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO
ALSO WELCOME A COLLEAGUE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF A ROUTE
THREE OF US SO WHO HAS
EXTENSIVE- ENGINEERING
BACKGROUND IS ALL THANK YOU.
FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY SO
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT
UP FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR-
OBERNOLTE OKAY. IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS SO. I HAD A QUESTION
ABOUT THIS LAST SLIDE. THAT
ILLUSTRATES THE WAY THAT THE
DEEP LEARNING IS- IS USED TO
APPLY TO THE DATA SO- IF I
UNDERSTAND IT RIGHT AND I'M NOT
SURE I DO BUT- THEY'RE WITH ME
SO- WE'VE GOT. VARIOUS LEVELS
OF ABSTRACTION THAT WE'RE GOING
THROUGH. WHEN WE'RE GOINGFROM
A FACE. YOU KNOW PICTORIAL
PRESENTATION WITH FACE. UP INTO
OF IF YOU KNOW IT FINAL RESULT
WHICH TO CALL. A START LIMITED
SORT OF COORDINATES THAT YOU
KNOW REPRESENTS YOU KNOW
NUMERICALLY WHAT THE FACES. SO
IN THE CASE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION- IS HUMAN
INTERVENTION USED TO DECIDE
WHAT THOSE LEVELS OF
ABSTRACTION ARE I MEAN WE SAY
OKAY. IN THIS LEVEL WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR YOU KNOW FOR THE OP
ARE IN THE IN THE STATE. OF THE
EYES IN THIS LEVEL WE'RE
TALKING. YOU KNOW SHAPE OF
YEARS OR WHATEVER IT IS. OR IS.
HE THE MACHINE OR- AND- THAT IS
WELL. YEAH SO. THE LATTER THE
MACHINELEARNING IS CONTROL OF
THAT THE FORMER SORT OF HOW
HEALTH PEOPLE USED TO DO
THINGS. AND NOW WE LET THE DATA
DETERMINE. BUT YOU. HAVING SAID
THAT THERE'S STILL THE QUESTION
OF HOW YOU'RE GOING TO BUILD
THIS SYSTEM IN PERSON. SEN WAS
SORT OF SORT OF THE OVAL ARE
ALL OVERALL ARE. SURE IN WHICH
THE LEARNING TAKES PLACE IN
WHICH DATA. TRACK ASSIST. AND
SO THEY SORT OF. SOME ICE. AB
TWO ONE. THE MACHINE IS MAKING
THE DECISIONS IN NOT IT'S NOT A
PERSONAL. IT POINT SAYING
LEARNED THIS VAN AND- THEN
OKAY. SO THEN ASKING THE
QUESTION IN REVERSE I KNOW ONE
OF THE CRITICISMS OF MACHINE
LEARNING ALGORITHMS HAS BEEN
THAT THERE'S NO WAY TO ASK THEM
IT THE ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
TO JUSTIFY HOW IT MADE A
CERTAIN DECISION SO IN OTHER
WORDS YOU SHORT YOU ASKED THE
QUESTION RIVERS AND SORT OF
SHOWING A FACE. AND. WHY DO YOU
THINK THAT THAT IS YOU KNOW
WHAT THE FACES AND I THINK THAT
THIS PARTICULAR RELEVANCE TO
USING THIS TECHNOLOGY IN A LAWN
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
YOU KNOW WHAT- IF WE HAVE TO GO
TO COURT AND WE USE IT IN AN
EVIDENTIARY WAY YOU HAVE TO
HAVE JUSTIFICATION FOR. YOU
KNOW WHY WE THINK THIS IS THE
WAY IT IS SO IS THERE A WAY AS
THEY DON'T OF THE DEEP LEARNING
ALGORITHMS THAT ARE BEING USED
FOR THE SYSTEM IS THERE A WAY
TO CREATE THAT RIVERS
JUSTIFICATION. THERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WORKING ON THAT RIGHT
NOW IT'S A WELL KNOWN CONCERN
AND PROBLEM AND IN FACT THE
GOVERNMENT IS FUNDING PROGRAMS-
CALLED EXPLAINABLE ARTIFICE
ARTIST SO INTELLIGENCE IN
GENERAL TO DO THAT SORT OF
THING- BUT I WOULDN'T SAY THAT
THERE ARE. VERY GOOD TOOLS
RIGHT NOW THAT ACCOMPLISH THAT
IT'S A PEOPLE ARE ON THEIR WAY
WORKING TOWARD THAT END. RIGHT
THANK YOU. I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ON THE SAME LINE.
OBVIOUSLY THE HOW THE DECISION
IS BEING MADE IS DETERMINED BY
THE- TYPE OF OTHER THAN BEING
USED. AND I PRESUME THERE THERE
IS- GOOD AUGER RHYTHMS OUT
THERE AND THERE ARE. A BETTER
ARE YOUR THE OTHER ISMS OUT
THERE OR OR NOT AS GOOD SO. SO
HOW DO HOW DO HOW DOES ONE
DETERMINE. OF YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT TO USE I KNOW IT'S PART OF
IT IS THE DENNIS STANDARD AND
ALL THAT BUT- BUT HOW. HOW CAN
LET'S A LAY PERSON YOU KNOW
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT. A
CERTAIN A PARTICULAR ORDER THEM
OUGHT TO BE USE OR HOW HOW IT
A- LOGARITHM. OUGHT TO BE
JUDGED. FO EXAMPLE. WILL
GENERALLY LAY PERSON IS NOT
GOING TO BE MAKING THAT
DECISION RIGHT LAY PERSON'S
GOING TO BUY AN IPHONE AND-
THEIR SYSTEMS GOING TO LET YOU
IN IT OR NOT RIGHT OR LAY
PERSON'S GOING TO GO TO THE
AIRPORT AND SOMEONE SYSTEM IS
GOING TO. LET THAT PERSON
THROUGH OR NOT- SO IT'S OTHER
PEOPLE WHO WERE PRESUMABLY YOU
KNOW MORE INFORMED AND ABLE TO
TALK TO THE PEOPLE WHO MADE THE
SYSTEMS AND MAKE THOSE CHOICES.
OR OR AT ARE YOU ASKING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT YEAH I
THINK ESSENTIALLY THAT THAT'S
IT. NOW ALL IN LIGHT OF ALL THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU MENTION-
SUED THE QUESTION THAT I HAVE
IS- YOU KNOW IF ART. THE
TECHNOLOGY OUR- THE GOOD. TIME
THE BASE. SAID UP. HOW TO
DEPLOY A- G. R. IN A CELL. R.
IT SO THEN. YOU KNOW. THEN
MAYBE JUST THE PART OF. FIRST
YES WITH VERY. KEEPING MIND
THAT FOR. RECOGNITION IS A LOT
OF THINGS ARE HAS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT KINDS OF APPLICATIONS
SO FOR EXAMPLE. IT TO USE IT
TO- AUTOMATICALLY. CLUSTER
IMAGES ON YOUR LARGE IMAGE
COLLECTION ON YOUR PHONE OR
COMPUTER OR SOMETHING- THAT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE PERFECT IT'S
NOT GONNA HURT TOO MANY PEOPLE
HIGH THINK AT ALL. IF THEIR
MISTAKES IN THEIR- IN FACE
RECOGNITION CAN DO A GREAT JOB
OF THAT RIGHT NOW. OR FOR
EXAMPLE SUGGESTING A FRIEND TO
BE YOU KNOW LABELED IN YOUR
PERSONAL COLLECTION OF IMAGES.
THERE'S NOT TOO MANY RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE KINDS OF
BEHAVIORS. AND SO FACE RECKON
IT FACE RECOGNITION HAS BEEN
USED FOR A LOT FOR A WHILE NOW
FOR THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. IS
IT READY TO BE FULLY AUTOMATIC
TO PULL THE TRIGGER ON THE
DECISION. IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT ON
SOMEBODY'S LIFE. IT DEPENDS THE
SCENARIO. IMAGE CENTER IT
DEPENDS THAT AFFECTS IS THERE.
KIND OF. IF IN THAT CASE. US I.
THINK IT'S A- YES WHEN. THE
SORT OF A- LIKE A TO A- I.
ARMED HEY SIR IS NOW YOUR
MENTION ABOUT THE 30% TO THE-
TO THE EQUATION I WANTED TO TRY
THAT THE OF THE OF THE TWO. NOW
FOR SOMEFACES PART PART OF THE
FACE IS BEING CONCEALED OR
LET'S SEE IF SOMEBODY'S MOVING
THEN ALL THOSE THINGS WILL COME
INTO PLAY I PRESUME. YEAH THE-
QUESTION THAT I HAVE WAS. ARE
YOU LET'S SAY. OUGHT WHAT ABOUT
DIFFERENT CAMERAS LET YOU KNOW.
ARE THERE SITUATIONS WHERE YOU
NEED TO HAVE MORE THAN ONE
CAMERA FOR EXAMPLE. POTENTIALLY
I I'D SAY A MORE SIGNIFICANT
CORE ISSUE OR QUESTION IS JUST
THE IMAGINING ENVIRONMENT OR IS
IT SORT OF A PASSPORT PHOTO
SCENARIO WHERE SOMEONE'S
WALKING IN IT IN FRONT OF A
CAMERA AND LOOKING AT THE
CAMERA AND WAITING FOR THE
PICTURE TO BE TAKEN. OR ARE YOU
LOOKING AT PEOPLE WALKING
DOWNTOWN AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT IF THAT SOMEONE YOU CARE
ABOUT YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S A
MUCH BIGGER DIFFERENTIAL
BETWEEN THOSE TWO SCENARIOS.
THAN MAYBE ONE CAMERA CAMERON
IN MOST SITUATIONS. GOT IT ARE
EIGHT. OKAY THIS CREDIT CARD I
JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
QUESTION BEFORE THAT SO ARE YOU
ARE WE ABLE TO- GENERATE
CONFIDENCE INTERVALS OR- BY YOU
KNOW ADJUSTING THE NUMBER OF
PARAMETERS UP ORDER DOWNWARD-
CALIBRATE THE- YOU KNOW THE
CERTAINTY ARE THE ODDS OF A
FALSE POSITIVE OR A FALSE
NEGATIVE AND THEN ADJUST THAT
ACCORDINGLY DEPENDING ON THE
SITUATION- YES AND NO SO YES
UNCERTAINTIES ARE CALCULATED
WITH MOST COMPOSED OF THE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE USEFUL BUT
THEY'RE NOT ACTUAL- OFFICE.
THEY'RE NOT YOU KNOW-
PROBABILITIES AND SO THEY'RE
USEFUL NUMBERS THEY CAN HELP
YOU UNDERSTAND THE USER OF THE
SYSTEM OR OR THE PERSON LOOKING
AT THE DECISIONS MADE BY THE
SYSTEM HOW COMMON IT WAS THAT
DECISION I NEED I WILL CHOOSE A
OR LIKE A BAT OF THERE'S NO
pTHOSE UNCERTAINTIES. I'M
THINKING OF KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE
A DNA ACT OR SOMETHING THIS AS
THEIR AND WANTED BILLION JAN
THAT THIS IS WRONG I COULD
SIMILAR. STATEMENTS BE MADE.
YES I DON'T KNOW HOW. PRECISE
SUCH STATEMENTS CAN BE MADE
TODAY BUT I BELIEVE IT'S MOVING
THAT DIRECTION BE ABLE TO MAKE
QUITE PRECISE STATEMENTS ABOUT
THAT BUT EVEN EVEN IF THE DNA
THERE'S A THERE'S A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF UNCERTAINTY WITH
THOSE RIGHT SO WITH ALL OF FROM
THERE WOULD BE. I THINK IF I
COULD GO BACK OUT I THINK THAT
WAS THE QUESTION KIND OF THE
QUESTION THAT I WAS GOING TO.
ASK AND THAT IS THE ERROR. I
MEAN IS THERE A THRESHOLD IS A-
HE ARE- INDICATED THAT. PEOPLE
CAN USE TO SAIL. THIS PROGRAM
IS LET'S SAY 5% ERROR RATE IN.
YOU KNOW IS THERE SOMETHING
THAT THAT WE CAN USE. OUR
FAMILY NAME IS FOR THOSE
PERSPECTIVE. AGAIN I SEE THAT
MORE AS SOMEONE WHO'S
IMPLEMENTING A SYSTEM FOR THEIR
COMPANY YOUR GOVERNOR WHATEVER
TO LOOK AT THOSE KINDS OF
NUMBERS FOR THE VENDORS YOU
MIGHT CONSIDER. YOU KNOW
PURCHASING A SYSTEM FROM I
DON'T SEE HOW- LAYPERSON
CONSUMER WILL NECESSARILY MAKE
USE OF THOSE KINDS OF NUMBERS I
WAS ONE OF THE TWENTY PLUS
LEGISLATORS ARE MISIDENTIFIED
BY PROGRAM BY WAY OF FORTY
PROGRAM. AND SUBSEQUENT TO THAT
I THINK I SOMEBODY MENTIONED TO
ME THAT. IF DE UM. IF THE
THRESHOLD WAS ADJUSTED PROPERLY
ON MEANING THAT LET'S SEE IF
THE ERROR RATE WAS SALAS AND
FIVE PERCENT. THEN THE YOU KNOW
I WOULD BEEN OF PROPERLY
IDENTIFIED BY THE PROGRAM- IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT'S KIND OF
COMMON IN IN THE INDUSTRY- YES-
AND AN MEANS TWO THINGS TO SAY
THAT THAT ERROR RATE. GOES DOWN
EVERY YEAR SO IN A WITH A AS OF
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE THIS IT GETS
BETTER ALL THE TIME- AND- YES
YOU IF. ARE PROPERLY LOOKING AT
NOT ONLY THE ANSWER BUT ALSO
THE UNCERTAINTY MEASURE OR YOU
KNOW OTHER INFORMATION
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT- THERE
THERE'S MORE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS. THAN SOME OF THESE
PUBLIC TEST MIGHT ACTUALLY LEAD
YOU TO BELIEVE. GOT IT OKAY
OTHER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. ON
ALL RIGHT THEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION WE
MAY HAVE MORE QUESTIONS LATER
ON SO- SO. AT THIS TIME I'D
LIKE TO BRING UP THE NEXT PANEL.
OUR WHO WILL DISCUSS THE TOPIC
OF CURRENT AND FUTURE
APPLICATIONS OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY IN
GOVERNMENT AND COMMERCIAL
SETTINGS AND- WE HOW FOR THIS
PANEL A MISTER JAKE PARKER WHO
IS SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AT THE
SECURITY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
AND DARRYL LUCIEN A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE
LEAGUE A WELCOME AND PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAMES FOR THE RECORD.
THANK YOU SIR- JAKE PARKER WITH
SECURITY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION-
CHAIRMAN SHALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY- STIRRED INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS OVER ONE
THOUSAND COMPANIES PROVIDING
SECURITY PRODUCTS IN THE UNITED
STATES. CUTTING HUNDRED FORTY
TWO HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR MEMBERS INCLUDE
MANY DEVELOPERS OFFICIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY AND
CALIFORNIA'S ACTUALLY HOME TO
SEVERAL LEADERS IN THIS FIELD I
ACTUALLY WANTED TO- BEFORE
PROCEEDING OF THE QUESTION
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
LAST SEGMENT- SO THE MAYBE HELP
LIKE I COULD EXPLAIN SO- EVEN A
SIMPLER WAITED TO UNDERSTAND
FISH RECOGNITION IS BASICALLY.
COME UP PHOTO COMPARISON TOOL
SO YOU'VE GOT ONE PHOTO YOU'RE
COMPARING IT WITH ONE OR MANY
MORE OTHER PHOTOS. THE JOB DID
THE PART THAT IS THAT THE
MACHINE DOES IS CREATE A
SIMILARITY SCORE RATES THAT FOR
OTHER PHOTO OR OTHER PHOTOS ON
HOUSE SOMEWHERE THEY ARE TOO.
THE PHOTO YOU'RE COMPARING
AGAINST IN SO- BUT AS YOU
MENTIONED- GERMAN AT THE-
THRESHOLD IS SAT. OVER WHICH
THE SYSTEM MAKES A- POTENTIAL
MATCH DETERMINATION OR
MASTURBATION UNDER WHICH IT
DOESN'T. SET THRESHOLD IS
ABSOLUTELY- ADJUSTED BY HUMAN
SO EITHER THE OPERATOR WHERE
THE DEVELOPER WAS SAID IT AND
THAT IS GOING TO DEPEND ON THE
PURPOSE. SO JUST TO TWO
EXAMPLES ONE IF THE PURPOSE OF
THE SYSTEM IS TO HELP SPEED
ENTRIES LIKE SAY TO UP TO A
VENUE- YOU WANT TO SET IT SO
YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE A LOT OF
FALSE- FALSE. THIS IS MISS
RATES SO YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
LINE'S ANY LONG SOMEONE SOMEONE
MAYBE IT'S POSITIVE SOMEONE IS
A TICKET THAT'S KIND OF
UNLIKELY TO HAPPEN THAT'S NOT
AS MUCH OF A CONCERN. ON THE
FLIP SIDE. SHOW LIKE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATIONS YOU
WANT TO SET THAT THRESHOLD
REALLY HIGH- SO YOU MAKE SURE
YOU'RE- GONNA MAKE SURE THE
ACTRESSES AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
I SO APPRECIATE MR TRICKS-
PRESENTATION ALSO AS YOU KNOW-
MISTER GROWTH- FROM THIS WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE TODAY AND
COULDN'T ATTEND- WE WOULD HAVE
DEFINITELY BENEFITED FROM HIS-
OVERVIEW OF NEXT- EVALUATION OF
FACE RECOGNITION WHICH IS GOING
ON FOR TWENTY YEARS. IT'S
DEFINITELY A WORLD STANDARD ON
EVALUATING ACCURACY OF THE OF
THE ALGORITHMS. ARE BASICALLY
IN LOOKING AT THIS WORK THE
BOTTOM LINE FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT MODERN
MODERN FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY IS HIGHLY ACCURATE-
N'EST IS FOUND AT THE FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE TEST IS
NOW MORE THAN TWENTY TIMES IS
ACCURATE. AND JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO AND RETRIEVING A MATCHING
PHOTO FROM DATABASE. IS
SEPTEMBER REPORT FOUND CLOSE TO
PERFECT PERFORMANCE BY HIGH
QUALITY ALGORITHMS WITNESS
RATES AVERAGING JUST POINT ONE
PERCENT. THIS REACHES THE
ACCURACY OF AUTOMATED
FINGERPRINT COMPARISON WHICH IS
AS THE GOLD STANDARD FOR
IDENTIFICATION. ON THE ISSUE OF
DEMOGRAPHIC EFFECTS ARE YOU
KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING
MORE ABOUT- THIS HEARING. THE
CONTEXT IS CRITICAL BECAUSE-
IMAGE QUALITY ISSUES MANY OF
WHICH WERE WORKED ARE SHOWN IN
THE LAST PRESENTATION. HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGED AFTER
SEEING NOT- DEMOGRAPHIC
EFFECTS. A HOWEVER- THE OUR
VIEW IS THAT THE REASON THIS
DEMOGRAPHIC REPORT THAT CAME
OUT IN DECEMBER. PROVIDES A
CONFERENCE OF ANSWER TO MANY OF
OUR MOST PRESSING QUESTIONS
ABOUT FACIAL RECOGNITION
ACCURACY. I AND RELATED
CONCERNS ABOUT BIAS. IT FOUND
THE HIGHEST PERFORMING
ALGORITHMS HAD UNDETECTABLE
DIFFERENCES IN PERFORMANCE
ACROSS DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS.
WHILE MOST OTHERS PERFORMED
MORE CONSISTENTLY THAN AND
WIDELY REPORTED IN THE MEDIA
AND ALSO IN SEVERAL NON
SCIENTIFIC TESTS. WELL SOME
COMMENTARY SPOKES ON THE VERY
LOWEST PERFORMING ALGORITHMS
IT'S IMPORTANT POINT OUT THAT
KEY GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS ARE
ALREADY USING SO THE HIGHEST
PERFORMING TECHNOLOGY DEFIED.
WITH ACCURACY RATES WELL ABOVE
99% AN UNDETECTABLE FALSE
POSITIVE PERFORMANCE ACROSS
DEMOGRAPHICS EVEN WHEN TESTED
AGAINST GALLERIES OF UP TO
TWELVE MILLION. IMAGES SO TO
FULLY COMPREHEND THE BENEFITS
THIS TECHNOLOGY YOU HAVE TO
CONSIDER WHETHER THE USE OF IT.
WHICH IS TYPICALLY TO ASSIST
NOT REPLACE HUMAN ANALYSIS AND
DECISION MAKING. IS BETTER THAN
THE ALTERNATIVE OF HUMAN
RECOGNITION ONLY. HEAR THE
EVIDENCE IS INDISPUTABLE AS
DOCUMENT IN THIS STUDY JUST TWO
YEARS AGO AND ELSEWHERE.
AUTOMATED FACIAL RECOGNITION
ALONG WITH EVEN ANALYSIS IS
MORE ACCURATE AND LESS BIASED
THAN HUMAN RECOGNITION ALONE.
YOU'VE LIKELY HEARD SOME
PERSPECTIVES THE CALL FOR
SEVERELY RESTRICTING OR EVEN
BANNING THE TECHNOLOGY. THE KEY
QUESTION HERE IS WHETHER IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO LIMIT PROCESSES
TO HUMAN CAPABILITY ALONE WHEN
THIS ADVANCED TOOLS AVAILABLE.
SPECIAL WERE IMPACTS SAFETY AND
SECURITY. IN THE BENEFITS ARE
NOT IT POTENTIAL OR
HYPOTHETICAL THEY ARE PROVEN
AND GROWING. THE PUBLIC SECTOR
FOR EXAMPLE HAS BEEN USED FOR
OVER A DECADE IMPROVE THE SPEED
ACCURACY CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS. AND ANY PROCESS
WORKERS POTENTIAL HIGH
CONSEQUENCE OUTCOMES THE
TECHNOLOGY SERVES ONLY AS A
TOOL TO ASSIST PERSONNEL. THIS
MAY EXPLAIN US LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S DECADE PLUS
OPERATING HISTORY IN MANY
THOUSANDS OF INSTANCES WITHOUT
ANY CONFIRMED EXAMPLE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY RESULTING IN A
MISTAKEN ARRESTOR IN PRISON AND-
ONE SUCCESS STORY RESCUING.
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS IN APRIL
LAST YEAR A CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS SAW SOCIAL
MEDIA POST ABOUT A MISSING
CHILD. THE OFFICER USED SPECIAL
RECOGNITION TOOL CALLED
SPOTLIGHT RETURNING A LIST OF
ONLINE SIX ADS FEATURING THE
GIRL. ACCORDING TO A STORY IN
WIRED MAGAZINE THE GIRL HAD
BEEN SOLD FOR WEEKS. BUT THE
OFFICERS ACTIONS HELP FOR- A
PROCESS TO RECOVER HER IMPROVED
FROM TRAUMA. SHE WAS JUST ONE
OF FIFTEEN THOUSAND VICTIMS
RESCUED USING THIS TOOL JUST
LAST COUPLE YEARS. IN AUGUST
LAST YEAR THE NYPD RESPONDED
WITH A MAN SPARK TERROR BY
LEADING RICE COOKERS AROUND
SUBWAY STATION. YEAH USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY TO
IDENTIFY HIM- FROM THEIR REST
DATABASE WITHIN ONE HOUR.
OFFICIALS LATER QUOTED SAYING
TO NOT USE THIS TECHNOLOGY
WOULD BE NEGLIGENT. IN MAY LAST
YEAR THREE MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY WERE SHOT AND KILLED
BY A MAN AT A HOME IN WAYNE
COUNTY MICHIGAN. DETROIT POLICE
DEPARTMENT USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION OTHER METHODS TO
HELP IDENTIFY THE SUSPECT BASED
ON SECURITY FOOTAGE FROM NEARBY
GAS STATION. HE'S ALSO BEEN
USED TO SOLVE COLD CASES. AFTER
SIXTEEN YEAR MANHUNT A MAN WAS
APPREHENDED IN OREGON IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WAS. ACCUSEDOF
SEXUALLY ASSAULTING A MINOR.
AND USING THE TECHNOLOGY THE
FBI WAS ABLE TO IDENTIFY THE
SUSPECT AFTER YOU APPLY FOR US
PASSPORT. THE TECHNOLOGY ALSO
PLAYS A KEY ROLE IN DETECTING
FRAUD IN STATE PROGRAMS WHICH
ENABLE THE JEDI STUFF THAT'S
USED FOR ALL SORTS OF CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
THE KANSAS DEPARTMENT MOTOR
VEHICLES FISHER A CONDITION
SYSTEM SPARKED AN INVESTIGATION
LEADING THE LARGEST FORCED
LABOR TRAFFICKING CASE AND
UNITED STATES. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALONE. NEW YORK'S DMB
FAN MORE THAN NINE THOUSAND
CASES INVOLVING DRIVERS WITH
RECORDS UNDER MORE THAN ONE
IDENTITY. SO THERE ALSO MANY
NON LAW ENFORCEMENT USES THAT
ARE INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT
PUBLIC SECTOR LIKE SECURE
AUTHENTICATION ACCESS CONTROL
FOR SENSITIVE AREAS OF
BUILDINGS AND USES PARTY
SECURITY SYSTEMS TO PROTECT
EMPLOYEES AND VISITORS. TO
GOVERNMENT FACILITIES. MANY
SCHOOLS AND UNIVERSITIES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED OR ARE CONSIDERING
THE TECHNOLOGY TO PROTECT
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS BY
NOTIFYING THEM. WHEN IN A REAL
PERSON OF INTEREST ARISES
FACILITY SUCH AS A SEX OFFENDER
SOMEONE WHO'S MADE VIOLENT
THREATS. IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
SWITCHING GEARS BUT RECOGNITION
IS PROVIDING ENORMOUS BENEFITS
PROVIDING INDIVIDUALS AN OPTION
TO SECURELY AND CONVENIENTLY
PROVE THEIR IDENTITY IN ORDER
TO INTERVENE YOU. BOARD A PLANE
PERFORMING VOTE ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS AND ACCESS
PERSONALIZED EXPERIENCES. ALL
WHILE REDUCING THE NEED TO SHOW
DOCUMENTS CONTAINING PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION OR
OTHERWISE AND EXPOSE THEM TO
POTENTIAL HUMAN VICE. NEWPORT'S
ACCOUNTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
FROM SAN JOSE TO ATLANTA
TECHNOLOGIES GIVING PASTORS THE
OPTION MORE QUICKLY. PASS FROM
THE CURBSIDE AIRPLANE SEAT.
SPECIFIC TO THE SECURITY
INDUSTRY IS ALSO ENABLING
BUSINESSES TO BETTER PROTECT
THEIR EMPLOYEES CUSTOMERS AND
PROPERTY. OFFICIAL RECOGNITION
COULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SECURITY FOR ACCESS CONTROL TO
PUT ARGUMENT OTHER CREDENTIALS
SUCH AS KEYS ARE CARDS THESE
CAN BE SHARED SOLENT STONER
SIMPLY LOST- BIOMETRIC ENTRY
SYSTEMS CAN ALSO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL CONVENIENCE
REGISTERED USERS OR SING US A
LARGE COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS.
WHEN IT WAS ARGUES WITH
TURNSTILES FOR EMPLOYEES
AUTHORIZED- TO ACCESS THE
BUILDING AND ITS COMBAT
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE SPEED
OF ENTRY HAS ELIMINATES
FUMBLING FOR CREDENTIALS.
ALLEN'S OF HIGH SECURITY NEEDS
CAN USE THE PHOTOGRAPH ALONG
WITH OTHER CREDENTIAL TO EASILY
ADD MULTI FACTOR AUTHENTICATION.
THE TECHNOLOGY ALSO IVES
BUSINESSES THE ABILITY TO ALERT
STAFF TO POTENTIAL DANGER
SITUATION WHERE A PERSON WITH A
RESTRAINING ORDER OR A
DISGRUNTLED FORMER EMPLOYEE FOR
EXAMPLE INTENDS TO ENTER.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE THE
TECHNOLOGIES BEING USED TO
ADDRESS SKYROCKETING ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME CALIFORNIA
UNDERSTATES. SOME STORES USING
FACIAL RECOGNITION ENTRY POINTS
TO ELLER CUSTOMER SERVICE STAFF
TO GREET KNOWN THIEVES WHEN
THEY ENTER PROPERTY AND OFFER
THEM CUSTOMER SERVICE. THIS
MODERN DAY QUICK A QUICK WANTED
POSTING SHOPLIFTERS PRINTED
PHOTO CAN HELP DETER CRIME
WITHOUT THE INVOLVEMENT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IN ONE CASE STORES
USING THIS STRATEGY OR FINDING
THAT OVER HALF THE INDIVIDUALS
AND ROLLED STOP SHOPLIFTING IN
COVER STORES AFTER TWO THREE
VISITS 90% STOP AFTER EIGHT TO
TEN VISITS PRODUCT SHRINKAGE IT
IS REDUCED BY 3270% MANY
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ARE
USING THE TECHNOLOGY TO PROTECT
OUR CUSTOMERS AGAINST IDENTITY
THEFT AND FRAUD. SOMEONE
ATTEMPTS TO OPEN A LINE OF
CREDIT USING A FACE PIC
DRIVER'S LICENSE WITH A
CUSTOMER'S REAL INFORMATION.
THIS IS DETECTED IF THE TELLER
TAKES HER PART WAS PHOTOS PARTY
APPLICATION PROCESS JUST
CHECKED AGAINST THE REAL
INFORMATION. IT'S ALSO
INCREASINGLY POURED TO THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER. THE
REGISTRATION AND MENTIONED
INNOCENT MISSION TO A VENUE A
RECOGNITION IN V. I. P.
PROGRAMS OR OTHERWISE THE
PERSONALIZED. CUSTOMER SERVICE.
SO IN IN HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
IT'S ALSO USED IN A VARIETY OF
WAYS- IN THIS IS BECOMING
INCREASING PORT TO HELP PROTECT
THE SAFETY AND- PATIENTS AND
STAFF. AND ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
AS- CONCERNS ABOUT COVERT
NINETEEN MOUNT. THIS INCLUDES
PROVIDING TOUCH WAS ACCESS IT
ONLY TRAINING AUTHORIZED
PERSONNEL CAN ENTER SENSITIVE
AREAS LIKE CLEAN ROOMS IN ORDER
TO ELIMINATE THE RISK OF
CONTAMINATION. FISHER
RECOGNITION OTHER BIOMETRIC
TECHNOLOGIES TECHNOLOGIES CAN
ALSO PROVIDE A WAY TO
IDENTIFIED UNCONSCIOUS PATIENTS
IN NEED OF EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE.
SEVERAL IS REASONS IT'S CLEAR
TO US TECHNOLOGY MAKES OUR
CITIZENS SAFER BRINGS VALUES
FOR LIVES WHEN IT'S USED
EFFECTIVELY AND RESPONSIBLY. WE
BELIEVE IN A BROAD RANGE OF
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR
APPLICATIONS TRANSPARENCY
SHOULD BE THE GOVERNING
PRINCIPLE TO ENSURE RESPONSIBLE
USE WITHOUT UNREASONABLY
RESTRICTING THIS ESSENTIAL
TECHNOLOGY TOOL. SO TELL ME OF
ANY POLICY IN THIS AREA MUST
TAKE A RISK BASS AND USED USE
BASED SPECIFIC APPROACH.
BECAUSE THE USES ARE SO VARIED
AND BECAUSE THESE PRESENT
EXTREMELY VERY PRIVACY
CONSIDERATIONS WHICH DEPEND ON
THE APPLICATION. ANY INVOLVED
ANY VERIFICATION ORDERS ALREADY
CONSENT OR EXISTING REQUIREMENT
TO PROVE ONE'S IDENTITY IN
THESE HAVE LITTLE IMPACT ON
PRIVACY OR CIVIL LIBERTIES. IN
OTHER APPLICATIONS A PROPERTY
OWNER SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
SECURE THE PREMISES USING
TECHNOLOGY BUT OTHERWISE SHOULD
OBTAIN CONSENT BEFORE OFFERING
CONVENIENCE OUR COMMERCIAL
BENEFITS. THE APPROACH NEEDS TO
BE THOUGHTFUL AND THOROUGH. I
RUSHED IMPLEMENT ONE SIZE FITS
ALL RULES COULD RESULT IN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THE
FULL RANGE OF THESE USES ARE
NOT CONSIDERED. SHOULD ALSO BE
A PRICKLY FLEXIBLE TAILORED TO
ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC PRIVACY
RISKS THAT A SPECIFIC
APPLICATION MAY POSE. WELL ANY
TECHNOLOGY HAS THE POTENTIAL
FOR MISUSE WE CERTAINLY BELIEVE
THE FACIAL RECOGNITION SHOULD
ONLY BE USED FOR PURPOSES THAT
ARE ETHICAL NON DISCRIMINATORY
AND ARE CONSISTENT WITH OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL FRAMEWORK. OF
LAWS AND REGULATIONS. THAT'S
WHY IT'S ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
FOR TRANSPARENCY TO ACCOMPANY
GOVERNMENT APPLICATIONS.
PRACTICAL MEASURES IN THIS AREA
INCLUDE POSTING CLEAR USE
POLICIES PROVIDING PRIVACY
IMPACT ASSESSMENTS IMPLEMENTING%
PROCUREMENT REQUIREMENTS FOR
TOP PERFORMING TECHNOLOGIES AS
WE SEE THERE'S QUITE A RANGE OF
DIFFERENCES IN HOW THEY PERFORM.
ANY OTHER HAND WIDE REACHING
RESTRICTIONS A SINGLE OUT JUST
ONE TECHNOLOGY TOOL WILSON WE
FAIL TO ADDRESS IMPORTANT
UNDERLYING SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
OTHER CONCERNS ARE THE ROOT OF
ANY OF OFFICIAL RECOGNITION
DEBATES. AS THE COMMITTEE
EXAMINE THESE ISSUES WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH A WIDE RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS. IN ON BEHALF OF
SIA APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE OUR COLLECTIVE INPUT
FROM THE INDUSTRY AND DO MY
BEST TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
NEXT NEXT WHEN IS PLEASE. YEAH
AFTERNOONS TO CHAIRMAN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE AND THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES. FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME STERILE LUCIEN I REPRESENT
THE TEN THOUSAND MEN AND WOMEN
OF THE LA POLICE PROTECTIVE
LEAGUE. THIS IS THE THIRD
LARGEST POLICE UNION IN THE
COUNTRY IN THE LARGEST HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE USES OF FACIAL RATE
FAKEL FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY IN GOVERNMENT
SETTING SO I WILL FOCUS ON
THESE USES AND THEN. DELVE INTO
SOME OF THE MYTHS AND
PERCEPTIONS- THAT ARE. FAIRLY
PREVALENT WITH THE USE OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY. WHEN YOU LOOK AT.
HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
USE TO IDENTIFY INDIVIDUALS
DEPARTMENTS WOULD TAKE DAYS
WEEKS OR LONGER- TO MANUALLY
SEARCH THROUGH A DATABASE OF
SOMETIMES IS MINIS THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND BOOKING
PHOTOS. PUT UP WANTED POSTERS
SAN MEDIAN NOTICES TO TRY AND
IDENTIFY SUSPECTS. WE'VE USE
TOOLS LIKE POLICE SKETCH
ARTIST- TO SKETCH. BASED ON
DESCRIPTIONS THAT WERE GIVEN BY
I WITNESSES IN VICTIMS
SOMETIMES EVEN WHEN THESE. I
WITNESSES ARE VICTIMS WERE WERE
STILL IN A STATE OF SHOCK
TRAUMA DISTRESS. OR CONFUSION-
AND IN SOME INSTANCES. AS FAR
AS I UNDERSTAND NOT LAPD BUT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY- DEPARTMENT
OF HIRED CRIME FIGHTING
PSYCHICS- IN IN AND I DON'T I
DON'T MEAN ANY OFFENSE TO THESE
PROFESSIONALS THAT HAVE SERVED
OUR PROFESSION BUT- THEY ARE
PART OF THE STORY. OF WHY
POLICE COMMUNITY RELATIONS
PERHAPS MAY HAVE NOT ALWAYS
BEEN AS POSITIVE. WHEN WE LOOK
AT I WITNESS CALLS WHEN WE LOOK
IN AN INSTANT WHEN I WITNESS
CALLS IN A DESCRIPTION OF A
PERPETRATOR LET'S JUST SAY
BLACK SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD FIVE
NINE BLUE JEANS BLACK SHOES
TATTOO ON THE ARM IN THE NECK-
AND YOU KNOW THE OFFICERS
PATROLLING LAPD'S SEVENTY
SEVENTH DIVISION- WHICH FOR
THOSE OF YOU DON'T KNOW. WOULD
BE CONSIDERED- THE OLD SOUTH
CENTRAL BETTER YET. WITH OUR
DISTINGUISHED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FROM THE EAST VALLEY LET'S JUST
SAY IT'S FOOTHILL DIVISION ARE
AND WILL CHANGE BLACK TO LATINO.
EVERY OTHER KID ON THE BLOCK IS
A POTENTIAL SUSPECT. AND WHEN
YOU HAVE TOO MANY POTENTIAL
SUSPECTS. SUSPECTS EXCUSE ME
COMMUNITIES BEGIN TO FEEL OVER
POLICED EVEN IF THE POLICE WORK
IS WELL INTENTIONED- AND IN
RESPONSE TO LEGITIMATE THREATS
NOW FORTUNATELY WE'VE BEEN IN
AND A TIME OF TRANSITION FOR A
LITTLE WHILE. LAPD IS A PART OF
A CONSORTIUM THAT IS THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY REGIONAL
IDENTIFICATION SYSTEM AND I
KNOW THERE'S A REPRESENTATIVE
HERE IN THE OFFICE AUDIENCE
FROM WHAT IS COMMONLY REFERRED
TO LACK CHRIS. IN THE AUDIENCE
TODAY. BUT LACK CHRIS IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
IDENTIFICATION OF ALL SUSPECTS
ARRESTED IN THE COUNTY. IT'S A
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP
INCLUDES- TOTAL SIXTY FOUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOCI. NOT
ASSOCIATION EXCUSE ME AGENCIES
IN THE COUNTY. LACK CHRIS
PROVIDES FACIAL RECOGNITION
SEARCH CAPABILITIES TO THESE
AGENCIES UPON REQUEST INCLUDING
LAPD. WE AND WHEN I SAY WE I
MEAN INCLUDE LACK OR SEEN HERE.
WE DO NOT USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION IN REAL TIME WE
UTILIZE TECHNOLOGY AFTER THE
FACT TO GENERATE ACCURATE
INVESTIGATIVE LEADS. NO JUDGE
WILL GIVE US A WARRANT NO D. A.
R. WILL BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
PROBABLE CAUSE TO ARREST
SOMEONE SOLELY ON THE GROUNDS
OF A POSSIBLE FACIAL
RECOGNITION MATCH. LAW
ENFORCEMENT USE OF THIS FACIAL
RECOGNITION IN TECH LA COUNTY.
IS LIMITED TO SEARCHES OF
BOOKING PHOTOS IN THE CRIMINAL
DATABASES THAT WE'RE REQUIRED
TO MAINTAIN A IN ACCORDANCE
WITH EXISTING LAW- AND AGAIN I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT IS FAR
AS LA COUNTY IS CONCERNED IN
PREDOMINATELY ACROSS STATE
ALTHOUGH I SUPPOSE THERE ARE
SOME EXCEPTIONS. WE RUN FACIAL
RECOGNITION SEARCHES ON BOOKING
DATA CONTAINED IN CRIMINAL
OFFENDER REGISTRIES- AS I
UNDERSTAND IT WE DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS OR CONNECTIVE ITTY TO
DMV RECORDS- AND LACK CHRIS
DOES NOT UTILIZE SOCIAL MEDIA
DATABASES OR OTHER OPEN SOURCE
PLATFORMS. THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF
THE CRIMINAL DATABASES THAT
REQUIRED TO MAINTAIN. ARM WE
ONLY REALLY MATCHED. TO
CRIMINAL DATABASE BOOKING
PHOTOS AT THE PRESENT TIME
BECAUSE THE IDENTITIES OF THE
IN THE INDIVIDUALS ARE KNOWN
WITH BIOMETRICS THAT ARE
CAPTURED AT THE TIME OF BOOKING
AND SORT OF MARY TO THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION SO WE CAN
MATCH AGAIN TO VERIFY WHO THEY
ARE- WITH SOCIAL MEDIA WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO BE
CAUTIOUS AND CAREFUL. BECAUSE
OF THE NUMEROUS FAKE ACCOUNTS
AND OTHER TYPES OF- HE
INTERESTING ACTIVITIES THAT
OCCUR ON ON SOCIAL MEDIA
WEBSITES IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
OPEN SOURCE SOLUTIONS LIKE
SOCIAL MEDIA ARE NOT POSSIBLE
BUT I THINK WHAT- IT
DEMONSTRATES HOPEFULLY TO THIS
COMMITTEE IS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO BE THOUGHTFUL CAUTIOUS ON
SELF REGULATE AS WE WAY THE
VERY SAME FACTORS THAT YOU ALL
STATED THAT YOU WERE WANTING.
AS FAR AS THE FUTURE USE OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION ARE
CONCERNED I MEAN THAT'S IN MANY
IN IN MANY INSTANCES IT'S GOING
TO BE- DEPENDING UPON. HOW THE
TECHNOLOGY EVOLVES IN IN HOW
IT. IT IS FIT FOR DIFFERENT
TYPES OF USE. THE ONE THING
THOUGH THAT I WILL RAISE TO
YOUR ATTENTION IS WE HAVE THE
OLYMPICS COMING UP VERY SOON.
IT'S RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER.
AND IT'S WORTH CON TEMPLATING
IN THAT TYPE OF SETTING GIVEN
THE NUMBER OF THREATS- TO THE
COUNTRY TO THE NATION- TO WHAT
EXTENT WE EMPLOY THAT AND OTHER
TYPE OF BIOMETRIC TECHNOLOGIES.
IN ORDER TO KEEP THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND SURROUNDING
AREAS SAFE. AS FAR AS- THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE
LEAGUE'S PRIMARY INTEREST IN
FILL OUT CO PRIMARY WILL CALL
IT INTERESTING FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY. OUTSIDE
OF THE OLYMPICS EASY YOU KNOW
REDUCING CRIME IS A PART OF IT
BUT- WE SEE TRUE VALUE IN
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY.
ARM HELPING WITH THE PROPER
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE TO
BRING THE RIGHT PERSON TO
JUSTICE AND TO REDUCE HUMAN
ERROR THAT LEADS TO FLAWED
INVESTIGATIONS. WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THAT FOR EXAMPLE
ACCORDING TO THE INNOCENCE
PROJECT WHICH IS A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM GROUP THAT. SAYS
IT'S COMMITTED TO EXONERATING
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED PEOPLE OF
ONE OF THE STATS THAT THEY THEY
HAVE A OF REFERENCED MULTIPLE
TIMES THREE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
PEOPLE CONVICTED AND SENTENCED
TO DEATH SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE HAVE BEEN EXONERATED. OF
THESE 71% HAD BEEN CONVICTED
THROUGH WHAT I'LL CALL I
WITNESS MISIDENTIFICATION. AND
IT SERVED AN AVERAGE OF
FOURTEEN YEARS BEFORE THE
EXONERATION. OF THOSE FALSE
IDENTIFICATIONS 41% INVOLVED
CROSS RACIAL MISIDENTIFICATION.
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE OF THE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT THAT
I- HAD JUST MENTIONED WERE
BLACK. SO WE ASK THE QUESTION
WHEN WE APPROACH SORT OF FUTURE
USES IN AND OUR EVEN OUR
CURRENT USAGE OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY. WITH HIGH
DEFINITION IMAGERY AND FACIAL
LOW JUST SAY TOP TIER FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGIES. COULD
THE FATE OF THESE MOSTLY BLACK
MEN HAVE CHANGED COULD THESE
TECHNOLOGICAL TOOLS HAVE.
REDIRECTED LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENERGIES TO THE ACTUAL
PERPETRATORS INSTEAD OF TWO
INNOCENT MEN WHO MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN IN PROXIMITY TO THE
CRIME OF THE CRIME SCENE- IN
OUR MIND THERE'S NOTHING WORSE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE THAN. US UTILIZING
TAXPAYER RESOURCES TO PURSUE
DETAIN ARREST INCARCERATE
PROSECUTE AND CONVICT SOMEONE
THAT WE WEREN'T EVEN REALLY
TRYING TO CATCH IN RAISING THIS
ISSUE. AND WE WONDER WHAT THE
ROLE IS OF THIS TECHNOLOGY IN
FACILITATING SORT OF A MORE
EVEN RACIALLY JUST JUSTICE
SYSTEM THAT DRASTICALLY LOWERS
ARM MIS IDENTIFICATIONS HOW DO
WE UTILIZE IT TO BE MORE
PRECISE ACCURATE WITH OUR
ACTIVITIES- SO THAT WE DON'T
GET ACCUSED OF THINGS LIKE.
OVER POLICING. IRRESPECTIVE OF
WHETHER THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE
TRUE EVEN BASELESS ALLEGATIONS
YOU KNOW AFFECT PERCEPTIONS OF
OUR WORK- HOW DO WE LEVERAGED
THE TECHNOLOGIES MYCOLOGIST
MENTIONED TO DEAL WITH THE
THOUSAND TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
MISSING ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA
BUT ALSO TENSOF THOUSANDS. OF
MISSING CHILDREN WERE NOT FULLY
THERE YET IN LA COUNTY BUT IT
IS IT IS TOP OF CONSCIENCE WILL
PUT IT THAT WAY- FIFTEEN HERE
BEING THAT WE WANT TO PREVENT
CRIMES WANNA SOLVE CRIMES WE
REALLY REUNITE MISSING PERSONS
WE WANT TO REDUCE UNNECESSARY
POOL. SERVE IN CAP. REDUCE X.
IT UNNECESSARY EXPERIENCES WITH
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND
INCREASE COMMUNITY CONFIDENCE.
ARM I'LL CONCLUDE WITH-
TOUCHING ON A COUPLE OF THE
POINTS IN IN A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
MENTIONED- WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT SOME OF THE- PROPAGANDA
ASSOCIATED WITH- THE WITH THE
USE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY. MANY OF
YOUR WHERE IT'S EASY YOU ALL OF
CITED IT MISSED THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF STANDARDS AND
TECHNOLOGY THEY REGULARLY
EVALUATE THESE TECHNOLOGIES IN
THEIR MOST RECENT REPORT
RELEASED ONLY A FEW MONTHS AGO.
THEY EVALUATED TWO HUNDRED
RHYTHMS FROM NINETY NINE
DEVELOPERS WHICH COMPRISES A
MAJORITY OF THE INDUSTRY- AND
THIS IS GLOBALLY. MANY OF THEIR
ALGORITHMS THAT THE- TESTED DID
DISPLAY SOME BIAS. AND YOU KNOW
NEW SET NEWS OUTLETS YOU KNOW
TOOK THAT TO WRITE THEIR THEIR
THEIR STORIES TO BASICALLY
CONCLUDE THAT ALL FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE WAS THE
SAME IN ALL FACIAL RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE WAS IN SOME WAY SHAPE
OR FORM RACIST OR SEXIST- BUT
IF YOU PAY YOUR INSIDE THE
REPORT. IT HIGHLIGHTS THAT AS
MY **** MENTION THE MOST
ACCURATE ALGORITHMS HAD DO HAVE
UNDETECTABLE- DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS AND
IT'S STILL WORTH STATING IN OUR
OPINION THAT. ARM WHEN YOU LOOK
AT WHEN YOU CONTRAST THE
ACCURACY. OF EVEN THE MID TIER
NOT THAT WE WOULD EVEN WANT TO
APPROACH YOUR MID TIER
TECHNOLOGIES BUT IF YOU IF YOU
CONTRAST MID TIER TECHNOLOGIES
WITH. THE HISTORIC PRACTICES OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. BOMB THOSE MID
TIER TECHNOLOGIES ARE
INFINITELY MORE ACCURATE THAN
OUR OLD SCHOOL WAYS SO THAT'S
WHY OF MISTER CHAIRMAN WHEN THE
FICTITIOUS CLAIM STARTED LAST
YEAR ALLEGE THAT. 20% OF
LEGISLATORS HAD BEEN
MISIDENTIFIED. IT IMMEDIATELY
IT PROVOKED- I THINK A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ON OUR SIDE THAT WE
ATTEMPTED TO DIALOGUE ABOUT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY DIDN'T HAVE A
WILLING RECIPIENT DIALOGUE-
WHERE DID YOU SET THE ACCURACY
THRESHOLDS FOR THE SOFTWARE.
WHAT WAS THE POLICY OF THE
IMAGES OF THE LEGISLATORS THAT
YOU USE. ARM WHAT WAS THE
QUALITY OF THESE. MYSTERIOUS
PUBLIC DATABASE THAT YOU
UTILIZE BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
CRIMINAL OFFENDER RECORD
INFORMATION- IS CONFIDENTIAL IS
ONLY USED FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES SO. AND WE CAN VOUCH
FOR THE QUALITY OF THE DATA
THAT IS INSERTED INTO THAT
SYSTEM WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
DATABASE THAT WAS USED ARM WE
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE
METHODOLOGY. DID RECEIVE IT TO
THOSE QUESTIONS AND THEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY. ARM DID WE USE TOP
TIER FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY AND ALGORITHMS- AS
JUDGE BY NEST OR DID WE
SOMETHING ELSE SO. EVEN IN THE
EVENT THAT LET'S JUST SAY
HYPOTHETICALLY ALL OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES. ARM WERE 20%
INACCURATE FOR THIS
HYPOTHETICAL IF WE HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN THE 71%
MISIDENTIFICATION NUMBER- OF
THOSE WHO ARE FALSELY ACCUSED
AND SENTENCED. TO DEATH ARM OR
OUR HYPOTHETICAL 20% ARM IF WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY IN THIS
THIS FALSE HYPOTHETICAL TO CUT
THE NUMBER OF WRONGLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE BUT MORE
THAN 65% WE WOULD JUST ASK THE
QUESTION WHY THE STATUS QUO. I
THINK FORTUNATELY FOR YOU ALL
YOU DON'T TO CHOOSE BETWEEN A
FALSE DICHOTOMY THERE ARE A LOT
OF TECHNOLOGIES AND TOOLS OF
BILLABLE THAT MUCH ACCURATE ARM
WE SEE THIS AS AN IN THE GATE
OF TOOL OUT THAT'LL LEAD US TO
THE RIGHT INVEST IF PASSED THE
TECHNOLOGY BY ITSELF. ARMED IS
NOT GIVE US PROBLEMS BECAUSE WE
AGREED TO IN A MINUTE TO BE
PLACED IN THE LAW I SEE THAT.
THE TECHNOLOGY SHOULD WILL NOT
IN AND OF IT DOUBLES PROBABLE
CAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THAT REAL
INVESTIGATIVE WORK NEEDS TO BE
DONE- WE HAVE TO PROVE TO A
JURY BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT-
IN IN THAT IS ALL THE A COMPASS
THAT I HAVE HERE TODAY
AVAILABLE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU REYES OF LEGITIMATE
QUESTION MY HOPE IS OUT MAYBE
THE P. R. PALETTE THE NEXT TWO
PANELS WOULD ADDRESS THE
ISSUES. AND WITHOUT THAT I LIKE
TO OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE LOOK AT THE SERVICE RIGHT.
THANK YOU- FOR A YEAR
PRESENTATIONS OF I YOU KNOW A
LOT OF TIMES JUST RECENTLY YOU
KNOW- WE'VE HEARD FROM YOU KNOW
OF THE EITHER THROUGH
RESEARCHER NEWS ARTICLES ABOUT
THE USE OF F. R. T. AND LONG
LONG PRESSMAN INSECURITY AND
NOW ESPECIALLY WITH- THE- IS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE LIKE READING
OR ANY TYPE OF THING AT THEIR
DOOR PEOPLE ARE YOU IN A MINUTE.
YOU KNOW WHAT SOCIAL MEDIA I.
DEV IS HOW. DO YOU HOW DO YOU
THINK OR DO YOU THINK LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE ABLE. TO
LOOK THROUGH- YOU KNOW
SUBSCRIBE TO SOME TYPE OF
SERVICE. THAT COULD HELP
IDENTIFY. SOMEONE THAT'S
ACCUSED OF A CRIME THAT YOU
HAVE A PHOTO OR VIDEO OF OR HOW
DO YOU THINK THAT COULD HAVE
YOU THOUGHT THROUGH THAT LIKE-
I MEAN WE IT THANK YOU I'M-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WE START
THROUGH A- LOT OF. AERIALS I'M
CERTAIN PHILOSOPHIC BE. ARM HOW
MUCH OR OR OR WHAT USES DO YOU
APPLYING FACIAL RECOGNITION-
TECHNOLOGIES TO AND- I MEAN
ULTIMATELY. IF WE'RE GOING TO
CONSIDER WHAT WHAT WE BELIEVE.
PUBLIC OPINION WHERE PUBLIC
OPINION STANDS WHAT THE PUBLIC
WANTS US TO DO- WHEN WE TAKE.
COMPLAINTS FROM- WILL CALL MARK
CUSTOMERS YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARM
WE VERY MUCH WE VERY MUCH WANT
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
ISSUE THAT THEY HAVE. AND STE
D. STAND THERE ARE TOOLS
AVAILABLE THAT ARE ACCURATE THE
BILL AGAIN PLUS FOLKS IN. ON
GOING DOWN RIGHT INVESTIGATIVE
PATHS WHAT THAT MEANS FOR IS
THAT WE SPEND MUCH LESS TIME.
THE I DON'T SEE ANTAGONIZES BUT
POLICE WORK THAT IS THAT IS
BOTHERS SOME OF SOMEONE'S YOU
KNOW RIGHTS IN THEIR LIBERTIES
IN ORDER TO FOCUS DOWN ON
GETTING TO THE TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE WOULD HAND.
SO I'VE FROM THE LAPD YUN
PERSON. WE'RE WE'RE REALLY
INTERESTED X. ALL THE TOOLS
THAT ARE ARE LOOK AVAILABLE AT
LEGITIMATE TOOLS ACCURATE TOOL.
THAT WAS THE ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES AT THAT
PARTICULARLY FROM AND I GUESS
YOU KNOW BASED ON WHAT YOU
SPONSORED I'M THINKING WHO. DID
HE MEAN LET ME THIS QUESTION
ALL OF US WHO IS TO DETERMINE
WHERE THESE ALLEGED TOOLS TO BE
IS THAT OF FOR RIGHT THEY
SHOULD IS AT THE STATE FEDERAL
COOPER. I'M JUST CARE FROM YOUR.
WHAT IS. THE LOW FOR AND- I
DIDN'T ON I THINK THUS FAR YET
NOT FAR WE WE'VE DIFFER TO ARM
THE COUNTY IN A WAY. LACK CHRIS
AS AN ORGAN. TO SORT OF THAT
BUT I THINK TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION ARM. AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED EARLIER WHAT WE
WOULDN'T BE OPPOSED TO THAT
REALLY BEING A PART OF THE
PROCURE PROCESS. LET'S PER THE
BEST TAKE ON THE FOR END LET'S.
THEIR ADVANTAGES TO. WERE
BENEFITS THAT THEY AND THEN
FROM THERE SO THAT WE KNOW- AND
IT'S DISTILLED DOWN TO YOU KNOW
THE OFFICERS THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE- AND CIVILIANS
PERHAPS THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR UTILIZING THESE
TECHNOLOGIES- JUST WHAT EXACTLY
WE'RE GETTING. AT WHAT WHAT WE
CAN REALLY I ON IN WE
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE NUANCES
ABOUT- WAYS IN WHICH YOU KNOW
NOT TO USE THE SOFTWARE I MEAN
FOR FROM MOST ALL OF THESE
SOFTWARE PROGRAM I MEAN YOU DO
NEED TO BE TO ON. YOU DO NEED
TO I NEED THE PARKS NEED THIS
POLICY. OUR DO NEED TO
OBVIOUSLY INTO THE TO BE A
ACCORDANCE WITH EXIST LAW BUT
THEY DO HE SAID THE MURDERS WE-
WERE VERY MUCH. THE LADY MEANT
HE- WE HAVE WE HAVE THE LAYERS
OF REGULATION ARM THAT DON'T
SPEAKS. ARM TO THE YOU OF
FACIAL TECH BUT OVER ARCHING
SORT OF GUY THE USE- IN THE
THINKING BEHIND SOME OF THE
LOCAL REGULATIONS THAT WE'VE
PROMULGATED FOR THE USE OF
METRICS. VERY MUCH MISSED KILEY
AS HAS QUESTION. MR APURVA SO
IN THAT EXAMPLES. REALLY ONE.
ABOUT HAITIAN ONE OF THE WRAPS
THE LITTLE BALL WAS WE HAVE A
NEW THE SHOWS ON A STORE IS
BASED UPON THE FACE OF A AND
READ AND THAT. THANKS FOR THE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT BECAUSE. IF SO
IN A WAY THAT. WE ARE A THAT.
YEAH I MEAN SO THE PERSONAL AS
YET THAT YOU RAISE THE RAISE A
GOOD A GOOD QUESTION I THINK
FIRST OF ALL IT'S NOT OLD
THAT'S A LONG FOR ACTIVITY IT'S
A PRIVATE PROPERTY BUT ALSO SO
OBVIOUSLY THE NEEDS TO BE
PROCESS THAT HAVE THERE MINOR.
IS MOST DOES THE RETAIL SECTOR
LAW PREVENTION PROGRAM THAT DO
DO KEEP TRACK THE OF PEOPLE
THIS IS BASS LIKE AN ADDITION
TO WHAT THERE ARE DOING BUT THE
EXAM I'VE SEEN OF YOU PAUL'S
FOR THIS TO ASSIST. THERE IS A
VERY. WE THOUGHT OUT PROCESS
FOR ATTY SOME OF LIKE THE REST
OF U. K. FILE SB VERIFY BY SERB
LAYERS OF IT OF A MISS. YOU
KNOW WITHIN THE WITHIN THE
COMPANY HAS TO BE A OR B.
METHOD FOR SOMEONE TO OUR RE
AND FROM THE WAY LEAST BEING
PUT ON A LIST LIKE THAT IN
THAT'S OF THE BEST PRACTICES
AND AREA OF SEEN BUT REALLY ANY
TO BE NEED THIRTY TO BE STRUCK
ON THAT FOR SURE. MR. THAT IT
IS FAR AS LONG INNER WHICH SAY
IN RETAIL SETTING ON MY
COLLEAGUES IS IT RIGHT LOS
PREVENT LAWS PREVENT DOES THAT
AND THE OPERA. THAT WE'VE HAD
TO SORT OF PEER BEHIND THE
CURTAIN OF THE THAT THAT DOES
HAVE YOU KNOW YOU WALK THE DOOR
IN LOS PREVENTION THEY FOLLOW
YOU THROUGH STORE THEY DOING
MAYBE IN SOME BLOW IN SOME
CASES THEY BE TO IT BE BE OF
CAN BIAS BUT AT THE END THESE
THESE HUMAN. SORT OF DOING SO
IS A AS WE YOU SUGGEST MIGHT
SAN A THERE'S AN REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THAT THE STATUS.
WE IS WHAT YOU SAY IN A
SCENARIO THAT IS PRIME. HE
DRIVEN IS WORSE. RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IF
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS I WANT TO THANK THE
TWO GENTLEMEN FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION SAID LET'S BRING
UP OUR NEXT PANEL. AND FOR OUR
NEXT PANEL I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
OUR OUR THIRD PANEL JOINING US
TODAY IS MEGAN GRAHAM WHO IS
CLINICAL SUPERVISING ATTORNEY
AT THE SAM HOUSTON LAW
TECHNOLOGY AND PUBLIC POLICY
CLINIC. AT UC BERKELEY SCHOOL
OF LAW ARE ALSO UNFORTUNATELY
MATT KEY GOAL TECHNOLOGY AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES ATTORNEY AT THE
A. C. L. U. OF CALIFORNIA
ORIGINALLY LISTED ON THE AGENDA
THAT WENT OUT THERE COULD NOT
JOIN IS TO DATE. BUT JOINING AS
A IS BECCA MALL. LEGISLATIVE
CORN AND HOW A KID AT THE- I
CAL. TO DISCUSS THE TOPIC
PRIVACY BY AS AND OTHER
CHALLENGES FOR TO THE USE OF
FACIAL TECHNOLOGY SO WELCOME
AND BEFORE YOU LIKE FOR YOU TO
STATE YOUR NAY FOR THE RECORD
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR ME TO
SPEAK THIS. MY NAME IS MIKE. AN
JUST SAT A CLINICAL SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY IN THE SAME IN LAW
TECHNO IN PUBLIC POLICY. UPPER
LAW. MY WORK IN THE CLINIC
FOCUSES THE INNER OF TECH. AND
CRIMINAL LAW FOR USE
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY DURING
AN- I'VE DONE SIX SUBS AND WORK
ON HOW LONG ENFORCEMENT IN
VARIOUS. USE FACIAL. TECH AND
HOW IT AFFECTS CRIMINAL
DEFENDANTS CASES. TODAY I WOULD
LIKE TO VOTE. ON HOW FACIAL. IS
MOST COMMONLY USED IN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS THE DIFFERENT
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES DEFENDANTS
FACE IF THEY FIND OUT THAT IT
THAT IT HAS BEEN USING THEIR
CASE. AND QUITE FRANKLY THAT'S
A BIG F. AT THIS POINT. IN
PRACTICE LAW ENFORCEMENT USES
THE TECHNOLOGY TO COMPARE WHAT
IS KNOWN AS A PRO PHOTO TO A
DATA SET OF FACES WHOSE
IDENTITIES ARE KNOWN. THE PRO
FOR IT WAS A PICTURE OF AN
UNKNOWN INDIVIDUAL THE PICTURE
CAN BE FROM A WITNESSES PHONE-
PICTURE THAT THEY TALK A
SECURITY CAMERA OR ANOTHER
SOURCE. THE KNOWN DATA SIDE IS
DETERMINED BY WHOSE PICTURES
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY CAN
ACCESS DEPENDING ON THE
JURISDICTION. THE DATA SET MAY
INCLUDE DRIVER'S LICENSE AND
IDENTIFICATION CARD PHOTOS
MUGSHOTS OR AS WE'VE LEARNED
RECENTLY I'M IN THE-
REVELATIONS ABOUT CLEARVIEW A.
I. AT THE PHOTOS. MAY IN THE
DATA SET CAN BE SCRAPED FROM
ALL ACROSS THE INTERNET WITHOUT
YOUR KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT. IN
NEW YORK AS AN EXAMPLE
CHILDREN'S ARREST PHOTOS HAVE
BEEN INCLUDE THE AND WHAT
BECAUSE- AS HAVE SO. MUGSHOT
THAT WERE PER. BY LAW FROM
BEING USED FOR. LAWN FOR
PURPOSES. TO BE CLEAR. THE DISK
ABOUT TO GET REALIZE INTO SOME.
THAT PROBE WERE OF. DEPENDING
ON THE SEARCH. A PERSON MAY
HAVE A FIRST AND FOURTH
AMENDMENT CLAIM THAT WOULD MAKE
THE INITIAL COLLECTION OF THE
PHOTO UNCONSTITUTIONAL. SO
BEFORE RUNNING A SEARCH LAW
ENFORCEMENT MUST ENSURE THAT
THE PROBE PHOTO WILL LEAD TO A
VIABLE RISK MATCH. PRO PHOTOS
ARE GENERALLY TAKEN UNDER LESS
THAN IDEAL CIRCUMSTANCES THEY
MAY BE BLURRY THEY CAN BE TAKEN
AND ANGLE THE LIGHTING MAY BE
BAD THE PERSON'S EYES MIGHT BE
CLOSED OR THEIR FACE MIGHT BE
OBSCURED ALL OF THESE SORTS OF
ISSUES MAKE THE SOFTWARE LESS
ACCURATE. LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL
REGULARLY MANIPULATE PRO PHOTOS
SO THE SOFTWARE IS MORE LIKELY
TO FIND A MATCH AND IN DOING
SO- POLICE MAY INTRODUCED BY A
SEIZE OR INACCURACIES INTO THE
ORIGINAL IMAGE. FOR EXAMPLE IF
OMEONE'S EYES ARE CLOSED AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT ADDS EYES TO
THE PICTURE THEY HAVE NO WAY OF
KNOWING WHAT COLOR EYES THE
ACTUAL PERSON IN THE PHOTO HAS.
THEN LAW ENFORCEMENT RUNS THE
SEARCH. WHETHER AN AGENT MUST
BE TRAINED AND WHAT TRAINING IS
APPROPRIATE MAYBE STEP BY
POLICY REGULATION IT MAY ALSO
NOT BE. THE SAME IS TRUE FOR
VARIOUS TECHNICAL THRESHOLD FOR
DEFINING A MATCH. AND FOR WHICH
CRIMES FACIAL RECOGNITION CAN
BE USED TO DURING THE
INVESTIGATION. THE SOFTWARE
COMPARES THE PRO PHOTO TO THE
DATA SET OF KNOWN FACES I
DESCRIBED AS OTHERS WELL AND
HAVE DISCUSSED THE ALGORITHMS
CURRENTLY ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS ACCURATE FOR FOLKS IN
CERTAIN DEMOGRAPHICS INCLUDING
FOR WOMEN COMPARED TO MEN. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DARK SKIN
COMPARED TO LIGHT SKIN AND
PARTICULARLY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AS COMPARED TO ADULTS. ONCE THE
SEARCH HAS BEEN RUN THE
ALGORITHM WILL PROVIDE A SET OF
POTENTIAL MATCHES WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CONFIDENCE OR LIKELIHOOD THAT
THE PROBE PHOTO MATCHES UNKNOWN
PHOTO. THE SOFTWARE DOES NOT
PROVIDE ONE TO ONE PERFECT
MATCHES SO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENT WILL EXAMINE THE RESULTS
TO DECIDE WHO IS THE BEST
MATCH. THE PERSON THE SOFTWARE
PLACES AT THE TOP OF THE LIST
IS NOT ALWAYS THE PERSON THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER DECIDES
IS THE BEST MATCH. FROM THEIR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AS ANY NUMBER
OF THINGS DEPENDING ON THE CASE
APPLICABLE RECORD REGULATIONS
IF ANY AND WHO THE PROBE PHOTO
IS UP. FOR AMBLE IF THE PRO
PHOTO IS OF A SUB FACT AND
REGULATE PERMIT IT POLICE MAY
USE APPS TO CREATE A OR LINE UP
TO SHOW AN EYE WITNESS.
ELSEWHERE ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
HAVE SIMPLY A WITNESS TO ASK
THE PERSON MAY HAVE A- THROUGH
FACIAL. IS SUSPECT. AND IN YET.
STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN DOES
YOU WILL RECOGNITION TO
IDENTIFY. WHO WERE UNWILLING TO
COME FOR. OR TO IDENTIFY SOME
WHO'S QUOTE UNABLE TO EIGHT HIM
OR HER. WITH CAN NO BOUNCE. I'M
ASSUMING FACIAL. IS YOU TO CHEN
AND I. I'D LAW FORCED MAY EVER
OF DEFENSE. IT'S MORE THAN JUST
THIS POINT. FACIAL RECOGNITION
MAYBE YOU. AND PARKS AND LIFE
IS M<c.cyan> DIRECTLY AFFECTED BY</c>
THAT MAY NEVER KNOW. DEPENDING
PROTECT THEIR CONCERT YOU
RIGHTS COURT IF THEY NEVER FIND
OUT WHAT THE POLICE DID DURING
THE- EVEN IF THE DEFENDANT FIND
OUT THAT OR- WAS. TO LAUNCH MAY
REFER TO SHARE AND ABOUT THE
SEARCH. SO FAR ACROSS THE
COUNTRY PROSECUTORS HAVE OFTEN
REFUSED TO SHARE BASIC
INFORMATION LIKE WHETHER AND
HOW THE PRO PHOTO WAS
MANIPULATED. HOW MANY POTENTIAL
MATCHES THE PROGRAM IDENTIFIED
HOW THE SCORE OF THE DEFENDANT
COMPARED TO THE OTHER POTENTIAL
MATCHES FOR INFORMATION ABOUT
THE TECHNICAL AND ACCURACY
TESTING OF SOFTWARE WHERE IT'S
BEING USED. ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION IS ARGUABLY BRADY
MATEER ALL THE DEFENDANT HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT NOW. IT IS
INHERENTLY EITHER INCULPATORY
OR EXCULPATORY AND BRADY VERSUS
MARYLAND AND ITS PROGENY
REQUIRE THE DISCLOSURE OF SUCH
INFORMATION. HOWEVER AT THE
EXACT THE EXISTING PRESSURES TO
PLEASE. AND THE SO CALLED
SENTENCING TAXES DEFENDANTS
REGULARLY FACE IF THEY GO TO
TRIAL OR CHOOSE TO LITIGATE
PRETRIAL ISSUES LIKE THIS. I
MEAN IF YOU COURTS OF HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT EXISTING CAPS LOCK YOUR
KEYS IN. RIGHT TO KNOW THIS AND
ACTION. FURTHERMORE BECAUSE THE
FOR RECOGNITION. ARE NOT
CURRENT BEING INTO DIRECTLY AS-
OF A POSITIVE I. COURTS HAVE
NOT HAD OPPORTUNITIES TO WEIGH
IN ON WHETHER FACIAL
RECOGNITION IS RELIABLE
EVIDENCE OF A CRIME. OR ANY
SORT QUITE FRANKLY A FRY
HEARING NORMALLY GIVES COURTS
THE CHANCE TO TEST THE
RELIABILITY OF EVIDENCE BUT
AGAIN BECAUSE LAW ENFORCEMENT
SO FAR GENERALLY CONCEDES THE
FACIAL RECOGNITION. RESULTS
CANNOT BE INTRODUCED DIRECTLY
THOSE HEARINGS ARE NOT BEING
HELPED. SO THE LEGAL MECHANISMS
WE GENERALLY ASSUME ARE IN
PLACE TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS ARE
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO
RELY ON WHEN IT COMES TO FACIAL
RECOGNITION. THE DEFENDANT
CANNOT ARGUE HER RIGHTS HAVE
BEEN HARMED BY FACIAL
RECOGNITION IF SHE DOES NOT
KNOW IT WAS USED BRADY CLAIMS
HAVE BEEN SLOW IN COMING AS A
RESULT OF THE LACK OF
INFORMATION CHAIRED BY
PROSECUTORS. AND MAY NOT
PRESENT. LET'S FIVE THE
OFFICIAL RESULTS AS I'VE
BECAUSE FORCE CAN CHOOSE SHIELD
THE TECHNOLOGY FROM QUEST BY IN
FOR ONLY THE I WOULD I DONE IT
EVENTUALLY. THESE WE COMPLEX
ARE NOT EASY TO FIX EVEN THEY
MAY SEEM LIKE SIMPLE FIXES
THEY'RE INTERLOCKING AND THE
KNOCK ON EFFECTS OF A SOLUTION
TO ONE WILL AFFECT. AS A DID
YOU DEVELOP MORE PRINT LEGAL
NEW ONES ARE LIKELY TO ARISE.
THIS I WOULD ENCOURAGE ALLEGE
THE LAW. TO TAKE TIME AND CARE
TO CRAFT A REGULATORY REGIME
BUT ADEQUATELY SAFEGUARDS
CALIFORNIANS CIVIL LIBERTIES
AND CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS. I'M
FACE RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
SIMPLY COMES WITH TOO MANY
RISKS TO CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS
RIGHTS FOR USE WHILE THAT
FRAMEWORK IS BEING DEVELOPED.
THERE RISKS OF
MISIDENTIFICATION BIAS AND
INADEQUATE TESTING OF THE
RELIABILITY OF THE RESULTS
AMONG OTHERS THAT I'M SURE
FOLKS WILL TALK ABOUT ON THE
NEXT PANEL. LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
BEEN ABLE TO DO ITS JOB SO FAR
WITHOUT USE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
AND OF COURSE THERE ARE
PROBLEMS AND BIAS THAT ARE
INTRODUCED BY I WITNESSED
TECHNOLOGY- EYEWITNESS
IDENTIFICATIONS. ON THEIR OWN
HOWEVER THE COURTS HAVE
PROCESSES IN PLACE FOR
DEFENDANTS TO BE ABLE TO
VINDICATE THEIR RIGHTS. IT IS
MY VIEW THAT WE THAT PERSON CAN
WAIT A LONGER WILL LEAD TO
DECIDE THE IMPROVE WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
MECHANISMS ARE. TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS RIGHT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU MUCH NEXT. PLEASE HI THANK
YOU THE ARE. TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS BECCA KRAMER
MATTER AND I'M LEGISLATIVE
COORDINATOR AN ADVOCATE AT THE
ACLU CALIFORNIA. I'D LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT THREE KEY ISSUES
WITH FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY AND MY TESTIMONY
THIS AFTERNOON. FIRST I DID AND
REAL THREAT THAT FACIAL
RECOGNITION POSES TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. THESE SYSTEMS CAN
AND- BEING A- BY ORAL
GOVERNMENT. INCLUDING I. TO
TARGET PEOPLE OF. IMMIGRANTS IN
POLITICAL ACTIVE. MORE IT. NESS
NOW PREVENT FURTHER HARM.
SECOND THE UNIQUE AND SO FOR
THAT FACE RECOGNITION POSES TO
OUR BAY. CIVIL RIGHTS AND CIVIL
LIBERTIES. FACIAL SAYS GENERATE
ON THE DENTED. ON RENT PURSE
SIR. AND EXPLAIN. GOT AND
CREATION. THIS DANGEROUS. CAN
BE YOU TO I BASIC OPPORTUNE.
AND TO PROMOTE DISC. AND MARCH.
HELLO CAN. THIRD I WANT THIS
IMPORT PROTECTING WILL MOVE
PREVENT DEPLOYMENT BACK BY.
RIGHT CAN BE AND A THE UNITED.
ARE STEPPING UP TO PER CIVIL
RIGHTS AND PUBLIC SAFETY BY
ADOPTING. ON FACE BACK USE BY
GOV. FISHER RECOGNITION GET
COVER UNIQUE POWER TO SPY ON US
WHEREVER WE GO IDENTIFYING US
THAT PROTESTS POLITICAL RALLIES
PLACES OF WORSHIP AND MORE.
THIS TECHNOLOGY SUPER CHARGES
THE GOVERNMENT'S EXISTING
ABUSIVE PRACTICES FROM
TERRORIZING IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES TO SPYING ON BLACK
AND BROWN ACTIVISTS. THIS POWER
ISN'T JUST BEING ABUSED IN
CHINA WHERE THE GOVERNMENT IS
USING IT TO TRACK AND CONTROL
MUSLIMS AMERICAN GOVERNMENTS
HAVE REPORTED THE USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION TO IDENTIFY
PROTESTERS FOR VAST AND
POWERFUL SYSTEMS LIKE CLEAR
VIEW A I CAN USE OUR SPECIAL
MEDIA PHOTOS. TO SECRETLY
RECORD OUR LOCATIONS AND WHO WE
MEET. FACIAL RECOGNITION.
THREATENS THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES ICE HAS DEMANDED
THAT MARYLAND AND WASHINGTON TO
STATES THAT LIKE CALIFORNIA
OFFERED DRIVERS LICENSES TOP
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS. RUN
FACIAL RECOGNITION SEARCHES ON
THEIR STATE DATABASES SYSTEMS
BELTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA WOULD
BE VULNERABLE TO THESE SAME
DEMANDS. FACIAL RECOGNITION
SYSTEMS ARE BEING USED TO
JUSTIFY A REST AND ARE DEEPLY
FLAWED CIRCUMSTANCES. POLICE
HAVE FED THE SYSTEMS FORENSICS
SKETCHES PHOTOS OF CELEBRITIES
AND AS WE JUST HEARD ABOUT IT
IT IT- IMAGES IN AN ATTEMPT TO
IDENTIFY PEOPLE. WE KNOW THE
DANGER AND THEIR EMINA. THAT IS
WHAT THE ACLU ARE STILL RIGHTS.
BELIEVE ANY LEAD ADDRESSING
FACIAL. SHOULD CLOSE THE DOOR
TO WIDESPREAD USE THE FACIAL
RASH GOODNESS OF MY HEALTH. THE
LEGISLATURE CAN AND SHOULD AND
A MORE. ON THE GOVERNMENT USE
OFFICIAL. THE ACLU AND OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS ALLIES ARE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE MY AUTHORIZED THE
GOVERNMENT ME TO USE FACIAL. TO
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE AS
WELL AS JOBS FINANCIAL SERVICES
EMPLOYMENT AND EVEN BASIC
NECESSITIES WITH LITTLE OR IF
ANY DETERRENCE AND THIS IS NOT
JUST A THEORETICAL. FOR
INSTANCE AGENCIES AND STATES
INCLUDING MICHIGAN AND NEW YORK
ARE CURRENTLY TRYING TO ADD
FACIAL RECOGNITION SEC
KNOWLEDGE A SYSTEMS TO PUBLIC
HOUSING. SOME FACIAL
RECOGNITION SYSTEMS ARE A
HUNDRED TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
MISS IDENTIFY A PERSON WHO IS
BLACK OR OF ASIAN DESCENT ARE
KNOWN TO MISS GENDER PEOPLE AND
AT HIGHER RATES PRESIDENT OF
THE- FOR WOMEN. USING MISSION
IN PUBLIC HOUSING WOULD LEAD TO
BEING DONE ACCESS PUBLIC
HOUSING EVEN TO THEIR OWN HOME
IF SUCH A SYSTEM DEPLOYED IN
CALIFORNIA MISS IDENTIFIES THEM.
FACIAL RECOGNITION COULD ALSO
BE IS TONIGHT OTHER SERVICES TO
PEOPLE DEEMED UNDESIRABLE BY
COMPANIES OR TO PEOPLE WHO LOOK
LIKE THIS PEOPLE. BUSINESSES IN
THE SACRAMENTO AREA EXAMPLE ARE
ALREADY DEPLOYING FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN
SHARE LIST OF UNDESIRABLE
PATRONS TO BARS AND OTHER
ESTABLISHMENTS RIGHT NOW SOME
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS IN THE US
ARE EXPLORING THE DEPLOYMENT
OF. RECOGNITION IN HOSPICE AS
WELL. THE LEGISLATURE COULD BE
EVERYTHING IN ITS PATH. TO
PROVIDE AID ACCESS AND SERVICES
AND NOT TO DENY THEM AND WHICH
SHOULD BE PREVENTING THE
DEPLOYMENT OF SYSTEMS THAT
FACILITATE THE MISTREATMENT AND
HARM AT THE HANDS OF
GOVERNMENTS AND BUSINESSES.
CALIFORNIANS. 82% OF LIKELY
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA VOTERS
DO NOT WANT TO BE MONITORED AND
TRACKED BY THE GOVERNMENT THREE
FACE OR OTHER BIOMETRIC
SURVEILLANCE. CITIES IN COUNTY
SHOULD BE EMPOWERED TO ADDRESS
THESE THREATS THROUGH
LEGISLATION THAT REGULATES AND
EVEN PROHIBITS THE USE OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION AND THEIR
JURISDICTIONS. CALIFORNIA
CITIES INCLUDING SAN FRANCISCO
OAKLAND AND BERKELEY HAVE ALL
DONE EXACTLY THIS BY ADOPTING
BANDS ON THE GOVERNMENT'S USE
OF FACIAL RECOGNITION. A
COMMUNITY ACTING THROUGH ITS
LOCAL DEMOCRATIC PROCESS SHOULD
BE ABLE TO PREVENT THE
DEPLOYMENT OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TO DENY PUBLIC
HOUSING BASIC SERVICES OR OTHER
USES I GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
ACLU AND CIVIL RIGHTS ALLIES
EXTRA EARNED THAT I JUST MIGHT
TAKE STEP TO PREVENT HOLIDAYS
FROM SEEING LOCAL FOR RECORD
LAW INCLUDE BANDS. IN LOCAL GOT
IT'S FROM BEING STRONG ACTIONS
THEY GET CANCEL THE FACE. WOULD
BE PLAINLY ANTI DEMOCRATIC THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD SUPPORT
LOCAL EFFORTS TO PROTECT CIVIL
RIGHTS FROM THE USE OF NEW
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGIES.
TECHNOLOGY MOVES QUICKLY AND
SOMETIMES IT CAN FEEL LIKE THE
USES OF TECHNOLOGY ARE
INEVITABLE BUT THAT'S NOT HOW
ARE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS WORKS WE
ALONG WITH OUR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES HAVE THE POWER
TO REJECT SURVEILLANCE THAT IS
INVASIVE THAT WE KNOW WILL BE
USED TO DISCRIMINATE AND THAT
SUFFERS. SERIOUS CURACY AND BY
SEES AGAINST FINANCE THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE ACTING TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY AND TO
PROTECT THE DISCRIMINATORY
TARGETING OF MARGINALIZED
CALIFORNIANS. THERE IS EXACTLY
ONE WAY TO DO THAT BY PASSING A
MORATORIUM NOW. THANK YOU FOR
OF IT ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK AND
I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS WITHOUT THE LIKE
TO OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MISTER NO THE CUP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LIKE TO
THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. YOU KNOW I IT'S
INTERESTING WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE ETHICAL RAMIFICATIONS OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY-
I. YOU KNOW I THINK WE NEED TO
DISTINGUISH. PHILOSOPHICALLY
THE THINGS THAT ARE DIFFERENT
ABOUT FRT THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE
ARE BRING UP ISSUES THAT WE
HAVEN'T FACED BEFORE SO- YOU'RE
ONE OF THOSE ISSUES MY MIND IS
WHETHER OR NOT THE PUBLIC HAS A
REASONABLE EXPECTATION OF
PRIVACY WHEN THEY'RE IN A-
PLACE. BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE
KNOW WANT TO STAND THAT FOR
EXAMPLE BARKING AT HAVE A
SURVEILLANCE CAMERA- THAT
RECORDS THE PATRONS TO COME
INTO THE BAR NO ONE IS SAYING
THAT A BAR SHOULDN'T COOPERATE
WITH OTHER BARS AND- SHARING A
NO A LIST- YOU KNOW PICTURES OF
KNOWN TROUBLEMAKERS SO THAT THE
OTHER BARS- COULD POTENTIALLY.
NOT ALLOW THE PEOPLE INTO THE
ESTABLISHMENT SO I'M WONDERING
YOU KNOW WHY WHAT'S DIFFERENT
ABOUT THIS APPLICATION THAT
JUST BECAUSE IT'S DONE IN AN
AUTOMATED WAY MAKES YOU THINK
THAT PEOPLE CIVIL LIBERTIES ARE
BEING IMPACTED. ENERGY LIKE.
I'M I THINK THAT PART OF IT IS
AN AUTOMATED WAY IF SOMEONE IS
LOOKING AT SURVEILLANCE TAPES
FOR EXAMPLE IT TAKES A LOT OF
PEOPLE POWER TO SORT THROUGH
THE HOURS OF TAPES TO TRY AND
IDENTIFY EVERYONE IN THEM WARES
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY-
ALLOWS FOLKS THAT TO HAPPEN IN
REAL TIME QUICKLY WITHOUT A LOT
OF STAFF POWER AND SO IT.
AMPLIFIES THE ABILITY TO
SURVEIL PEOPLE AND IDENTIFY
THEM IN PRIVATE SPACES WHICH IS
RIDICULOUSLY TROUBLING WHEN
COMBINED WITH BLACK LISTS THAT
PEOPLE MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO
KNOW WHY THERE ON THOSE LISTS
AND MIGHT- AND THAT THE FOLKS
THAT CREATE THE LESS MIGHT ALSO
NOT BE ABLE TO DETERMINE WHY
SOMEONE WAS BLACKLISTED IF THEY
ARE NOT ABLE TO UNDERSTAND. WHY
THAT THE ALGORITHM BEHIND THE
TECHNOLOGY BUT I DON'T HAVE
THAT PROBLEM NOW AND SOMEONE
COULD BE BLACKLISTED FROM A BAR
BASED ON A PICTURE THAT WAS
TAKEN UP OUR NAKED PROTECT THE
TRUTH YEARS AGO RIGHT- HOW. HAS
ELEVEN THAT'S ALL OF A BIGGER
AND IF I AM FOR EXAMPLE
BLACKLISTED AT A BAR I AND
YOU'RE THE PERSON NOT LETTING
ME AND I COULD ASK YOU. AND YOU
WOULD BE ABLE TO SAY WE GOT
YOUR PICTURE FROM THIS BAR AND
THEY BLACKLISTED YOU AND I
COULD GO TO THEM AND SAY. WHY
WAS I. AND SOMEONE THERE WOULD
KNOW THE ANSWER WHERE AS IF
WE'RE RUNNING FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY IT COULD
JUST BE THAT MY PHOTO WAS
MISIDENTIFIED. AND FLAGGED AS
SOMEONE WHO I'M NOT. AND THE
PERSON RUNNING THE TECHNOLOGY
MAY NOT KNOW THE ANSWER THEY
WOULD JUST SAY THAT YOU'RE DONE
AND I KNOW. THAT WAS TRUE
THIRTY YEARS AGO THE PERSON
LOOKING AT THE PICTURE COULD
HAVE MISIDENTIFIED YOU I'M JUST
A- YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DISTINGUISH. THE
THING THAT ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
YOU KNOW ETHICALLY DIFFERENT
FROM THE APPLICATION OF TESTIS
TECHNO. TO THE SOCIETAL NORMS
WE'VE ESTABLISHED ALREADY
PERHAPS IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
LOOK AT A DIFFERENT EXAMPLE SO
FOR EXAMPLE. I HAVE PHOTOS ARE
ELDERLY AGAIN AT- PROTEST AND
RALLIES WE SEE THEM ON THE NEWS
CENTER- NO ONE IS SITTING THERE
AT THE END OF FINE WHO EXACTLY
IS IN EACH OTHER'S BUT IT'S
WITH BASS. RECOGNITION IT IS
POSSIBLE TO. FIND ANY THE
PEOPLE. AND SO IT'S SCALE OF.
THE THAT. THE. I MEAN I'M
STRUCK WITH THIS OKAY SO IF
THOUGHT SHE TO ATTACK A RALLY.
YOU KNOW A- NO. THAT PHOTO
BEFORE GRAY ARE BEING TO AT THE
RALLY. I HAVE A REASONABLE LIKE.
THAT SOMEONE'S NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE A PICTURE. AND I
DO. THAT I WAS AT THAT RALLY
RIGHT THAT WAS TRUE THIRTY
YEARS AGO IT'S TRUE NOW. YOU
KNOW I'VE GIVEN UP THEIR
EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY BY GOING
TO A RALLY THE PUBLIC PLACE. SO
I MEAN I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT. FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY OTHER
THAN IT'S EASIER NOW THAN IT
USED TO BE. BUT I MEAN
ETHICALLY THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE TO BE DISTINCTION. I AM I
WOULD DISAGREE WITH YOUR
CLASSIFICATION OF GIVING UP
THEIR RIGHT TO PRIVACY SIMPLY
BY BEING OUT IN THE PUBLIC I
THINK THAT THE CONSTITUTION IN.
PARTICULAR THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. WHICH
SPECIFICALLY LESS OUT THE RIGHT
TO PRIVACY. WOULD ALLOW FOR US
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE A RIGHT TO
PRIVACY EVEN WHEN WE ACCESS OUR
HOUSE. OR IN PUBLIC SPACES. I
MEAN THAT THAT'S THAT TO ME
WHAT WHAT YOU JUST SAID IS THAT
GOES TO THE HEART OF. YOU KNOW
THE THIS PHILOSOPHICAL
DISCUSSION THAT WE'RE HAVING
AND I THINK THAT'S THE ISSUE
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
GRAPPLE WITH. AS A SOCIETY OF
YOU KNOW WHAT MAKES THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION. DIFFERENT
AT IT BUT BUT I YOU KNOW I
STRUGGLE WITH THAT. MYSELF BUT
I MEAN I THINK WE BALANCE THAT.
AGAINST THE SOCIETAL GOOD THAT
WE THAT CAN BE. BROUGHT ABOUT
BY THE USE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY.
SO I WAS ONLY ABLE WHAT DID YOU
HAVE DISCUSSIONS. I'LL CUT
MISCALCULATED. SO I AND YOU CAN
COUNT ME AMONG THE EIGHTY SOME
PERCENT OF AMERICANS WHO DON'T
WANT THE GOVERNMENT MONITORING
AND TRACKING ME I KIND OF
WONDER ABOUT THE TEN PLUS
PERCENT WHO DO ON THAT- HOWEVER
I'M NOT SURE I QUITE UNDERSTAND
THE ACLU'S OPPOSITION WHICH AS
FAR AS I UNDERSTAND THIS KIND
OF A WHOLESALE- MORATORIUM ON
THE TECHNOLOGY ITSELF I MEAN
THERE'S YOU KNOW WITH ANY
TECHNOLOGY AND SHE CAN COME UP
WITH AN ENDLESS LIST OF-
POTENTIALLY MALICIOUS- USES AND
GENERALLY WE TRY TO. REGULATE
OR PROHIBIT THOSE PARTICULAR
MALICIOUS USES- AS OPPOSED TO
JUST- YOU KNOW BAND THE
TECHNOLOGY ITSELF SO YOU KNOW
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THIS
TECHNOLOGIES KIND OF SIMILAR TO
MR OBERNOLTE IS QUESTION AT
THAT IS SO DISTINCTIVE SUCH
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT THAT WINDS
GOVERNMENT YOU
JUST AUTOMATICALLY FOLLOW WHAT
WE- TAKE AN APPROACH THAT'S A
LITTLE MORE FOCUSED AND WE'LL
GET WITH THE POTENTIAL FOR
ABUSES EXIST. SO I BELIEVE THAT
LIKE MOST LEGISLATORS AND THAT
WITHOUT IMMEDIATE ACTION.
GOVERNMENT AND CORPORATE USE A
FACIAL RECOGNITION DOES HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO KIND OF SPIRAL
OUT OF CONTROL WITH SOME OF
THOSE- SITUATIONS THAT YOU FEEL
LIKE. TO CROSS THE BORDER OF
WANTING TO OF BEING TRACKED ALL
THE TIME FOR EXAMPLE- AND SO
IT'S PRUDENT TO TAKE A PAUSE.
WITH THE MORATORIUM AND
CONSIDER THE IMPLICATIONS FOR
OUR FREEDOMS OUR SAFETY AND OUR
DEMOCRACY AND FIGURE OUT. IF
THERE ARE ANY SUCH USES THAT
MIGHT BE ACCEPTABLE FOR FACIAL
RECOGNITION BECAUSE- THERE ARE.
REAL BENEFITS THAT I- AND
EITHER NO REAL REST OR THE
OUTWEIGH THE REAL BREASTS BUT
RIGHT NOW TO TAKE A PAUSE. SO
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS NOT BEING
DEPLOYED IN THESE DANGEROUS AND
HARMFUL WAYS SO IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU MORE OR LESS AGREE WITH MY
APPROACHED. TIMIDLY WE SHOULD
BE. REGULATING ON THAT YOU KNOW
CASE BY CASE OUR APPLICATION
BASED YOU KNOW BASIS AS
OPPOSED. BUT BUT YOU THINK THAT
THE TECHNOLOGY IS KIND OF GOT
AND THE HEAD OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING SO WE NEED TO.
CREATE SPACE FOR THOSE
DECISIONS TO BE MADE IS THAT
THE- I'M I WOULD SAY THAT WE DO
NEED TO CREATE THE SPACE FOR-
THE- EXAMINATION TO CONTINUE.
BUT I. NECESSARILY AT THAT AT
THIS POINT I'M- SAYING THAT
THERE ARE OFTEN USES THAT
SHOULD BE ALLOWED OR THAT COULD
BE. THE HARMS TO A. B. C.
MITIGATED OR ELIMINATED THREE
REGULATIONS THAT THAT'S PART OF
THE REASON THAT WE NEED TO
PRESS PAUSE. AND LOOK AT THAT
MORE THOROUGHLY WHILE NOT USING
THE TECHNOLOGY IN THE MEANTIME.
I IF I COULD JUST FOLLOW UP ON
THAT A LITTLE BIT- AND THEN I
HAVE ANOTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTION
TO. WHAT FOR WHAT YOU KNOW- FOR
PURPOSES OF DISCUSSION JUST TO
TODAY. ARE YOU'RE PROPOSING A
KIND OF A MORATORIUM A COMPLETE
BAN UNTIL YOU HIT YOU HIT THE
PAUSE BUTTON. BUT AREN'T YOU
ALSO- DISMISSING A LOT OF
BENEFITS CREATED BY THE BY THE
TECHNOLOGY ITSELF IN LIGHT OF.
YOU KNOW THE- THINGS THAT IT'S
BEING. YELP CREATED OR- THE
FACT THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
USING THE TECHNOLOGY AND THAT'S
A FIGHTING CRIME AND ALL THAT
SO ARE YOU DISMISSING ALL THAT
YOU KNOW AT THE SAME TIME- I
MEAN I. IT BY HITTING THE PAUSE
BUTTON ARE YOU SEE SOME SIMPLY
SUGGESTING THAT WE SHOULDN'T
USE THAT AT ALL WHATSOEVER- YOU
KNOW YOU TO BUY A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR OTHERWISE. SO
YOU CAN'T BUILD A FACIAL
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM INTENDED
FOR CRIME FIGHTING WITHOUT ALSO
CREATING ONE THEY CANBE IS TO
STIFLE PROTESTS- ATTACK
IMMIGRANTS MONITOR PEOPLE JUST
GOING ABOUT THEIR DAILY LIVES
THAT THEY COME. HAND IN HAND-
BECAUSE IT'S THE TECHNOLOGY IN
THE SYSTEM ITSELF THAT ALLOWS
IT TO BE USED IN EITHER WAY AND
SO ONCE THE SYSTEMS ARE BUILT
THE HARM IS DONE AND SUPPORT.
SERIOUS ABOUT SOLVING THE WORST
CRIMES I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
RATHER THAN ASKING LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HANDLE EDITION
BUT ISSUES THAT WOULD BE BETTER
ADDRESSED BY PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS AND COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS. SUCH AS STOPPING THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF DRUG
ADDICTION CRIMINALIZATION OF
MENTAL ILLNESS AND POVERTY. AND
MOVING IN SAID TOWARDS A
CULTURE OF CARE THAT WOULD GO A
LONG WAY TO MAKING SAFE
COMMUNITY. WITHOUT INTRODUCING
ALL OF VERY REAL HARMS THAT
FEATURE RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
PRESENTS. ARE WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE FOURTH AMENDMENT COME INTO
PLAY IN THIS CONTACTS A- D. THE
VIEW THAT THE USE OF- F. R. T.
CONSTITUTE A SEARCH UNDER THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT. OUR IN IT IT
THE TO MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ITS STATE IMAGES TAKEN
OPENS THIS IS LOW. FIVE EIGHT I
SET YOU KNOW SETTING OR EVEN SO.
FOR THE PERRIN FOR INSTANCE.
I'M SAY THAT ADAM CURRY CASE I
WOULD INTO THAT THERE ARE DO IN
YOUR OF PRIVACY UNDER THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT DEPENDING ON
WHERE THE PHOTO WAS TAKEN YES
BUT I'M AS I'M WAS EARLIER SAID
BEING OUT PUBLIC DOESN'T FULLY
DIMINISH YOUR AN EXPECTATION OF
PRIVACY SO FROM YOU KNOW THE
WORK THAT I HAVE DONE ON THIS
ISSUE THERE IS A FOURTH
AMENDMENT- RIGHT AT PLAY THAT
MIGHT HAVE TO DEPEND ON THE
PARTICULAR CONTEXT IN WHICH
FACIAL RECOGNITION IS BEING
USED IN A PARTICULAR CASE IF
THAT MAKES SENSE AS FAR AS
WHERE THE PROBE PHOTO WAS TAKEN
FROM. I'M AND I WOULD JUST ALSO
ADD THAT FACIAL RECOGNITION
WOULD CALL INTO QUESTION A
PERSON'S RIGHT NOT TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT- WE HAVE THE RIGHT NOT TO
SAY WHO WE ARE BUT IF LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN JUST SNAP A
PHOTO OF US. RUN IT THROUGH A
DATABASE AND COME UP WITH THAT
ON OUR OWN THAT THAT WOULD
IMPLICATE THAT RIGHT- AND THAT
THAT SOMETHING THAT ALSO NEEDS
TO BE LOOKED AT. YEAH I SEE.
THE USE OF THE TECHNOLOGY IS-
CONTINUING SO TO SPEAK- I
THINK- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY- ARE
CURRENTLY. YOU KNOW THE
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT REGULATED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND ALL ON
THE OTHER EXTREME OF THE
CONTINUUM IS A COMPLETE. BAN OR
A MORATORIUM FOR EXAMPLE. IN
ALONG THE CONTINUUM DO YOU SEE
VIEW SOME KIND OF A YOU KNOW A
SPOT WHERE. IT IS MORE
REASONABLE- TO BE ADDED FOR THE
STATE OF FOR EXAMPLE I'M JUST
THROWING THINGS OUT. WHETHER
OBTAINING CONSENT OR NOTICE AND
OR NOTICE- TO THE PERSONS WHOSE
IMAGES BEING. CAPTURE WOULD DOT
ALSO ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS. ALONG THAT CONTINUUM
FOR EXAMPLE AND THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION AND ONE THAT
I THINK WOULD BE WONDERFUL TO.
PONDER AND DISCUSS WHILE WE
HAVE A MORATORIUM IN PLACE TO
PUT A PAUSE ON THE USE OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
UNTIL WE HAVE AN ANSWER- AS A
CALIFORNIA ON AND JUST TO
FOLLOW UP WHO WHO. WHO IS A
DINO WHO IS CONDUCTING ON THE
STATE EASE WHILE WE HIT THE
PAUSE BUTTON. ON TO SOME EXTENT
THAT DEPENDS ON WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDES TO ASK
SOMEONE TO- I KNOW THAT THIS IS
NOT AT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS BEING DISCUSSED IN CIVIL
RIGHTS AND CIVIL LIBERTY
ORGANIZATIONS AS TO WHETHER
THERE ARE ANY POTENTIAL
POSITIVE USES OR WHETHER THE
HARMS REALLY DO OUTWEIGH. ANY
BENEFITS- AND AS OF RIGHT NOW-
THERE ARE AND SIXTY PLUS
ORGANIZATIONS FROM- YOU KNOW
TRADITIONAL CIVIL LIBERTIES
ORGANIZATIONS TO IMMIGRANTS
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS RACIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS AND
OTHERS HERE SAID THAT THE RIGHT
THING TO DO IS TO EITHER HIT
POTS WITH A MORATORIUM OR DO AN
OUTRIGHT BAN THAT THAT IS WHERE
THEY SEE IT THE- APPROPRIATE
BALANCE. YOUR IMAGE IF THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS I WANT TO THANK THE
TWO LADIES FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE YEAH SO THAT BRINGS
US TO THE NEXT PANEL. I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME ALL FOURTH PANEL WHO
IS SPEAK TO THE ISSUE OF
CURRENT LEGAL FRAMEWORK AND
POTENTIAL NEED FOR. GOVERNMENT
REGULATION OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY. ARE
CATHERINE CRUMB. IS AN
ASSISTANT CRITICAL PART OF
CLINICAL AND SORRY CLINICAL
PROFESSOR OF LAW AND DIRECTOR
AT THE SAM HOUSTON LAW
TECHNOLOGY AND PUBLIC POLICY
CLINICS SHE'S ALSO CO DIRECTOR.
AT THE BERKELEY CENTER FOR LAW
AND TECHNOLOGY. ALSO JOINING US
ON MICHAEL MCLAUGHLIN RESEARCH
ANALYST AT THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATION
FOUNDATION- ALSO JOINING US IS-
MISTER ADAM SHORTS SO SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE-
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
AND FINALLY- WE HAVE MISTER
RYAN HARKINS SO SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF PUBLIC POLICY AT MICROSOFT-
WELCOME ALL OF YOU- PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SAYS. WELCOME
CAN WE START WITH SAY THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK AND THANK
YOU FOR HOLDING THESE HEARINGS
IT'S BEEN A FASCINATING RANGE
OF PERSPECTIVES ON THIS ISSUE-
SO I'M AN ASSISTANT CLINICAL
PROFESSOR AT BERKELEY LAW
SCHOOL MY NAME IS KATHERINE
COMP AND I DIRECT THE SAME AS
IN CLINIC FOR LAW TECHNOLOGY
AND PUBLIC POLICY. SO
SURPRISING ABOUT A CALL. THIS
ROOM ACTUALLY OF THE YEAR THERE
SOME PEOPLE BELIEVE THE
TECHNOLOGY SHOULD BE BANNED OUT
RIGHT MAYBE SOME PEOPLE FROM
THE POLICE UNION BELIEVE THAT
SELF REGULATION IS THE ANSWER
BUT I IMAGINE MOST OF US FALL
SOMEWHERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
QUESTION- MOST OF US ALL OF US
I WOULD SAY ONE AT THE CAPITOL
BECAUSE THAT SHOOTER TO BE
FOUND AND OFFICIAL RECOGNITION
CAN DO THAT- ALL THE BETTER. AT
THE SAME TIME I THINK YOU CAN
CONCEDE THAT POINT WHILE ALSO
BEING DEEPLY TROUBLED BY THE
USE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY- AND I'D
LIKE TO SPEND MY TIME- TALKING
PARTICULARLY ABOUT SOME OF THE
CIVIL LIBERTIES CONSEQUENCES OF
DEPLOYMENT OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES PRETTY IT
IMPACT ON THE- BEING IN PUBLIC.
AND THOUGH I WILL DO THAT IN
REFERENCE TO THE FIRST AMEND
RIGHT AT TWO ASSEMBLY AND THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT RIGHT TO
PRIVACY BUT OF COURSE YOU THE
CONSTITUTION MAY. OR WHAT THE
PROTECT OUR UP THAT SAID THE
CEILING AND THIS BY HAS NO ROLE
TO DETERMINING THE RULES OF THE
ROAD FOR USING THIS TECHNOLOGY-
SO. ONE OF REASONS WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSED TO IS WHAT IS A- DE
ABOUT THE USE OF FACIAL.
TECHNOLOGY I THINK MEMBER
OBERNOLTE WAS AT TALKING ABOUT
THAT- AND- EIGHT IT IS JUST A
VAST EXPANSION OF THE ABILITY
TO IDENTIFY PEOPLE WHEN THEY
ARE OUT IN PUBLIC. IT IS A HUGE
CHANGE IT IS TRUE THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN VIDEO. SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS IN PUBLIC PLACES FOR A
LONG TIME. BUT IN GENERAL NO
ONE LOOKED AT THE FOOTAGE RIGHT
YOU MIGHT LOOK AT THE FOOTAGE
IF FOR EXAMPLE A CRIME
OCCURRED- AND YOU'RE TRYING TO
IDENTIFY SOMEONE- BUT THERE WAS
NO PERSISTENT PERPETUAL
REVIEWING OF THE FOOTAGE. AND
IN LOOKING AT THE FOOTAGE
REQUIRED SOME EFFORT SOME
PEOPLE ARE FOR THIS HOSPITAL
REQUIRES TIME IT REQUIRES
COMMITMENT A LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES. AND FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY COUPLED
WITH ALGORITHM ALGORITHMS THAT
CAN ANALYZE FOOTAGE RAISE THE
PROSPECT OF BEING ABLE TO
IDENTIFY PEOPLE ON A FAIRLY
PERSISTENT BASIS IN PUBLIC
PLACES. AND FOR A PRACTICAL
MATTER THAT IS A RADICAL CHANGE
TO HOW WE ARE IN PUBLIC- IS THE
ESSENTIAL EXAMPLE COMES FROM
THE FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT. WE
HAVE A PERSON MEANT. I JUST
READ OF SPEED BUT ALSO TO SOME.
IN THE- AND- IN COURT HAS ROAD.
THAT AND THE RIGHT TO ACCESS
THESE RIGHTS ANONYMOUSLY. THE
QUINTESSENTIAL CASE IS THE NWC
TV ALABAMA CASE IN WHICH- THE
STATE OF ALABAMA ATTEMPTED TO
REQUIRE THE AND DOUBLE ACP TO
DISCLOSE ITS MEMBERSHIP. THIS
CASE DATED FROM THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES ANYONE WHO KNOWS
ANYTHING AT ALL ABOUT AMERICAN
HISTORY UNDERSTANDS THAT YOU A
DATE THE TO IDENTIFY YOURSELF
AS AN AND DOUBLE ACP. MEMBER IN
ALABAMA NINETEEN FIFTY WOULD BE
UNLIKELY TO JOIN AND THE
SUPREME COURT SAID THAT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT ENCOMPASSES THE
RIGHT. NOT JUST TO- EXERCISE
YOUR FREEDOMS BUT TO DO SO FREE
FROM HAVING TO DO SO PUBLICLY
AND THAT'S EXTENDED TO PUBLIC
PROTESTS AND IT IS SURE IT IS
TRUE TO BE SURE. THAT WHEN
YOU'RE OUT IN PUBLIC YOU MIGHT
BE INCIDENTALLY IDENTIFIED
RIGHT YOU COULD RUN INTO A
FRIEND YOU COULD RUN INTO A
NEIGHBOR YOU COULD DRAW THE
ATTENTION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES SOME HOW BUT IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT- I WAS
REALLY STRUCK BY- THE FIRST
PRESENTER SLIDER HE SHOULD AN
IMAGE OF A CROWD. WITH A LITTLE
YELLOW BOX AROUND EVERY FACE
RIGHT THAT AND WHEN ULTIMATELY
BEING ABLE TO NOT JUST
RECOGNIZE THOSE FACES WHICH IS
WHAT THAT SLIDE WAS ABOUT BUT
ULTIMATELY TO IDENTIFY THOSE
PEOPLE. AT SCALE IT
FUNDAMENTALLY. AND THE MOST
STRIKING EXAMPLE OF ALL OF THIS
WAS NOT A U. S. BASED EXAMPLE
BUT A HONG KONG BASED EXAMPLE
WHEN WE ARE WATCHING PROTESTERS
IN MASKS- GOING OUT TO PROTEST.
BECAUSE OF THEIR DESIRE TO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES BUT FEAR OF
THE CONSEQUENCES AND YOU CAN
SEE WHAT IS LOST AT POTENTIALLY
FROM THE PUBLIC SQUARE IF
PEOPLE- IT CAN'T GO OUT AND
PROTEST WITHOUT THINKING THAT
THEIR EVERY MOVEMENT IS. AT
EVERY IMAGE IS GOING TO BE
TRACKED- SO. THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS
ANOTHER QUESTION THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT IS WHERE TO
THE FOURTH AMENDMENT RIGHT TO
PRIVACY COME IN. IF THERE IS A
TO BE FREE FROM UNREASONABLE
SEARCHES AND SEIZURES. AND IT
TO THE MATTER. WE DON'T KNOW
HOW THAT PLAY PATIENT.
TECHNOLOGY ON THE HAND PEOPLE'S.
SAID TO HAVE A RIGHT TO HAVE A
SEAT IN THERE FOR. PARTICULARLY
PUBLIC. A THE OTHER HAND IN A
SERIES RECENT CASES THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT HAS BEEN
GRAPPLING WITH THE QUESTION. OF
TO WHAT EXTENT ARE DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGIES DIFFERENT FROM
ANALOG TECHNOLOGIES UP SO FOR
EXAMPLE. IT IS OFTEN CNCLUDED-
THAT THERE ARE MEANINGFUL
DIFFERENCES- IN A RECENT CASE
FOR EXAMPLE- THE SUPREME COURT
CONCLUDED THAT THE GOVERNMENT
NEEDED A WARRANT BASED ON
PROBABLE CAUSE. TO OBTAIN-
I'LL- SELL SITE LOCATION AT IS
IT PROBABLE CAUSE TO SEARCH THE
CONTENT OF AN ARRESTED PERSON
CELL PHONE. NOW THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE LAWYERS KNOW THAT
SEARCHING SOMEONE'S POCKETS
RIGHT IT'S SOMETHING YOU COULD
SIMPLY DO INCIDENT TO ARREST
WITH NO WARRANT WHATSOEVER JUST
BECAUSE SOMEONE HAS BEEN
ARRESTED. BUT THE SUPREME COURT
DECLINES TO EXTEND THAT TO
ALLOWING LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO SEARCH A CELL
PHONE. AND IT DID SO BECAUSE IT
THOUGHT. THAT SAYING THAT
SEARCHING POCKETS COMPARED TO
SEARCHING A CELL PHONE WAS LIKE
SAYING A RIDE ON HORSEBACK IS
IN DISTINGUISHES MATERIALLY
INDISTINGUISHABLE. FROM A
FLIGHT TO THE MOON RIGHT
THERE'S REALLY NO DIFFERENCE
AND THERE'S A VAST DIFFERENCE
IN TERMS OF PRIVACY INVASION.
OF GOING THROUGH SOMEONE'S
POCKETS AND GO THROUGH THE BILL
DECK. OF AND- SOMEONE ELSE
PREVIEW. SEC FOLLOWING SOMEONE
THAT MAY NOT IMPLICATE A FOURTH
AMENDMENT RIGHT READY
PHYSICALLY FOLLOW SOMEONE AND
SOME ARGUED THAT WHY THEN CAN'T
YOU SIMPLY OBTAIN SOMEONE'S
HISTORICAL CELL PHONE LOCATION
HERDS. AS WELL RIGHT THAT IS
ALSO- TRACKING EOPLE WHERE
THEY MOVE UP BUT THE SUPREME
COURT HAS SAID THAT THAT
ACTUALLY DOES REQUIRE OF FOURTH
AMENDMENT WARRANT- AND IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE DIGITAL NATURE
OF THE DATA- BECAUSE THE COURT
SAID THAT THE TIME STAMP DATA
PROVIDED INTIMATE WINDOW INTO A
PERSON'S PERSONAL LIFE.
REVEALING NOT ONLY HIS
PARTICULAR MOVEMENTS BUT
THROUGH THAN HIS FAMILIAL
POLITICAL PROFESSIONAL
RELIGIOUS AND SEXUAL
ASSOCIATIONS RIGHT THERE WHEN
YOU START TO BE ABLE TO TRACK
PEOPLE SPACES THE MAN HE
DATABASES ANALYZE I'M NOT YOU
ARE SIMPLY YOU KNOW A MOONS
LINK AWAY FROM OUR PREVIOUS
ANALOG WORLD IN WHICH YOU MIGHT
HAVE- INDIVIDUALS- LOOKING AT
ONE- ONE AT TANK DONE IF I. AN
SO GUTEN BEFORE. OF THE
CONSTITUTION PER A- OF
REGULATION AND NOT A CEILING
AND THE FACT THAT THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS ISSUE
PLAYS. AT PLAY DOES NOT MEAN
THAT THIS BODY SIMPLY WAIT FOR
COURTS TO RESOLVE THIS- THAT
TENDS TO TAKE A LONG TIME IT
TOOK THE COURT UNTIL- THE-
TWENTY TEN FOR EXAMPLE TO
DECIDE THAT A CELL PHONE-
RESEARCH TRIGGERS THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT WE DON'T WANNA RATE
AROUND FOR SIMILAR PERIODS OF.
TIME AND ALSO THE SUPREME COURT
HAS BEEN SEPARATELY SIGNALING
THAT IT WOULD VASTLY PREFER IT
LEGISLATORS RATHER THAN- THE
SUPREME COURT DECIDE THESE
TECHNOLOGY ISSUES AS- JUSTICE
LEADER REMARKED IN AN OPINION A
LEGISLATIVE BODY IS WELL SUITED
TO GAME. CHANGING PUBLIC
ATTITUDES TO DROP DETAILED
LINES AND TO BALANCE PRICE AND
HOW SAFETY IN A COMPREHENSIVE
WAY AND THAT IS OF COURSE OR
JOB HERE. THE ONE THING I THINK
YOU SO I TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT I THINK YOU SHOULD.
YOU AB WHICH FEELS I'M SURE
INVITE ME JUST THAT SO HERE I
AM THE ONE THING I. SHOULD NOT
IS TO. IS UNIQUE IN THAT IN THE
DAYS BE PERMITTED THIS REGULATE
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS I'M OF
RESEARCH. FOR BUT POLICE. WELL
PLACE TO MAKE VALUES TRADE OFFS
AND IT IS YOUR JOB TO DECIDE
HOW TO VALUE PUBLIC SAFETY
VERSUS PRIVACY VERSUS FREE
SPEECH AND WHERE THOSE LINE
SHOULD BE DRAWN- SO WHEN IT
COMES TO- REGULATION A FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY I THINK
REASONABLE MINDS CAN DIFFER
ABOUT WHAT WE DO- AND- BY THE
WAY. ALTHOUGH A MORATORIUM
SOUNDS EXTREME IF YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO ACT IN MORATORIUM HAD
TO ACTUALLY PUT IN DETAILED
REGULATIONS A MORATORIUM ME
SOUNDS LIKE A VERY GOOD IDEA.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THERE IS NO
STAYING STILL THIS DEBATE. IF
YOU DO NOTHING THIS TECHNOLOGY
IS SIMPLY GOING TO BECOME MORE
ENTRENCHED AND THEN IT IS GOING
TO BE EVER HARDER FOR YOU TO
REGULATE. BECAUSE LAW ENFORCER
THAT. LOT ON THIS TECH. IT THE
ARE YOU CAN THEN CUT AND
REGULATE IS WILL APPEAR EVEN.
RESTIVE SO. YOU MAY BE WILL
POSE NOW TO MAKE IT OFFICIAL
CONNECTION DATE BUT IF YOU SIDE
THAT FURTHER TIME IN EVOLUTION
OF TECHNOLOGY IS. A REQUIRED
THAT AT LEAST ONE LAW
ENFORCEMENT USES AND SO IT
WOULD BE BETTER PUT MORE
INTERNET PLACE OR MAINLY THE
WINDOW AND HIGHLY. THERE IS A-
AND IS POTENTIAL AND THAT IS
WHEN IT TO THE PERVASIVE USE
RECOGNITION TO IN PUBLIC PLACES
IT MAY BE THE AMERICANS ARE
PREPARE TO KNOW THAT EVERY TIME
THEY STEP OUT OF DOORS- THEY
COULD POTENTIALLY BE- MONITORED
WITHOUT SUSPICION- TO LOOK AT
PEOPLE'S FACES TO ENGAGE IN
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY CORRELATION
THAT AND IF THINGS. AREN'T
QUESTION REALLY A YOU KNOW AND
THAT'S A WITH RELATIVELY EASY
TO WRITE TO REGULATE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
THAT'S RIGHT IT MAY BE THE
FUTURE BUT IT IS NOT THE
PRESENT AND THEREFORE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO OPPOSE ANYONE'S
ENTRENCHED PROGRAM. I THINK THE
REAL QUESTION COMES- BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT NEVER USES WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUSPECTS A
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL WHO'S
BEEN CAUGHT ON VIDEOTAPE- HAS
BEEN- IT IS HAS BEEN SHOWN
ENGAGING IN A CRIME AND THEY
IDENTIFY THAT. AND THAT'S
LEGITIMATE USE THIS TECHNOLOGY
IN MY VIEW BUT IT SHOULD BE
REGULATED- AND- SOME OF MY
FELLOW LAW PROFESSORS FRIEDMAN
AND ANDREW. HAVE MADE A
PROPOSAL THIS IS I THINK IS
REALLY QUITE REASONABLE FIRST
OF ALL THEY THINK THIS
TECHNOLOGY SHOULD BE USED UNTIL
ISSUES A BIASED CAN BE WORKED
OUT THEY'RE NOT ISSUES A BIAS
ALREADY COUSIN IN POLICING. WE
DON'T WANT TO MAKE THINGS WORK
BUT THAT HARD. LAN FOR TO BE A-
TO. THEY WANT TO USE THE SECOND
IT'S NOT BANNED BUT YOU DO HAVE
TO GO TO JUDGE SO YOU HAVE A
PROBABLE CAUSE TO BELIEVE THAT
SOMEONE IS ENGAGED IN
WRONGDOING AND THAT USING THIS
PARTICULAR TECHNOLOGY WILL HELP
IDENTIFY SOMEONE HAS COMMITTED
A CRIME. A THIRD. THERE SHOULD
BE AS OTHERS HAVE SAID- OF.
REQUIRED THAT IT THAT THE CRIME
AT ISSUE BE A SERIOUS ONE THIS
IS EXACTLY WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID WHEN IT FIRST
IMPLEMENTED WIRE TAPS- IT
PASSED TITLE THREE OF THE WIRE
TAP LAW SAYING THAT YOU CAN
ENGAGE IN. WIRE TAPS BUT
BECAUSE IS THE PRIVACY INVASIVE
TECHNOLOGY YOU CAN ONLY DO SO
FOR THE NUMERATOR LIST OF
CRIMES THAT ARE PARTICULARLY
SERIOUS. ON AND FIND. OF IT AND
I THINK HERE I IN THE POLICE
UNION A THREE- THERE SHOULD BE
REALLY EXTENSIVE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY OR FIREMEN
SO THERE SHOULD BE PUBLIC
POLICIES WHAT THEY USE THEY
SHOULD OUTLINED THE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH THE
TECHNOLOGY WILL BE USED- AND IT
SHOULD BE AUDIT REQUIREMENTS
THAT YOU SHOULD KNOW WHO HAS
USED THIS TECHNOLOGY. AND IF
BEST. IT RESULT IN A MATCH I. A
VERY OFTEN POLICE TECHNOLOGIES
PROPAGATE- AND- USED- BUT WE
DON'T HAVE ANSWERS TO THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION WHICH IS
THIS ACTUALLY HELPING TO SOLVE
CRIME WE OFTEN HEAR LONG LIST
OF VERY COMPELLING ANECDOTES
ABOUT THAT HIS CELL PARTICULAR
CRIMES. BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER DO SOMETHING
SYSTEMATICALLY WE SHOULD HAVE
SYSTEMATIC EVIDENCE THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH CHAU. MISTER
MCLAUGHLIN. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
MCLAUGHLIN GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN CHAO WASTE YOUR KILEY
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
FISHER RECOGNITION IS IMPORTANT
TECHNOLOGY IS ALREADY PROVIDED
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS TO OUR
SOCIETY FOR EXAMPLE AS A
BELIEVE WE DISCUSSED EARLIER
THE TECHNOLOGY HAS HELPED
IDENTIFY IN LEE TO THE RESCUE
FROM CHAPTER TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS. INCLUDING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE BENEFITS ALSO
INCLUDE INCREASED CONVENIENCE
FOR CONSUMERS AND A TEST OF THE
LOS ANGELES INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT FISHER RECOGNITION
REDUCE THE TIME IT TAKES TO
BOARD A PLANE BY HALF.
NONETHELESS FISHER RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGIES ALSO MISS
UNDERSTOOD. THIS
MISUNDERSTANDING IS ONE REASON
WHY SOME OUR SOCIETY AKON FOR
FACIAL RECOGNITION BANDS.
IMPLEMENTING A BANNING
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE THE WRONG
APPROACH. TODAY LIKE TO FOCUS
ON THREE THINGS FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE PROTECTED FROM
POSSIBLE ABUSES OFFICIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY AND
SEVERAL WAYS INCLUDING BY STATE
LAW. THE US CONSTITUTION AND
SELF REGULATORY EFFORTS BY
INDUSTRY. SECOND I WILL OFFER
NUMEROUS WAYS LAWMAKERS CAN
FURTHER PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
FROM POTENTIAL ABUSES OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. THIRD I WOULD
DISCUSS WIDE BAND OFFICIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
TEMPORARY PERMIT IS NOT IN THE
INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
BACK TO MY INITIAL POINT. THE
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION IS CONSTRAINED IN
SEVERAL WAYS WHICH IS ONE
REASON WHY TARGET REGULATIONS
RATHER THAN BANDS IS THE BEST
PATH FORWARD. FOR EXAMPLE THE
NEWLY ENACTED CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT PROVIDES
CALIFORNIA'S NUMEROUS PRIVACY
RIGHTS BETWEEN THE COLLECTION
USE AND SHARING OF PERSONAL
DATA. INCLUDING IMAGERY OF THE
FACE. THE LAW REQUIRES
BUSINESSES TO INFORM CONSUMERS
OF THEIR COLLECTING PERSONAL
DATA CONSUMERS ALSO HAVE THE
RIGHT TO KNOW THE REASON WHY A
BUSINESS IS COLLECTING DATA AND
IF THE BUSINESS TO SOME OF THE
DATA AND TO HIM. BUSINESS IS
ALSO UP TO DELETE PERSONAL DATA
THE CONSUMERS REQUESTS AND
CONSUMERS CAN BLOCKING
ORGANIZATION FROM SELLING THEIR
DATA. COLLECTIVELY THESE RIGHTS
INCREASE THE TRANSPARENCY OF
THE USE OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
BY PRIVATE ACTORS. AND LIMIT
POTENTIAL ABUSES SUCH AS THE
UNWANTED SALE OFFICIAL
RECOGNITION DATA. AND LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA ALSO PASSED AB
TWELVE FIFTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS
THE BODY CAMERA ACCOUNTABILITY%
ACT THE ACT PROHIBITS LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM USING FISHER
RECOGNITION IN CONJUNCTION OF
BODY CAMERAS. IN ADDITION THE
US CONSTITUTION LIKELY PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT ABUSING THE
TECHNOLOGY. A. D. THE USE OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
TO SEVILLE AN INDIVIDUAL FOR
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME WITHOUT
A SEARCH WARRANT. IS LIKELY A
VIOLATION OF THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT. THE STATE OR PUBLIC
BECAUSE TO MAKE AN ARREST ALSO
PROTECTS CALIFORNIANS. FINALLY
INDUSTRY HAS DEVELOPED
VOLUNTARY SELF REGULATION AND
PRINCIPLES TO FOSTER FOSTER THE
RESPONSIBLE USE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. INDEED MANY OF THE
LEADING FISHER RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY VENDORS INCLUDING
GOOGLE MICROSOFT AND AMAZON.
HAVE DEVELOPED PRINCIPLES OUR
GUIDANCE FOR THE USE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY. MY
SECOND POINT IS THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN IMPLEMENT ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS TO PREVENT THE
POTENTIAL ABUSES. ARE OR
POTENTIAL MISUSE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. FOR EXAMPLE THE
STATE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
REQUIRE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES PUBLICLY DISCLOSED
THEY ARE USING THE TECHNOLOGY.
THE STATE SHOULD ALSO CAR THAT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ONE OF THE ROLE OF AN
AGENCY ESTABLISHED PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS FOR FACIAL
RECOGNITION SYSTEMS. STANDARDS
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT INCLUDING
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN YOU SPECIAL
RECOGNITION AND SENSE OF
ENVIRONMENTS SUCH AS AYE
PROTESTS. AND POLICIES FOR HOW
THE STATE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
CAN ACQUIRE AND SHARE PHOTOS
USED FOR FACIAL RECOGNITION. IN
ADDITION THE STATE SHOULD
REQUIRE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OBTAIN A WARRANT TO USE FACE
RECOGNITION. OR ANY TECHNOLOGY
TO TRACK THE LOCATION OF AN
INDIVIDUAL OVER AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME. FINALLY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD REQUIRE HAT
STATE AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES HAVE WRITTEN POLICIES
AND HOW THEY WERE USED THE
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS ENCOURAGE
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO POUT PILOT
THE TECHNOLOGY BEFORE
IMPLEMENTING IT. POUTING THE
TECHNOLOGY WOULD HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEARN A PARTICULAR
FISHER RECOGNITION SYSTEM
STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES. AND
ABOUT HOW PERFORMS IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. IF CALIFORNIANS
WERE TO SHAPE THE FUTURE OF
THIS TOP TECHNOLOGY SHOULD KEEP
A SET THE TABLE WHICH PILOTS
CAN HELP IT DO. MY THIRD AND
FINAL POINT. IS THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT REASONS WHY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD ADOPT
TARGETED LEGISLATION. FOR
FISHER RECOGNITION RATHER THAN
BAND THE TECHNOLOGY. FIRST MANY
CRITICS CONTRABAND STATE
MISLEADING RESEARCH TO BOLSTER
THEIR CLAIMS. FOR EXAMPLE THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
HAS PRODUCED TWO MISLEADING
REPORTS. THE ENACT WE SUGGEST
FACIAL RECOGNITION SYSTEMS ARE
ACCURATE. AND THE FIRST REPORT
THE A SO YOU USE AMAZON'S
RECOGNITION SERVICE. TO COMPARE
MUGSHOT IMAGES OF CRIMINALS TO
PHOTOS. OF MEMBERS OF THE
NIGHT'S IT'S CONGRESS. COVER
THE ACER USE THAT ARTIFICIALLY
LOW CONFIDENCE SPECIALS FOR
MATCHING FACES. TO CREATE THESE
RESULTS THAT MANY FALSE
POSITIVES WERE ALLOWED WHICH I
BELIEVE WE DISCUSSED EARLIER.
INDEED AMAZON HAS NOTED THAT
THE A STILL USE ERROR RATES FOR
MATCHING MEMBERS OF THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS WOULD HAVE
DROPPED TO ZERO. IF I TO USE AN
APPROPRIATE CONFISCATED SKEWS
ME APPROPRIATE CONFIDENCE
THRESHOLD OF 99% THE ACLU
REPEATED ITS TEST IN THE SAME
MANNER FOR CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS
EVEN AFTER AMAZON HAVE PUBLICLY
CLARIFIED ITS POSITION ON
APPROPRIATE COMP AND SOCIALS.
SECOND THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE
OF STANDARDS AND TECHNOLOGY HAS
FOUND THAT THE BEST FACIAL
RECOGNITION ALGORITHMS ARE
EXTREMELY ACCURATE. FOR EXAMPLE
THE BEST OUR THEM THIS TESTED
IN A TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
REPORT FILTERING THE CORRECT
CANDIDATE AS THE MOST LIKELY
MATCH ONLY ZERO ONE POINT 2% OF
THE TIME WHEN PERFORMING A
SEARCH OF A DATABASE THAT
CONTAINED. IMAGES OF THREE
MILLION INDIVIDUALS. THIRD THE
BEST FACIAL RECOGNITION SYSTEMS
HAVE NO OR LITTLE BIAS. IN THIS
REPORT. ACTOR ALBUMS HAVE
UNDETECTABLE BIASES-
UNDETECTABLE EXCUSE ME
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUPS. THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE THE
MOTIVATION FOR MANY OF THE
BANDS IS A CONCERN ABOUT RACIAL
BIAS BUT IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE FOR
THE BEST PERFORMING ALGORITHMS.
FOURTH FANS CAN HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR EXAMPLE SAN
FRANCISCO'S BAN A GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES USING FACIAL
RECOGNITION MEDIA LEGAL FOR THE
SEASON POINTS YOU CITY ISSUE
OUR PHONES WHICH USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION. FIFTH THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST TIME WE'VE HEARD
CLAIMS A TECHNOLOGY WILL LEAD
TO WIDESPREAD SURVEILLANCE FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
MANY PEOPLE FEEL TRANSISTOR
FEARED TRANSISTORS WOULD SPELL
THE END OF PIRACY AS MINIATURE
ELECTRONICS COULD BE USED USED
UP ON PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS.
AND IN THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS
PRIVACY ADVOCATES CALLED FOR
BANDS OF RFID CHIPS WE USE
RATED WHICH USE RADIO WAVES TO
TRANSMIT. DATA AND THE FEARS
THAT STORES GOVERNMENTS ARE
TERRACE TRACKING INDIVIDUALS
WITH RFID NEVER MATERIALIZED
MOREOVER JUST AS TRANSISTORS TO
NOT GIVE RISE TO WIDESPREAD
EAVESDROPPING NOW THEY WILL
FACE RECOGNITION WE TO
PERVASIVE SO UP SURVEILLANCE.
IN CONCLUSION. TARGET
LEGISLATION COULD ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA RECEIVES BOTH THE
BENEFITS OFFICIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY. WITHOUT TO PLAYING
RACIALLY BIASED TECHNOLOGY OR
SUFFERING UNDER A CHINESE STYLE
MASS SURVEILLANCE. BUT OFFICIAL
RECOGNITION BAND A MORATORIUM
LIMITS NOT ONLY THE NEGATIVE
USES OFFICIAL RECOGNITION BUT
ALSO THE POSITIVE USES A FACIAL
RECOGNITION. AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S GO TO MISTER SHORTS THE
NEXT. AND A CHILD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS A- OKAY. KILEY MY
NAME IS ADAM SHORTS I AM A
SENIOR LAWYER AT THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION. EFF IS A
NON PROFIT THAT WORKS TO ENSURE
THE TECHNOLOGY SUPPORTS
FREEDOM- JUSTICE AND INNOVATION
FOR ALL THE PEOPLE OF THE
WORLD. ON BEHALF OF OUR MORE
THAN THIRTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
FROM AROUND THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING THOUSANDS FROM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY THIS
AFTERNOON AT THIS VERY
pHEARD FROM A NUMBER OF
PANELISTS FACE SURVEILLANCE IS
PROFOUNDLY DANGEROUS. IT
INVADES OUR PRIVACY BY TRACKING
A UNIQUE MARKER WE SHOW
EVERYWHERE WE GO AND CANNOT
CHANGE OUR OWN FACES. THIS CAN
TURN OUR MOVEMENTS IN
ASSOCIATIONS AND OPEN BOOKS FOR
SCRUTINY BY BUREAUCRATS AND
BUSINESSES ALIKE TO SCRUTINIZE.
THIS DETERS SPEECH AND
ASSOCIATION IN PUBLIC PLACES.
AGGRAVATES ADJUSTING EXISTING
UNFAIR RACE DISPARITIES- THAT
PLAGUE OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. IT CAN BE USED AGAINST
IMMIGRANTS AND DISSIDENTS AND
WHEN FACE PRINTS ARE STOLEN AS
THEY OFTEN ARE IT OPENS UP TO
RISK OF IDENTITY THEFT. AND SO
EFS MESSAGE TODAY TO THE
CALIFORNIA. STATE ASSEMBLY IS
SIMPLE OUT WE REQUEST THAT YOU
BàN THE GOVERNMENTS USE A FACE
SURVEILLANCE AND THAT ADDS TO
PRIVATE SECTOR USE IF A
SURVEILLANCE THERE BE A
REQUIREMENT OF INFORMED OPT IN
CONSENT. BEFORE A BUSINESS YOU
CAN COLLECT SOMEBODY'S FACE
PRINT. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTRY ARE
BANNING GOVERNMENT USED TO FACE
OF ALEX WE'VE HEARD ABOUT-
HEARING CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO BERKELEY AND OAKLAND.
A FOR SUCH CITIES HAVE DONE
THIS IN THE STATE OF
MASSACHUSETTS. EFF IS WORKING
WITH ADVOCACY GROUPS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY- TO- ENCOURAGE MORE
CITIES TO DO THIS AND A PROGRAM
THAT WE CALL ABOUT FACE. AND SO
WE URGE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE NOT TO INTERFERE
WITH EFFORTS BY CITY LEADERS TO
PROTECT THEIR CONSTITUENTS
RATHER ANY STATE LEGISLATION
ABOUT THE SURVEILLANCE OUGHT TO
EXPRESS THE ALLOW CITIES TO
CONTINUE THIS IMPORTANT WORK.
AND ASH SHOULD NOT PREEMPTS
CITIES FROM DOING SO. WE ALSO
URGE THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
TO ENACT BASELINE PROTECTIONS
AND WE'RE OFF TO A VERY GOOD
START WITH LAST YEAR'S ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE FIFTEEN SPONSORED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG. AS
YOU'VE HEARD IT PLACES A THREE
OF FACE SURVEILLANCE WHEN USED
IN CONNECTION WITH CAMERAS WORN
OR CARRIED BY POLICE OFFICERS
AND PROVIDES A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION BY WAY OF ENFORCEMENT I
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE HERE
THAT. IF THERE'S GOING TO BE A
LAW- A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
IS TRULY THE BEST WAY TO INSURE
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE ALL TOO
OFTEN- AGENCIES CHARGED WITH
ENFORCEMENT. DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES. TO DO SO. THERE ARE
FOUR CRITICAL WAYS THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THIS AUGUST
BODY TO BUILD UPON. THE WORK
DONE LAST YEAR HE AND ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE FIFTEEN. AT FIRST
WHERE THE STE WE NEED A STATE
LAW THAT APPLIES TO ALL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND NOT
JUST TO A POLICE DEPARTMENTS
ALL THE GOVERNMENT'S USE OF
FACE SURVEILLANCE IS HAZARDOUS
TO PRIVACY FOR EXAMPLE STATE
DMV IS AS WE'VE HEARD HAVE AYE
AYES CONDUCT FACE RECOGNITION
ON DRIVER PHOTOS. FOR
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES. SECOND WE NEED A
STATE LAW THAT APPLIES TO ALL
TYPES OF GOVERNMENT USE OF FACE
SURVEILLANCE AND NOT JUST WHEN
USED IN CONNECTION WITH CAMERAS
THAT SOMEONE IS CARRYING OR
WEARING SO FOR EXAMPLE MANY
RESIDENTS OF SAN DIEGO OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT IMAGES THAT WERE
CAPTURED BY SMART STREET LIGHTS
YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY PAUL
CAMERAS. BEING USED IN
CONNECTION WITH FACED A BALANCE.
NUMBER THREE WE NEED A STATE
LAW THAT APPLIES NOT JUST TO
THE GOVERNMENT ITSELF USING ITS
OWN FACE RECOGNITION SYSTEM.
BUT ALSO TO GOVERNMENT
ACQUIRING INFORMATION DERIVED
FROM SOMEONE ELSE'S FACE
RECOGNITION SYSTEM SO FOR
EXAMPLE CLEARVIEW A AYE THIS
COMPANY THAT HAS GATHERED THREE
BILLION PUBLIC FACING FACES-
APPARENTLY ASSEMBLED A STORE
HOUSE OF THREE BILLION FACE
PRINCE. AND HAS GIVEN
INFORMATION TO TWO THOUSAND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AS WELL AS
PRIVATE. ENTITIES AND HAS DONE
SO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND TIMES
IN JUST A COUPLE OF YEARS. WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT ANY
LEGISLATION HERE APPLIES NOT
JUST WHEN THE GOVERNMENT USES
ITS OWN. FACE RECOGNITION BUT
WHEN IT ACQUIRES FACE
RECOGNITION SERVICES FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. GONNA PAVE IT
TO PRIVATE SECTORS USE OF FACE
SURVEILLANCE. WE ASK THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE TO ENACT
A LAW THAT REQUIRES A COMPANY.
BEFORE DIRECTING FACE
SURVEILLANCE AT A PARTICULAR
PERSON TO GET THAT PERSON'S
INFORMED OPT IN CONSENT. THAT
WE SHOULD JUST THE CALIFORNIA
CAN FOLLOW IN THE FOOTSTEPS OF
THE STATE OF ILLINOIS WHICH IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT ENACTED ITS
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION PRIVACY
ACT OR FERPA. WHICH AGAIN
REQUIRES. I'VE BEEN INTRODUCED
TO GET CONSENT BEFORE
CONDUCTING- FACE RECOGNITION OR
OTHER BIOMETRIC HARVESTING
UNDER THAT LAW. SOME CONSUMERS
MIGHT BELIEVE IT'S IN THEIR
INTEREST TO ALLOW THIS IS TO
COLLECT THEIR FACE PRINT FOR
EXAMPLE TO GET ON AN AIRPLANE
OR TO ENTER A BUILDING OR TO
UNLOCK THEIR PHONE. BUT WE
BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE UP TO THE
CONSUMER TO WEIGH THE PROS AND
CONS FOR THEM. OF DOING SO- IT
SHOULD BE THEIR OWN ECONOMIST
CHOICE FREELY GIVEN. AND IT
SHOULD NOT BE BUSINESSES THAT
ASIDE FOR CONSUMERS- WEATHER
APP THIS IS IN THE CONSUMERS
INTERESTS. TO BE CLEAR IT IS A
NOT ENOUGH WE BELIEVE. FOR
STATE LAW TO REQUIRE BUSINESS
SIMPLY TO NOTIFY CONSUMERS THAT
FACE RECOGNITION IS GOING ON
EITHER IN A PHYSICAL PLACE OR
IN A DIGITAL PLACE. THAT GIVES
THE POWER OF CHOICE TO THE
BUSINESSES AND NOT TO THE
CONSUMERS- EXCEPT IN THE NARROW
SENSE THAT CONSUMER CAN REFUSE
TO GO- ON THE INTERNET OR TO
PUBLIC PLACES WHICH WE THINK IS
REALLY. AT NO CHOICE AT ALL IN
IN THIS DAY AND AGE I DO WANT
TO. ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF RACE-
IN A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL AS
A PROFESSOR CRUMPETS SAID WE
HAVE FIRST AMENDMENT
ENFORCEMENT ISSUES. IN PLAY
HERE. EFF WAS SUGGESTED THERE
ALSO ARE FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT
ISSUES- NUMBER ONE. THERE ARE-
ARE EXISTING DISPARITIES IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM BASED
ON CENTURIES AND CENTURIES OF
MISUSE SUCH THAT MUGSHOT
DATABASES ARE MUGSHOT PHOTO
DATABASES ARE- OVER
CONCENTRATED WITH PEOPLE OF
COLOR- YOU KNOW WE ALL KNOW
THAT PEOPLE USE MARIJUANA AT
THE SAME RATES AND GETS- ALL OF
THE OR OR HIGHLY
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBERS OF
MARIJUANA ARRESTS HAVE BEEN. OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR COMPARED TO
WHITE PEOPLE. AND SO WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT A BUSINESS USING
FACE RECOGNITION TO IDENTIFY
EVERYONE WALKING IN THE DOOR
AND FIGURE OUT WHO THE
POTENTIAL SHOPLIFTERS ARE WE
ARE JUST AGGRAVATING USE
EXISTING DISPARITIES. MCCALLA
JUSTICE SYSTEM NUMBER TWO- OVER
TIME NEW TECHNOLOGIES HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYED DESPERATELY TO
MINORITY COMMUNITIES AND
APPLIED A DESPERATELY TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE STOPPED BY
POLICE WHICH OF COURSE-
DESPERATELY ARE ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT. POLICE USING FRN PEOPLE
THEY'RE STOPPING WERE TALKING
DISPROPORTIONATELY ABOUT DOING
THIS IN MINORITY NEIGHBORHOODS
TO MINORITY YOUNG MAN. NUMBER
THREE WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT
THE ERROR BIAS WHICH IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE- I WOULD URGE
THIS BODY TO LOOK AT THE WORK
BEING DONE BY JOY. GLOBAL ON
WE- WHO HAS MANY MANY STUDIES
ABOUT THIS- THE NEWEST REPORT
DOES SHOW THAT HAS SOME OF THE
ERROR IS GOING DOWN WITH SOME
OF THE SYSTEMS. IT ALSO SHOWS
THAT A LOT OF ERROR IS
CONTINUING WITH A LOT OF THE
SYSTEMS AND WE SHOULDN'T EVEN
BE TALKING ABOUT- GOVERNMENT
USE OF FACE RECOGNITION OR
BUSINESSES ARE USING IT WITHOUT
CONSENT WELL THOSE- ISSUES
LINGER. WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
EXONERATION NO DOUBT- THERE ARE
A LOT OF PEOPLE BEHIND BARS WHO
DON'T BELONG THERE AND WE
SHOULD DO IT WE SHOULD SOLVE
THOSE PROBLEMS BY GOING TO THE
ROOT OF THE PROBLEM SUCH AS-
HAVING BETTER FIGHTER.
DEFENDERS OR CHANGING THE RULES
OF EVIDENCE- REDUCING AMASSING
CARS XIN AS THOSE TWO I'M DOING
THIS KIND OF INDIRECT APPROACH
TO THE PROBLEM- BY THROWING
MORE TECHNOLOGY AT IT. I DO
WANT TO FINALLY JUST NOTE THE
PROBLEM OF MISSION CREEP YOU
KNOW WE'VE HEARD THE IDEA. THAT
WE CAN BEGIN JUST BY
IDENTIFYING A NOTE SUSPECT IN A
PHOTOGRAPH BUT WE WON'T SEE YOU
KNOW IT DANCE IT TOO- REAL
TIME- OR YOU KNOW DRAGNET
SURVEILLANCE AND COMMUNITY
PLACES. BUT WE'VE HEARD TODAY
ABOUT THE UPCOMING OLYMPICS IN
LOS ANGELES AS A REASON TO BE
DOING FACE SURVEILLANCE AND- TO
MY YEARS THAT SOUNDS LIKE
DRAGNET REAL TIME FACE OF ALICE
TO STOP A TERRORIST. YOU KNOW
FROM WALKING INTO A CROWDED
BUILDING WE'VE ALSO. HEARD
ABOUT AND RESTRICTING ARE USED
TO MUGSHOT DATABASES- ONLY TO
HEAR THAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT
USE OF- IMAGES ON SOCIAL MEDIA
AS ALREADY A CLEAR VIEW A I IS
DOING AND THOUSANDS OF POLICE
DEPARTMENT TO TAKING. ADVANTAGE
OF. SO IN CONCLUSION FACE
SURVEILLANCE IS ONE OF THE
SINGLE GREATEST THREATS TO OUR
DIGITAL PRIVACY WE ARE GRATEFUL
THAT THIS. THIS BODY IS
CONDUCTING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATIVE HEARING I AND
AGAIN. WE RESPECTFULLY URGE A
BAN ON GOVERNMENT USE AND
REQUIREMENTS ON- PRIDE THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO GET- INFORMED
OPT IN CONSENT BEFORE THE USE
OF FACE SURVEILLANCE. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM. ALL
ANSWER CHRIS. I APOLOGIZE. ARE
MISTER HARKINS I BELIEVE. THANK
YOU GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
MY NAME IS RYAN HARKINS I AM
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY WITH MICROSOFT AND ID
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
NO IS SITTING HERE LISTENING TO
ALL OF THE PANELS. IT STRUCK ME
THAT THIS IS YET THE LATEST
ITERATION OF A STORY WE'VE SEEN
PLAY OUT BEFORE. RAPID
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGES A CHECK
THAT BRING ALONG A WHOLE HOST
OF POTENTIAL BENEFITS. BUT THAT
ALSO CREATE A LOT OF DISRUPTION.
IN THAT CREATE A LOT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS
OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES FOR A LOT
OF THE VALUES THAT HAVE
GOVERNED IN OUR COUNTRY SINCE
ITS FOUNDING. CHALLENGES THE
PRIVACY CHALLENGES TO CIVIL
LIBERTIES CHALLENGES TO
DEMOCRATIC FREEDOMS. THESE ARE
CHALLENGES FRANKLY THAT WE'VE
FACED FOR OVER A HUNDRED YEARS.
AND THEIR THEIR CHALLENGES THAT
HAVE LED OUR COMPANY IN
PARTICULAR OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN PLUS YEARS. DAD FOR
REGULATION. THE STEP UP AN
ADVOCATE AS WE'VE DONE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE FOR
COMPREHENSIVE PRIVACY LAWS IN
THIS COUNTRY. MORE RECENTLY TO
CALL FOR REGULATION OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
BEEN CONTROVERSY. IT'S BECAUSE
SOME OF OUR FRIENDS IN INDUSTRY
TO CRITICIZE US FOR ASKING FOR
NEW RULES THAT WOULD APPLY TO
US AND ALL OF THEM. IT'S
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE. ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE IF YOU
WILL TO CRITICIZE US FOR
ADVOCATING FOR WHAT THEY VIEW
AS- WEAK REGULATION THAT WOULD
QUOTE LEGITIMIZE TECHNOLOGY. I
THINK THAT PRESENTS A AN
UNFORTUNATE MISUNDERSTANDING OF
OUR COMPANY'S POSITION AND OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO. AND MY
HOPE IS THAT THIS HEARING CAN
START MORE CONVERSATIONS AMONG
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS INDUSTRY
CONSUMERS GOVERNMENT'S
ADVOCATES. ABOUT WHAT THE RULES
OUGHT TO BE IN PLACE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
GET THE BENEFITS OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE FACE
RECOGNITION. WELL ADDRESSING
THE VERY SERIOUS CONCERNS THAT
THE TECHNOLOGY POSES. SO
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT FACE
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY IS
PROVIDING A WHOLE HOST OF
BENEFITS ANY AND YOU'VE HEARD
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES TODAY.
SECURITY I'M A MORE EFFICIENT
AND BETTER WAY TO ACCESS YOUR
DEVICE OR YOUR ACCOUNTS- IT'S
OFTENTIMES MORE SECURE THAN
SIMPLY RELYING ON PASSWORDS
IDENTIFYING MISSING CHILDREN
IDENTIFYING. INCAPACITATED
PEOPLE WHOARE IN NEED OF
ASSISTANCE IDENTIFYING VICTIMS
OF CRIMES. IDENTIFIED SUSPECTS
AT LARGE. THERE ARE ALSO OTHER
USES WE FOR EXAMPLE. HAVE A
PROGRAM CALLED SCENE A I. WHICH
IS BEING DEVELOPED BY A
SOFTWARE ENGINEER AT MICROSOFT
NAME SHEIK MOHAMMED IN THE U.
K. WHO LOST AS I SAID AT THE
AGE OF SEVEN. AND IT'S A
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD CONNECT TWO
GLASSES WITH A HIGH POWERED
CAMERA. WITH THEN SYNC UP TO
THE CLOUD. IN USING A AYE AND
FACE A RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
AND OTHER THINGS PROVIDE HIM OR
OTHER PEOPLE WITH VISION
IMPAIRMENT THE NARRATIVE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE WORLD
AROUND THEM. BUT BUT WE AGREE
WITH THE CONCERNS. THE CONCERNS
ABOUT BIAS IN THEM AND
DISCRIMINATION THERE ARE
ABSOLUTELY STUDIES AND IT DOES
NO ONE ANY GOOD TO SHY AWAY
FROM THEM THAT SHOW THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY IN MANY INSTANCES
HAS BEEN MORE ACCURATE FOR
YOUNG WHITE MALES THAN IT HAS
BEEN FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR THAN
IT HAS BEEN FOR WOMEN THAT BEEN
FOR OLDER PEOPLE. THOSE THINGS
SHOULD CONCERN ALL OF US.
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPLICATIONS FOR PRIVACY AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES WITH THE
CONTINUED DEPLOYMENT OF CAMERAS
IN PUBLIC SPACES. AND THE RAPID
IMPROVEMENT IN FACE RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGIES IT POSES REAL
CONCERNS ABOUT. SURVEILLANCE OF
THE PUBLIC. BASS A RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY SHOULD NOT BE USED
TO CONDUCT MASS SURVEILLANCE OF
THE PUBLIC. SO. THEIR CONCERNS
AS WELL ABOUT DUE PROCESS THESE
ARE CONCERNS FRANKLY THAT
RELATE TO THE USE OF A AYE MORE
GENERALLY PARTICULARLY A BLACK
BOX ALGORITHMS OUR ALGORITHMS
WHICH ARE VERY GOOD AT DERIVING
CONCLUSIONS FROM BROAD SETS OF
DATA IDENTIFYING PATTERNS FROM
BROAD SETS OF DATA BUT WHICH
AREN'T AS GOOD. AT TELLING US
HOW THEY ARRIVE AT THOSE
CONCLUSIONS. THOSE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS CAMPOS REAL CHALLENGES
IF THEY ARE GOING TO BE USED IN
CONJUNCTION WITH DECISIONS
ABOUT PEOPLE THAT WOULD HAVE
CONSEQUENTIAL AFFECTS OR LEGAL
AFFECTS ABOUT THEM CRIMINAL
JUSTICE THE PROVISION OF CREDIT
INSURANCE EDUCATION SECTOR. SO
HOW CAN WE START TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS. WELL MAKING
SURE WE ENABLE THE BENEFITS THE
TECHNOLOGY IS PROVIDING THERE
ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
COMPANIES CAN DO THEMSELVES. SO
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF CONCERNS.
THAT LED MICROSOFT FOR EXAMPLE
TO CREATE AN ETHICS COMMITTEE
WITHIN THE COMPANY. THE ETHER
COMMITTEE AND I ALWAYS BLANK ON
WHAT YOU THROUGH MEANS THE A.
I. IN ETHICS IN ENGINEERING AND
RESEARCH COMMITTEE IT'S AN
ETHICS COMMITTEE THAT CONSISTS
OF SENIOR MEMBERS ARE SENIOR
LEADERS AROUND THE COMPANY.
WHICH PRODUCED AND PUBLISHED A
SET OF ETHICAL PRINCIPLES THAT
GOVERN THE WAY WE DEVELOP AND
DEPLOY THE TECHNOLOGY. THEY
REVIEW HOW WE'RE DOING AND
WHETHER WE'RE COMPLYING WITH
OUR PRINCIPLES. DAVE USE THAT
TO TURN DOWN BUSINESS. WE FOR
EXAMPLE HAVE TURNED DOWN
PROPOSALS TO DEPLOY FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY ON
POLICE BODY WORN CAMERAS
BECAUSE WE THINK IT WOULD BE
UNETHICAL TO DO SO. THE
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT THERE IT'S
INACCURATE AND THE RISKS OF
GETTING SOMETHING WRONG IN THE
SCENARIOS IN WHICH IT WOULD BE
DEPLOYED ARE FAR TOO GREAT.
IT'S THE KIND OF THING THAT LED
US TO DEVELOP A SIMILAR SET OF
ETHICAL PRINCIPLES SPECIFICALLY
FOR FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY. BUT SELF REGULATION
IS NOT ENOUGH. NONE OF US
SHOULD BE COMFORTABLE WITH
RELYING UPON CORPORATIONS TO
REGULATE THEMSELVES AND MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISIONS IN THIS
SPACE THE TECHNOLOGIES TOO
POWERFUL THE RISKS ARE TOO
GREAT. AND FRANKLY NOT EVERY
ORGANIZATION WILL HAVE THE WILL
OR THE RESOURCES OF A PLACE
LIKE MICROSOFT. TO IMPOSE RULES
UPON ITSELF. WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
RECENT EXAMPLES PERHAPS OF THAT
IN THE PRESS AND FRANKLY. A
RACE TO THE BOTTOM IN AN
UNFETTERED MARKETPLACE BENEFITS
NO ONE. IT'S WHY WE HAVE BEEN
CALLING SINCE THE SUMMER OF TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
SPECIFICALLY FOR GOVERNMENT TO
STEP IN AND PASS LAWS. SO WHAT
SHOULD THOSE LAWS LOOK LIKE.
WE'VE SUPPORTED LEGISLATION IN
OUR HOME STATE OF WASHINGTON.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE WOULD
APPLAUD YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN INTRODUCING
AB TWO TWO SIX ONE WE'VE
SUPPORTED LEGISLATION IN OTHER
PLACES THAT WOULD REGULATE BOTH
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND THE
PUBLIC SECTOR IN THEIR USE AND
DEVELOPMENT OF TECHNOLOGY- OF
FACE RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY.
FOR EXAMPLE. WE'VE SUPPORTED
RESTRICTIONS ON THE PRIVATE
SECTOR RULES THAT WOULD REQUIRE
IT FOR EXAMPLE TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS OF BY SYMPTOMS AND
DISCRIMINATION BY REQUIRING
THEM TO TEST THE TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGY FOR BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION. BY REQUIRING
THEM TO ENABLE INDEPENDENT
THIRD PARTIES TO TEST THE
TECHNOLOGY FOR BY CENTER AND
DISCRIMINATION WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH. THE EIGHTEEN AN API AN
APPLICATION PROGRAMMING
INTERFACE OR SOME OTHER
MECHANISM TO ALLOW THIRD
PARTIES TO TEST THE TECHNOLOGY
NOT ALL COMPANIES DO THAT. BY
REQUIRING THEM. TO HAVE TO PUT
IN PLACE A PLAN TO ADDRESS ANY
CONCERNS ANY INACCURACIES IN
ERRORS AND BIASES PARTICULARLY
ERRORS IN BY A SEIZE ACROSS A
POPULATIONS- TO ACTUALLY PUT IN
PLACE PLANS TO START TO ADDRESS
THOSE THINGS. WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
THAT COMPANIES WHO HAVE EXPOSED
THEIR TECHNOLOGY TO INDEPENDENT
TESTING. TO THE SORT OF PUBLIC
SHAMING THAT FRANKLY WE WERE
PART OF WITH THE RECENT MIT
GENDER SHOULD STUDY. A STUDY
THAT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN TESTED THE GENDER
CLASSIFIER FOR VARIOUS- FACE
RECOGNITION ALGORITHMS AND
COMPARED THE ERROR RATES ACROSS
VARIOUS SUBGROUPS. FIRST SET OF
RESULTS WAS REVEALED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN AND- FOR
OUR OUT PROGRAMS FRANKLY THEY
WERE EMBARRASSING. THE ERROR
RATE FOR WHITE MEN WAS 0% AS
YOU MIGHT GUESS. THE ERROR RATE
FOR BLACK MEN WAS 6% THE ERROR
RATE FOR WHITE WOMEN WAS ONE
POINT 7% TO AIR IT FOR BLACK
WOMEN WAS TWENTY POINT 8%
ACCEPTABLE. IT EMBARRASSED OUR
ENGINEERING TEAM SO THEY GOT TO
WORK IMPROVING THE ALGORITHMS
AND SPECIFICALLY IMPROVING THE
QUALITY AND THE PROPORTIONALITY
OF THE DATA SETS THEY WERE
USING TO TRAIN THEIR ALGORITHMS
WE CAME BACK A YEAR LATER. THE
ERROR RATES WERE AGAIN 0% FOR
WHITE MEN POINT 3% FOR BLACK
MEN. POINT 3% FOR WHITE WOMEN.
IN ONE POINT 5% FOR BLACK WOMEN
NOT WHERE WE WOULD LIKE THEM.
BUT WE'VE SEEN DRAMATIC
IMPROVEMENTS AND WE'VE SEEN
THAT WITH RESPECT TO OTHER
TESTING AS WELL. WE'VE
SUPPORTED. RULES THAT WOULD
REQUIRE. SIMILAR TO WHAT MISTER
SHORTS IS SUGGESTING CONSENT IN
ORDER TO ENROLL AN IMAGE OPT IN
CONSENT IN ORDER TO ENROLL AN
IMAGE OR A TEMPLATE CREATED BY.
YOUR IMAGE AND A FACIAL
RECOGNITION DATABASE WE'VE
SUPPORTED OTHER RULES THAT
WOULD REQUIRE TRANSPARENCY THAT
WOULD REQUIRE FOR EXAMPLE A
PERSON TO BE IN THE LOOP. MEAN
FOR HUMAN REVIEW OF SOMEONE WHO
IS IN POWER TO CHANGE A
DECISION THAT MIGHT BE MADE
ABOUT AN INDIVIDUAL- FOR
SIGNIFICANT DECISIONS ABOUT
PEOPLE IF FACE RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY IS TO BE USED IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THOSE
DECISIONS. NAMELY DECISIONS
THAT WOULD HAVE CONSEQUENTIAL
ILLEGAL AFFECTS ON PEOPLE. AND
FRANKLY WE ALSO HAVE SUPPORTED
AND DO SUPPORT RESTRICTIONS ON
THE GOVERNMENT'S USE OF
TECHNOLOGY. RULES THAT WOULD
REQUIRE GREATER OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. REQUIRING
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES TO PRODUCE
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY REPORTS
BEFORE THEY PLAN TO USE THE
TECHNOLOGY DESCRIBING HOW THEY
WILL USE IT WHY ITS POTENTIAL
IMPACT ON A CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
REQUIRING ANNUAL REPORTS ON THE
GOVERNMENT'S ONGOING USE THE
TECHNOLOGY REQUIRING REPORTS
FROM JUDGES. ABOUT ANY WARRANTS
THEY ISSUE AUTHORIZING THE USE
OF THE TECHNOLOGY REQUIRING
DISCLOSURES TO CRIMINAL
DEFENDANTS. IF PROSECUTORS ARE%
GOING TO USE EVIDENCE GLEANED
FROM THE TECHNOLOGY IN TRIAL.
WE SUPPORTED OTHER SORTS OF
RULES GREATER COMMUNITY
PARTICIPATION. MANDATORY PUBLIC
NOTICE AND COMMENT PERIODS
BEFORE THE TECHNOLOGY CAN BE
USED BY AGENCIES RULES THAT
WOULD ADDRESS CONCERNS AROUND
BIAS AND DISCRIMINATION.
REQUIREMENTS FOR ON GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO TEST IT. IT FINALLY
AMONG OTHER THINGS RESTRICTIONS
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO
USE THE TECHNOLOGY. WE AGREE
THAT THERE ARE VERY LEGITIMATE
PUBLIC SAFETY USES OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. AND WE WANT LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BE ABLE TO USE
IT WHERE APPROPRIATE WITH
RESTRICTIONS IN ORDER TO DO
THEIR JOBS AND KEEP US SAFE.
BUT THE TECHNOLOGY IS.
POTENTIALLY PRONE TO ABUSE. AND
WE'VE SEEN AS AT OTHER TIMES IN
OUR HISTORY THE EXAMPLE OF WIRE
TAPS IS A GOOD ONE. POWERFUL
TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN GIVE THE
GOVERNMENT A WINDOW INTO
PEOPLE'S. ACTIVITIES THAT DID
NOT EXIST BEFORE. SO WE WOULD
SUPPORT AND HAVE SUPPORTED
RULES THAT FOR EXAMPLE WOULD
REQUIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT TO GET
A WARRANT BACK BY PROBABLE
CAUSE BEFORE USING FACE
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY TO
SURVEIL PEOPLE IN PUBLIC PLACES.
REQUIREMENT THAT SEARCH
WARRANTS ONLY BE AVAILABLE FOR
SERIOUS CRIMES. REQUIREMENT
THAT SEARCH WARRANTS ONLY BE
AVAILABLE UPON THE APPROVAL OF
SENIOR OFFICERS WITHIN A
DEPARTMENT OR CARMEN PERHAPS
EVEN OF NECESSITY. IN OTHER
WORDS IT A SHOWING. THAT LAUNCH
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS TRIED OTHER
METHODS TO COLLECT THE EVIDENCE
OR THAT THOSE SORTS OF METHODS-
WOULD BE UNREASONABLY DANGEROUS
ARE ON RECENTLY LIKELY TO
SUCCEED THERE ARE PRECEDENTS
FOR THESE KINDS OF RESTRICTIONS
IN OUR LAWS. THIS IS THE KIND
OF ARCHITECTURE THAT THE
FEDERAL WIRETAP ACT HAS LONG
APPLIED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
ABILITY TO OBTAIN WIRETAPS IN
ORDER TO CONDUCT SURVEILLANCE
OF SUSPECTS. THE OTHER THING
THAT OCCURRED TO ME AS I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THE HISTORY OF.
WIRE TAPS. YOU KNOW OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO. WE SAW A NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT. PROVIDED ALL
SORTS OF BENEFITS BUT ALSO
POTENTIALLY GAVE THE GOVERNMENT
A WINDOW INTO PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS THAT PEOPLE USED
TO BE ABLE TO HAPPEN THAT WAS
THE TELEGRAPH AND THE TELEPHONE.
AND WE SAW A LOT OF CONTROVERSY
AND UNEASE ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENT'S POTENTIAL. USE OF
WIRETAPS. SUPREME COURT IN THE
ARM SAID CASE IN NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN INITIALLY RULED
THAT THE GOVERNMENT DID NOT
NEED A WARRANT IN ORDER TO
CONDUCT WIRETAPS UNLESS IT
PHYSICALLY TRUST PASSED ON
SOMEONE'S HOME. THAT BECAUSE
THE MEDIA OUTCRY INFECTED
CAUSED CONGRESS A FEW YEARS
LATER TO PASS WHAT REALLY WAS
THE COUNTRY'S FIRST WIRE TAPS
STATUE NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR A
STATUE THOUGH THAT DIDN'T
REALLY FIX THE PROBLEMS OF THE
OLMSTEAD DECISION. IT TOOK THE
COURT FORTY YEARS. NOT UNTIL
THE CATS AND BURGER DECISIONS
IN THE SIXTIES TO FINALLY
OVERTURN HOMESTEAD AND HOLD.
THE AMERICANS HAD- A FOURTH
AMENDMENT RIGHT TO PRIVACY A
RIGHT TO BE FREE FROM
UNREASONABLE EXPECT OUR FROM
UNREASONABLE SEARCHES AND
SEIZURES IN THEIR PHONE CALLS
IN THAT GOVERNMENT COULD
VIOLATE THAT. WITHOUT
PHYSICALLY TRESPASSING IN A
HOME OR IN AN OFFICE. IN OUR
VIEW SOME OF THE RESTRICTIONS
THAT WE HAVE SUPPORTED IN IN
LEGISLATION ARE ENTIRELY
CONSISTENT WITH THE DECISION
THAT PROFESSOR CROP WAS
ALLUDING TO THE CARBON THAT
CARPENTER DECISION IN WHICH THE
SUPREME COURT HELD. THAT THE
GOVERNMENT NEEDS OF SEARCH
WARRANT BACK BY PROBABLE CAUSE
IN ORDER TO TRACK SOMEONE'S
LOCATION THROUGH THE PUBLIC
USING CELL SITE LOCATION
INFORMATION. WE THINK THE SAME
SORT OF PRINCIPLES AT MINIMUM I
TO APPLY TO THE GOVERNMENT'S
SIMILAR USE OF FACE RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY IN SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCES SO. WITH THAT I'D
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TODAY AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONIES AND WITHOUT THAT
LIKE TO OPEN A FOR MISTER
KILEY. YOUR QUESTION. I YEAH I
JUST A COUPLE CONCLUDING
REMARKS ON I THINK THE CHAIR
AND THAT COMMITTEE FOR WHEN I
WAS IN THIS AND THIS IS A VERY
HELPFUL DISCUSSION- I- YOU KNOW
A COUPLE TAKE AWAYS FROM ME ARE
AT. I THINK THAT. ANY TALK
RIGHT NOW OF THE CATEGORICAL
BANNER MORATORIUM- WOULD- WIPE
OUT TREMENDOUS. A SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC VALUE AND SO I WOULD
NOT FAVOR THAT IN FACT I THINK
THAT IF THERE ARE
MUNICIPALITIES THAT ARE
IMPOSING SUCH BANDS ABOUT. A
RATIONAL BASIS THERE MIGHT BE A
NEED FOR SOME LEVEL OF. OF
UNIFORMITY BUT- AT THE SAME
TIME I DON'T THINK IT'S ENOUGH.
TO SAY THAT IF YOU CAN MAKE AN
ANALOGY. TO AN EXISTING- HUMAN
PROCESS OR IF ALL WE'RE DOING
IS. ENHANCING THE CAPABILITY OF
A- OF A- HUMAN PROCESS THAT
THERE AREN'T DISTINCTIVE
PRIVACY CONCERNS I DO THINK
THAT- AT A CERTAIN POINT A
DIFFERENCE OF DEGREE BECOMES. A
DIFFERENCE OF. KIND FOR- SOME
OF THE REASONS THAT HAVE BEEN
STATED. BY HAVING TO DO WITH
SCALE OR MAKING SOMETHING-
SYSTEMATIC AND I THINK EVEN
WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK OF. AN
EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY- YOU
KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PUBLIC SURVEILLANCE ISSUE- YOU
DO HAVE A REASONABLE
EXPECTATION THAT SOMEONE MIGHT.
SEE YOUR FACE EVEN PERHAPS
SOMEONE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN
YOU STEP OUTSIDE YOUR HOME- BUT
PERHAPS YOU DON'T HAVE. A
REASONABLE EXPECTATION THAT
IT'LL BE- YOU KNOW- CAPTURED
AND ANALYZED AND IDENTIFIED.
AND STORES SO- I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE CHAIR- TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES IN A WAY
THAT- THAT YOU KNOW MAXIMIZES
THE UPSIDE WILL MINIMIZING-
THE- THE LEGITIMATE RISKS AND I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF BETTER FOR. DISCUSSION
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING AT IT I MEAN. A
COUPLE COMMENTS I HAVE WHAT
WILL BE FIRST SAY THAT I THINK
WE'RE ALL IN FURIOUS AGREEMENT
THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
SHOULD BE TACKLED.
LEGISLATIVELY AND I ACTUALLY
HAVE A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON
WHY THAT IS- I THINK THE COURTS
ARE SENDING US A SIGNAL THAT.
THEY REALLY DON'T HAVE A FIRM
JUDICIAL BASIS FOR TACKLING
THIS SOME IN THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT THE CONSTITUTION IS
NOT ABOUT PRIVACY IT'S ABOUT.
UNREASONABLE SEARCH AND
SEIZURES AND SO YOU KNOW THE
COURTS HAVE BEEN PUSHED FURTHER
AND FURTHER AND FURTHER KIND OF
OUT ON A LIMB THERE IN REALLY
THEY'VE GONE AS FAR AS THEY CAN
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT. THAT
YOU KNOW IS APPROPRIATELY
GOVERNED BY THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH OF NOT THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH SO I MEAN I THINK WE'RE
DOING THE RIGHT THING HERE AND
HAVING. THIS DISCUSSION- OVER
TO WILL ALSO WANT TO TALK JUST
TO TOUCH ABOUT SOMETHING WAS
SAID ABOUT THE NATURE OF THAT
AT A BECAUSE- I MEAN I THINK
THAT. THAT'S REALLY THE CRUX
OF. WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHEN WE ARGUE ABOUT PRIVACY
WHEN I TALK ABOUT DIGITAL
VERSUS ANALOG. THE REASON WHY.
THE COURTS HAVE RULED THAT YOU
NEED A SEARCH WARRANT TO SEARCH
SOMEONE'S PHONE IS BECAUSE
THERE'S INFORMATION IN THERE
THAT'S NOT AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC YOU KNOW YOU HAVE NOT
DISCLOSED IT. I MEAN I CAN'T
LOOK AT YOU AND KNOW WHAT YOUR
SEARCH HISTORY IS ON YOUR
IPHONE AND FRANKLY I DON'T WANT
TO KNOW. BUT YOU KNOW BUT- YEAH
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY IT IT
IT REQUIRES A WARRANT IS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT IT'S DIGITAL OR ITS ANALOG
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S- KIND
OF. AN INTERESTING THING ABOUT
FACIAL RECOGNITION IS THAT WHEN
YOU STEP OUTSIDE REALLY. YOUR
FACE IS THERE. I MEAN IF YOU'RE
HONG KONG YOU'RE GOING TO
PROTEST AND YOU PUT A MASK ON.
YOU'RE MAKING THE DECISION THE
DECLARATION. YOU KNOW I'M NOT
SHARING THAT INFORMATION OF.
WHAT MY IDENTITY IS. AND IF YOU
WALK OUTSIDE WITHOUT A MASK
IT'S AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT.
THAT YES SOMEONE MIGHT LOOK AT
ME AND RECOGNIZE ME AND I MEAN
I THINK THAT THAT'S- YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S A FUN. THE
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE. I ALSO
ONE OF VEHEMENTLY DISAGREE WITH
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN A SET A
COUPLE OF TIMES. I BELIEVE IT
WAS ON THIS PANEL. WHICH IS
THAT. THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE
CRIME SHOULD BE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT DISTINGUISHES
WHETHER NOT FACIAL RECOGNITION.
TECHNOLOGY IS APPROPRIATE. I
VERY MUCH DISAGREE WITH THAT. I
MEAN IF YOU ASK THE AVERAGE.
CONSTITUENT OF OURS. WHETHER OR
NOT. THEY THINK. THAT THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE THEIR
THEIR THEIR DOOR CAM. FOOTAGE
WHEN SOMEONE STEALS AN AMAZON
PACKAGE OFF OF THEIR PORCH. AND
GIVE THAT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT SO
THEY CAN IDENTIFY WHO DID IT.
AND PREVENT IT FROM HAPPENING
FROM SOMEONE TO SOMEONE ELSE.
YOU KNOW. 99% OF PEOPLE WILL
SAY YES. OKAY THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY ON THE LEAST SERIOUS.
AXIS OF THE WHOLE CRIME
SPECTRUM RIGHT. SO I MEAN I
REALLY I REALLY THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S SOCIETAL
BENEFITS THAT. COME FROM THIS
THAT. DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH SERIOUSNESS OF CRIME. BOB
AND I ALSO WISH. AND THIS IS
PROBABLY IF YOU'LL HOLD BUT I
MEAN I WISH WE COULD DIVORCE.
THIS KIND OF PHILOSOPHICAL
DISCUSSION OF THIS ISSUE FROM.
SOME OF THE VERY EMOTIONAL
TOPICS THAT WE WRESTLE WITH AS
A SOCIETY. AND BIASES A GREAT
EXAMPLE. YOU KNOW WHEN WE SAY
BYPASS. I MEAN I THINK THAT
CONFLATES. AN EMOTIONAL BY US
ON THE SENSE IN THE SENSE OF A
PERSON. YOU KNOW WITH. A IRAQ
AN INACCURACY FOR AN ALGORITHM
RIGHT OR IT'S NOT FAIR TO SAY
THAT THE ALGORITHM IS BIASED.
WE CAN SAY THAT THE ALGORITHM
HAS A DIFFERENT- SUCCESS RATE.
FOR PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT
ETHNICITIES THAT BE CORRECT NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
KNOWLEDGE. AND WE NEED TO WORK
ON. BUT IT'S AN IMPROVEMENT
OVER. OUR WHAT WE HAD IN THE
PAST WHICH IS KIND OF
UNACKNOWLEDGED. HUMAN BY US.
RIGHT SO IT'S ACTUALLY BY BY
HAVING AN ALGORITHM DO IT AS
LONG AS WE'RE CAREFUL ABOUT IT
WE'RE ACTUALLY MOVING. IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. I SAW IT I
THINK GOINGON HERE. IT'S BEEN
SAID A COUPLE TIMES IN THIS
ROOM TODAY THAT. FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY
THREATENS THE SAFETY OF
IMMIGRANT. COMMUNITIES RIGHT
BUT WHAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOW HERE. IS NOT. THE
ALGORITHM WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
DISAGREEMENT OVER FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAW AND WHAT SHOULD
BE ENFORCEABLE WHAT SHOULDN'T
BE THAT'S- THAT'S A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT TOPIC. THE SOLVING OF
FINALLY JUDGE THINK. ARE AGREE
WITH MR KILEY ABOUT THE FACT
THAT IT. OFFICIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY HAS A LOT OF
BENEFICIAL USES YEAH I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT I MEAN FIRST OF
FIRST OF ALL I THINK IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT FOR US NOT TO
POINT ON THIS ISSUE IN PASSING
A MORATORIUM WOULD BE PROJECT.
RIGHT WERE SAY ONE TO THROW THE
BABY OUT WITH THE BATH WATER
AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DISALLOW ALL THE
BENEFICIAL USES AS WELL AS THAT
IS THE NON BENEFICIAL USES I
THINK INSTEAD WE NEED TO DO A
VERY CAREFUL AND STUDIED
ANALYSIS OF. HOW THIS
TECHNOLOGY COULD BE ABUSED AND
I MEAN IF YOU GO OUT ON THE
LONG AXIS OF ABUSE RIGHT HOW
COULD IT BE ABUSED WELL IF THE
GOVERNMENT NEW. EVERY TIME-SOMEONE WENT INTO A PUBLIC
PLACE EXACTLY WHO THEY WERE AND
WHERE THEY WENT IF THAT RECORD
WAS AVAILABLE ON A CONTINUAL
BASIS YOU KNOW THROUGH ALL OF
THE YEARS OF SOMEONE'S LIFE THE
GOVERNMENT COULD USE THAT TO
IDENTIFY DISSIDENTS- TO STIFLE
FREE SPEECH IN WAYS THAT HAVE
DONE BEEN DONE ELSEWHERE IN
HUMAN HISTORY BY AUTHORITARIAN
REGIMES. THAT'S TERRIFYING
RIGHT THAT IS WHAT TRYING TO
AVOID HERE. OKAY BUT TO SAY
WE'RE GOING TO BAN FACIAL REST
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY ALL
TOGETHER BECAUSE WE'RE AFRAID
OF THAT OUTCOME IS LIKE SAYING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE
AFRAID THAT PEOPLE OCCASIONALLY
WE'LL GET INTO FATAL CAR
ACCIDENT AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
PREVENT ANYONE FOR PRIVATE CAR
RIDES IT EXHIBIT BRUTICUS
EXAMPLE BUT ESSENTIALLY
PHILOSOPHICALLY THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING. INSTEAD I THINK WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON HOW THE USES
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY CAN GO WRONG.
AND PREVENT. THE GOVERNMENT USE
OF THAT TECHNOLOGY IN WAYS.
THAT THAT THAT LEAD TOWARDS
THOSE OUTCOMES. RIGHT THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING HERE
AND IT'S GONNA TAKE A LOT OF
TIME IT'S GOING TO TAKE
ENGAGEMENT BY. ALL OF US ARE
ALL OUR VARIOUS USER
COMMUNITIES- AND IT'S GOING TO
TAKE- Y'ALL A LOT OF HEARINGS.
AND A LOT OF DELIBERATION BUT
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO GO. SO
ARE YOU KNOW TO THAT AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR CONVENE HEARING- THIS IS
EXACTLY THE KIND OF DIALOGUE
THAT WE NEED TO BE HAVE. HAVING
ON THIS TOPIC AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND-
INDENTURES OF TIME I I'M GONNA.
JUST THERE PROBABLY CONCLUDE.
BY THANKING ALL OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE INCLUDING ALL THE
OTHER PANELISTS WHO PRESENTED
THE EARLIER- IN LET ME JUST ASK
MY- COLLEAGUES I MEAN. THIS IS
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY
FASCINATING TOPIC. OF ALL OF
THIS AND ALL I THANK YOU FOR
EDUCATING OTHER MEMBERSHIP
HERE- BECAUSE THIS SOMETHING
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO KNOW WE-
WE WANT TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
TECHNOLOGY AND YOU GUYS ARE IN
THE TRENCHES YOU KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING ON IT. SO IT'S
BEEN. EXTREMELY HELPFUL TO US
TO UNDERSTAND THE TECHNOLOGY IN
AND WHERE WE SHOULD GO GOING
FORWARD THE FROM THIS POINT. SO
I WANTED ENGAGE- TOM BOB MANY
OF YOU AFTER THIS HEARING IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU. N. O. YOU
DO PRESENT A YA YOU HAVE
PRESENT A LOT OF. OUR GREAT
INPUT THAT WE WANT TO FOLLOW UP
ON. TO IF IT'S AN OKAY FOR YOU
FOLKS THAT WE LIKE TO CONTACT
WITH YOU ALSO. SO WITH THAT I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE. AND I THINK WE'LL JUST TO
HAVE TO OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AS WELL I DO HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS BUT I'M GONNA SAY
THOSE QUESTIONS FOR LATER. SALE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE SO. WITH THAT UP. LET'S GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO LIKE TO. MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS PLEASE. FEEL FREE TO
DO SO PLEASE. BEHIND. I AM
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF ALSO
BEFORE YOU DO. THANK YOU YES
GOOD EVENING AHEAD HERE NO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
GRANT WARD I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
C. BUT THE SEARCHERS SIMPLY
BENEFITS ASSOCIATION SAMAEL
COUNTY. I WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT
BY THE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
OF SAMUEL COUNTY FROM FROM
THERE- ELECTED TO BE THE
PRESIDENT OF SCALE THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA Y. SALON FORSMAN. I
HAD THE DISTINCT HONOR WITHIN
MY CAREER OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
LAST TWENTY TWO YEARS. AS A
DEPUTY FOR THIRTEEN YEARS
DETECTIVE FOR SIX YEARS AND
SERGEANT FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS. I WILL TELL YOU THAT MY
JOB IN NINETEEN INTENSE ARE TWO
THOUSAND. AND NINE. THE
CHRISTIAN TWO THOUSAND. ELEVEN
TO TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WAS TO
RESEARCH ASSESSED BY METRIC
TECHNOLOGIES FOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SAN REMO COUNTY AND
IMPLEMENTED. A MOBILE
EDIFICATION PROGRAM. FOR LAS
VEGAS METROPOLITAN POLICE
DEPARTMENT. I WILL TELL YOU
THAT THERE WAS A LOT OF-
INACCURACIES WERE BETRAYED BY
THE BY THE PANELISTS- THE HERE
HOWEVER. A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
POINTS THAT WERE RAISED. THAT
COULD ABSOLUTELY BE SERVED BY
REGULATION. REGULATION IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE I WILL TELL
YOU- WITH HOW FRAZIER
RECOGNITION WORKS- THAT IT DOES
OPEN THE DOOR FOR CERTAIN
ABUSES. AND WE WANT TO PREVENT
THAT I WILL TELL YOU IN MY
COUNTY SPECIFICALLY. IS THERE
ARE THERE IS A MECHANISM TO
PREVENT THOSE ABUSES IN ITS
ONLY USED BY THOSE IT'S A
MINUTE TO. A REGIONAL.
INTELLIGENCE DIVISION
INTELLIGENCE DIVISION TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT- IT RISES TO THE
LEVEL OF SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE. RENTERS FACE
RECOGNITION. THE IT'S ONLY
PERFORMED BY ACTUAL EXPERTS
THAT KNOW THE LIMITATIONS AND
THE CAPABILITIES OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. IT BEFORE A RETURN
IS PROVIDED. AND THE CONFIDENCE
LEVEL IS NOT ONLY BY KAMALA
COME FROM MY COMPUTER BUT IS
CONFIRMED BY A PERSON. BEFORE
THAT DETECTIVE OR THE DEPUTY IS
PROVIDED WITH THE RESULT. I
WILL TELL YOU IT HAS SOLVED
NUMEROUS. CRIMES OVER OVER THE-
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS. SINCE
THAT HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY ALONE- IN
TWO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE IS POINT. A YOU DON'T
WANNA LIMITED JUST TO SERIOUS
OFFENSES BECAUSE THAT THAT
DOESN'T SERVE THE COMMUNITY SO
BEFORE I GOT INTO. BY METRICS I
WAS IN CHARGE OF A RETAIL
THEFT TEAM IN THAT ORGANIZED-
WHO WILL THAT WE WERE. BUT I'M
IN CHARGE OF. COMBATING
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME IN HIGH
LEVEL IDENTITY THEFT CRIMES SO.
FOR RETAILERS IN THAT IS THAT.
IS A HUGE HUGE. TOOL FOR THE IN
IT'S REASONABLE FOR THOSE THAT
WANT TO GO OUT AND PROTEST TO
SAY. I EXPECT MY PRIVACY AND
THAT'S REASONABLE- IT BUT FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S GOING TO ACTIVELY
COMMITTING A CRIME IN TRYING TO
VICTIMIZE THE PUBLIC. THEY
SHOULD NOT HAVE THE SAME
EXPECTATION THAT THE POLICE OR
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE
ABLE TO USE ANY RESOURCE THEY
CAN'T TO TRY TO. BRING JUSTICE
TO THE VICTIMS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THAT. I HAVE
TALKING POINTS FOR ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT THEY WERE
MISREPRESENTED BUT IN THE
REFERENCE OF TIME I WILL BRING
IN. SOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT YOUR-
TESTIMONIES OR YOUR INPUT. TO
US IN WRITING IF YOU SO DESIRE.
AND WE'LL BE SURE THEY LOOK AT-
THEM AS WELL IT ALSO BE
APPROACHING EACH COMMITTEE
MEMBER IN TE FUTURE LETTING
YOU KNOW. EXACTLY HOW WE REALLY
USE THE TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU. NEXT
UP PLEASE. I THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON FEELING READS THE
VANCE MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. I JUST WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS THAT- FACE USE OF
FACIAL RUSSIAN RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY. APPLICATIONS IN
HEALTH CARE SPECIFICALLY IS
JUST IN ITS BEGINNING PHASES
WERE JUST STARTING TO. FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE PROMISE OF IT
COULD BE- JUST A FEW EXAMPLES
THINGS LIKE PATIENT SAFETY
FROM- FALL OF AB
MISIDENTIFICATION OF PATIENTS-
PREVENTING OPIOID DIVERSION-
EMOTIONAL- RECOGNITION AND
THINGS LIKE THAT RECOGNIZING
PAYING MORE ACCURATELY THAN.
HUMAN BEING MIGHT BE ABLE TO-
JUST A FEW EXAMPLES SO WE JUST
WANNA REMIND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
LEGISLATURE THAT ARE IMPORTANT
APPLICATIONS. IN HEALTH CARE IN
THE FUTURE. AND THAT'S IT AVAIL
GIVE HIM THE QUESTION IF YOU
TAKE VERY MUCH. THANKS PLEASE.
A LITTLE SHORTER ALL RIGHT ERIC
SABATINI ON THE CALEDON MANAGER
FOR LACK CHRIS LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SO- I ALSO HAD A FOUR
MINUTE SPIEL AND I'M GONNA CUT
IT DOWN JUST AS LIKE A BUNCH OF
QUESTIONS- ONE THING I THINK
THAT REALLY NEEDS TO BE.
CLARIFIED IS THE USE FOR
SURVEILLANCE AND THE USE AND
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS TWO
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THINGS
FISH RECOGNITION IS NOT
SURVEILLANCE IT'S A TOOL THAT
CAN BE USED IN SURVEILLANCE.
BUT IT IS NOT SURVEILLANCE IN
ITSELF I THINK THAT WAS ONE OF
THE THINGS IS KIND OF MUDDY THE
WATER A LITTLE BIT. THE OTHER
THING IS FACE RECOGNITION IS
NOT SOMETHING NEW. IT'S NOT
SOMETHING NEW IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IT'S BEEN PART
OF A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
SENSE IF YOU WANT TO GO BACK TO
ORGANICALLY TILL THE WANTED
POSTER. RIGHT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THAT SOMEONE NEEDS TO BE A-
THE SUSPECT HAS TO BE
IDENTIFIED IN COURT. IT IS
PROBABLE CAUSE THROUGH THE
INVESTIGATION THAT IDENTIFIES
AN INDIVIDUAL IS NOT A MACHINE
OR DEVICE THAT SPITS OUT A
PICTURE. AND SAYS THIS IS YOUR
GUY GO ARREST THEM. SO I THINK
THAT ALSO HAS BEEN KIND OF
ELUDED TO IN IN THIS
REPRESENTED HERE. I WANT TO
OFFER LACK CHRIS IN OUR
ASSISTANCE IN HELPING YOU GUYS
CREATE AND WORKING WITH
EVERYBODY WE'VE BEEN LIKE I
SAID WE'VE BEEN IN TALKS WITH
THE ACLU SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN
SO IT'S NOT LIKE WE WERE NOT
WILLING TO DO THAT- AND IF
ANYBODY WANTS NO JUST GO TO OUR
WEBSITE LACKS DOT ORG AND YOU
CAN SEE OUR POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES THAT ARE ON THE WEB
PAGE GOING. THROUGH YOUR
QUESTION SO- DO WE USE RING
DOOR ABOUT SO CRIMINAL EVIDENCE
THERE'S ALSO SOMETHING NEEDS TO
BE CLARIFIED TO IS THERE'S-
EVIDENCE. REGARDING CRIMINAL
OFFENDER RECORDS. AND THAT'S
THE ONLY THING THAT THAT. IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS USED FOR
LONG FOR FACE RECOGNITION
INVESTIGATIONS THERE ARE RULES
THAT GOVERN IT THE DOJ AUDIT
TO. SO THERE IS EXISTING LAWS
IN PLACE FOR CRIMINAL OFFENDER
RECORD INFORMATION SO THERE
THERE I GOVERNMENT'S ON ON
TH<c.cyan> FACE RECOGNITION IS USED</c>
TO THAT- THE OTHER THING IS
EVIDENCE SO. YOU KNOW DO USE
RING DOORBELL INFORMATION YES
WE DO USE SO SAYS A PRIVATE
PERSON LEGALLY IF WE'LL
ILLEGALLY OBTAINED EVIDENCE BE
AT. A SOMEONE'S. SURE THE GUY
WHEN THEY CALL PORTS PIRATE
STEALING SOMETHING OFF THE
PORCH RIGHT THAT'S ILLEGALLY
OBTAINED PIECE OF EVIDENCE
WITHIN RUN AGAINST THE CRIMINAL
OFFENDER RECORD DATABASE. AND
THEN IF WE GET LEADS ARE
GENERATED THERE'S NO
IDENTIFICATION AND THAT
INVESTIGATION PASSED IDENTIFY
THAT INDIVIDUAL. SO THERE'S
ALREADY PROCESS IN PLACE AND
IT'S ALREADY BEING USED LIKE
THAT. BUT IT'S ALSO SAID THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S IMPLICITLY BY A
STORE TO BUY A STRAIGHT AND I
ACTUALLY WANNA MAKE THE
ARGUMENT AND THE EXPERTS CAN
CAN WEIGH IN ON THAT. IT'S
ACTUALLY THE OPPOSITE. HUMANS
HAVE BIASES WE'VE HAD INSTANCES
WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL- RUNS A
PERSON MALE HISPANIC AND
ACTUALLY ENDS UP THROUGH.
BECAUSE THEY'RE TRAINED AND
GOING THROUGH PAST PRACTICES OF
GOING I NEED A LITTLE LIMIT
THIS AND NARROW IT DOWN. PERSON
LOOKS LIKE- MALE HISPANIC I'M
GONNA SEARCH MALE HISPANICS
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW IT WAS DONE
IN THE PAST. WHEN YOU HAD TO GO
THROUGH MANUAL BOOKS OF BOOKING
PHOTOS. AGAIN THIS IS NOT NEW
PROCESSES THIS IS EXISTING
PROCESSES WELL WE'VE USED USED
IN THE PAST WEEK- MANUALLY
THROUGH THROUGH BOOKING PHOTOS.
NOW YOU HAVE SOMETHING THAT
AUTOMATES THAT. THAT PROCESS
WHICH ALLOWS YOU TO INVESTIGATE.
CRIMES OF LESSER SIGNIFICANCE
BECAUSE NOW YOU HAVE THE- THE
ABILITY TO DO SO WHERE WOULD
TAKE NUMEROUS MAN HOURS YOU
WOULDN'T DO THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A BUNCH OF STUFF AND WE
CAN TALK ABOUT IT SOME MORE AND
PROBABLY IN A BETTER PLACE BUT-
I. JUST WANT TO LET EVERYBODY
KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
NEW AND IT'S BEEN SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AS SIMILARLY IF FEEL
FREE TO SUBMIT ANY TESTIMONIES
YOU MAY HAVE A TO US IN WRITING
AS WELL. SO WITHOUT DOUBT I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU AGAIN
FOR BEING HERE- FOR THOSE- WHO
TRAVEL- LONG DISTANCE I THINK
YOU PARTICULARLY- AND I'M TRULY
GRATEFUL SELL US WITHOUT THAT
YOU KNOW I WE DO WANT TO
CONTINUE A DIALOGUE WITH YOU IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU. AND
WITHOUT THAT THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE.